[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
a candidate has become the challenger at
the v-day candidates in madrid spain
with victory out of reach for all but
one the battle for second heated up
american hikaru nakamura won his game
defeating yang christophe duda to secure
seoul second place after dominating the
field tournament victor ian napomiaji
will now prepare to battle it out for
the world championship title against
reigning world champion magnus carlson
the final round of the 2022 v-day
candidates coming up next
[Music]
good morning everyone happy independence
day america and welcome to our live
coverage of the 2022 candidates
tournament from madrid spain we are in
the 14th
and final round and we have a champion
and therefore a challenger good morning
yes sir how's it going it's last day can
you believe wow a marathon
it's over everybody nepo has won the
competition he is now officially the
challenger to the world champion magnus
carlson
and the question is will magnus defend
his title if he doesn't
the fight for second place is
all-important
dorset how is the standings and about
this fight for the second place well
uh nepo has won he's good to go he is
good to go now there is a huge fight
between the second uh for the second
place between our seats number two and
three
because they're actually playing
together today naka has seven and a half
points ding has seven points and one of
those two will be
silver in this tournament no question
about it baby and timor can not catch
them and our format dorsal
[Music]
and by the way of course once again uh
here is our champion so uh young nepal
from well
russia
has won the candidates officially she
will be playing in a match in 2000 um in
2023 with who we'll know hopefully soon
and he has also won
48 000 euros plus some money from the
other
points
so that will be that will be a lot of
money certainly more than a hundred
thousand oh yes and now our format
today is uh oop never mind we have an
eighth player double round ribbon and
today is officially our last round so no
playoffs that's that's good to go
exactly and we have 120 minutes for the
first 40 moves 60 extra minutes for the
next 20 moves and a final 15 minutes and
30 second increment for the rest of the
game no draws before black's 40th move
and once again a half a million euros in
prize money and we're very fortunate to
have on studio alejandro to drill down a
little bit deeper about this fight for
second in the all-important match-up
today alejandra good to see you my
friend good morning yasir good morning
doris happy independence day everybody
and of course you've mentioned it yasser
it's all about this fight for second
place now the tournament it's over jana
pomnyachi is the winner but will magnus
defend his crown let's see this fight
between two players hikaru nakamura and
day loren they're the only players that
can obtain sakura they're playing
against each other which is why this
match is so relevant seven and a half
points for ricardo gives him the lead
this is the current head-to-head they
had a draw in round six in the first
half of this event lots of draws between
these two players i know that favors
chicago fans as hikaru is the only
decisive win between these two players
in classical chess let's take a look at
how dingley red got to this position he
had a miserable first half of the event
starting with the loss against the
underpants with the white pieces but the
bounce back in the second half was just
incredible take a look at those wins in
rounds 9 10 and 11 that included two
victories with black against richard
brackford and fabiano caruana only to
get destroyed by timur rajab of their
that big fat goose egg in round number
12 has him half a point behind hikaru
because let's take a look at the line
score of the america and he also started
badly with the loss against fabiano
carrana but his bounce back was
immediate beating team rajabov in round
two and his second half has simply been
magnificent wins in round eight in round
ten that included a grind down against
fabiano caruana and a great victory
yesterday against yan shisht of duda has
him half a point ahead of dingley wren
we know that he covers a very solid play
with the black pieces i'm sure a draw is
all he is looking for the chinese
superstar has to go absolutely all out
to claim second what a great fight we
have in our hands to finish the
tournament guys absolutely thank you
alejandro for that and dorsa set the
stage for our audience and tell us about
the pairings for round 14. of course
so we're gonna have some fun chess
between
rapport and regiable followed by another
fun chess round wow caruana phiros jenna
those two are not as important for our
standing but they're still they're still
very high level chess exactly baby
versus perugia that could be a very
exciting game and then the all-important
of course the key match-up for the round
is ding versus nakamura
and then the big question can nepo go
undefeated remember
the previous candidate yes yes he
previous candidate he he was in similar
situation he was already secured to win
and the last round he kind of lost a
little bit to ding i believe right a
little too much celebration in advance
and can duda pull off a victory and give
him as
alejandro just described it a goose egg
but it's all about
um
ding laren putting some pressure in the
opening on hikaru
and then
for ding fans
grinding it out i noticed alejandro in
the head-to-head
you had one victory
for hikaru could you
remind our audience
where that victory was it just didn't
come to my mind immediately where did
hikaru beat thing well they did draw
here in the previous uh matchup on round
six and uh it's also good to keep in
mind that with the draw naka does go
away absolutely absolutely all naka
needs is a draw but when did he win uh
alejandro
i'll have to ask var akovia there at the
truck to help us out with that one or
the internet i don't i just call yeah me
either i just had this blank
when you were showing that head-to-head
and i was thinking to myself
was it
so we're being told that syncfield cup
26 i have no memory of this game he car
was beating the ranks field cup of 2016.
that's the one
that wesley won right 16. okay
so not a lot of decisive i have to look
this up now i have to go and look at
that i have no idea what is
dingler and going to do to press hikaru
today he's been a d4 player
traditionally and i think that he's
going to employ some kind of d4 he's not
a super sharp
let's go get them type of d4 player he
likes this positional approach to chess
with the white pieces he's being
employing this e3 rubenstein nimzo
indian in this tournament i would be
surprised if he doesn't go into these
lines
we're told uh thank you a big shout out
to verruzian by the way uh who who works
so very well with the production staff
and feeds us this information a moscow
variation
a moscow variation i guess of the slav
defense with bishop h4 we'll have to
look that one up but now having said the
rubenstein variation the nimzo indian
i mean that loss to timor
left the bitter taste in ding's mouth
he's not going to repeat that line oh
he's pretty stubborn the thing about
dean loren as a player he's a very
stubborn player that wants something
fails but is part of his repertoire he
just patches it up and fixes it and goes
on to the next game so i wouldn't be
surprised if he doesn't lose faith in
the variation just thinks it's a good
line that he misplayed uh remind the
viewers uh of the line that he played
against timor it was a nimzo indian
right with e3
and then
came uh bishop b4
uh c3 e3
um was it with an immediate d5 or
castles first
i think it was with d5 but i don't think
it matters okay
and it was like a c d e d bishop d3
castles
three bishop pier
queen
and somehow it was like this early
knight a6
that threw
um ding lehren off his stride and he
never got
really anything out of this opening
where if you were gonna guess
where do you think he's gonna deviate
well yes sir if i knew i think yeah
i think dealer would be hiring me
you're willing to uh
give it a guess well we got day four
o'clock in the morning do you want to
refute your car nakamura's repertoire
yeah let's give it a try
uh i'm not really sure i mean dangler as
i said likes to stick to d4c4 he hasn't
played e4 this event right so i don't
think he's brought it for the candidates
i i don't think that these players are
just finding new stuff to do especially
trying to break down the berlin in the
middle of the event i do expect d4 i
don't think the english has particularly
self-ding ran well he lost to nepo he
got nothing against alireza drew that
game as well so i don't think the
english is going to be his weapon of
choice that's his secondary idea uh d4
has i would say it looked vulnerable for
hikaru but it is the most predictable
part of his repertoire
d4 was played on the board by the way
and uh speaking of names on indian so in
um
in like i want to say like 21 between
2400 level
that nimzo with f3 is just so tricky and
painful
so i just wanted to get your guys's
opinion because
there's also uh
if i'm not mistaken one of the club
very strong club players here caleb the
nba national master plays that's nimzo
indian f3 and man it is hard to beat him
exactly i remember i went to bond
germany uh for the match between
vishwanathan and nand
and vladimir kramnik and that was really
debated that whole line with knight c3
bishop b4
the two players really
went deep into these
these uh really sharp and dynamic lines
that continued like with d5
and so really take a look at those games
and then you know kind of get a an idea
of where you want to go in that line of
the nim so by the way we do we did i'm
gonna just uh sure refresh my board but
we did have a different approach we had
stubborn you said uh alejandro but not
so stubborn
uh this time around no knight c3 but
knight f3 d5 knight c3 now
i i must say that uh hikaru
he mixes things up and he could play the
this uh neo vienna he can equally play
queen's gambit declined he's played that
on numerous occasions
and here with the move c c7 c5 he's
intimating that he's willing to play uh
this kind of um
i could guess we could call it atarosh
it's called the semitar semi-terror yeah
the second irish which has become
extremely popular exactly at this level
of chess
so many players have been playing this
line as black and
maybe anticipating that hikaru was going
to play c7 c5 very quickly came became
e2 e3
and now we can go back into our dusty
library
and i used to play the black side of
this variation
very well in my opinion i i a lot of my
opponents really did not understand the
subtleties of the move a7 a6 and why in
this exact position i chose it i would
get very very good games literally the
queen's gambit accepted variations with
the knight having been committed to
knight c3 uh knight c6
and now a2 a3
and the players have quickly
reached this position bishop d3 a bit of
a rarity the main move certainly is
castle
d takes c4 certainly not the way that
most people handle this variation most
people play
something else including the move a6
directly the movie takes c4 is a bit
rare exactly a7 a6 directly remember a
game that
tony miles defeated
walter sean brown and a very important
olympia at game as white
uh
in this line takes on c4 i agree with
you ace takes on c4
bishop takes c4 a7 a6 and now that the
knight has already committed itself to
c6 it's not exactly the setup i want as
black i'd like bishop b5 bishop b7 and
knight d7 okay so
it could be one of those isolated queen
pawn positions where both sides are
still jockeying
for
their setups i mean a7 a6 i think is
more useful than a2a3 but that's just my
my uh taste uh for the matter it's quite
interesting i'm seeing naka here and
he's just looking up i don't know how
familiar ever yeah my our viewers are
but naka's expressions but whenever he's
like trying to figure out what he's
trying to do he just looks up he's
trying to remember he's trying to
remember
so he's having that right now just
looking up trying to remember his lines
and it's quite interesting for me
that um
well he just made his move
wow
looking into the sky yeah i remember my
first time i ever played a seal ivan
you know for five hours he was looking
at the ceiling and he was calculating
everything is in his head
five hours into the game i began to look
at the ceiling
what the heck was up there was there a
screen or something we'll keep an eye on
that on this game as uh we do have more
moves
bishop d3 b7 b7b5 on the board and like
you say hikaru
just going through the files in his mind
any trickies here
alejandro
because there is
a potential
for the pieces along the c file well we
do have d take c4 d takes c5 bishop
takes c5 on the board uh what's our
theoretical
uh oracles tell us about this position
almost no games here yasser no games
only four games in the database this
idea of playing bishop d3 before
castling rather unique i think that if
you castle you transpose back into some
positions but perhaps the best way of
playing here at the end just want to go
b4 immediately the bishop always has
this choice right go to a7 go to e7
normally you go to e7 when this pawn is
still on e3
that's what the engines recommend is
best and the question is that will white
have anything to do
for an advantage with a little bit of an
initiative that you get what is the
initiative based on the extra tempo that
you have in the center you are a temple
office white it means that in this
completely symmetrical structure you
might be able to get in a trick you
might be able to get a knight e4 in
before your opponent gets 95 this kind
of little details that will allow white
to get an advantage for example i don't
know something like castle you have to
figure out if 94 works with the idea
that if you take take somehow this
pressure on this diagonal does something
it goes to a very much tempo by tempo
position in which
it's all about this one move whether
dingley wreck can get some initiative or
not out of the opening the next few
moves i think are rather crucial because
either ding gets a little something or
nakamura just completely equalizes the
position this is the nature of this
symmetrical pawn structures now speaking
of the symmetrical pawn structure i want
to get your take well you dink is in a i
need a win situation so
how do you feel about that because
symmetrical pawn structure is
very as you said it's like there's few
moves you're going to get something or
you're going to go home with a half a
point so
what do you think about his opening
choice alejandro
well uh still early right we have to see
where it gets us
i'll base the opening choice based on
how both sides handle it still there's
so many ways that both players can do it
no i don't think there's anything
particularly wrong with going to a
symmetrical pawn structure in a must-win
situation it's just depending on how you
handle it afterwards do you have the
prep in to get your opponent into an
uncomfortable position these players are
so strong that you get a bit of an
uncomfortable set of pieces and that
might be enough for them to take a point
right wonderful thank you
yeah it's hard uh these days to get any
kinds of advantage
against these extremely well-prepared uh
candidates um but i'm with alejandro on
this it's it's the attitude that you
bring into the game that you're gonna
you not necessarily get a huge opening
advantage but what you are going to do
is you know show this incredible
determination
like magnus does and you know try to get
an advantage against your opponent i
want to turn our attention to our
winner uh nepo as he
he is black against duda today and he
came into this event saying look guys
my number one defense is going to be the
petrov defense i'm going to play it
you guys try to figure out how you're
going to get an advantage and when
richie committed suicide
uh nepo's uh choice of uh the petrov
never appeared so good
i mean he's doing well he's got a plus
score with black of course i have to say
i did enjoy the game that fabi did
against nepo with the knight h4 yes yes
i thought that was quite fun but
unfortunately it just didn't
give fabi the full point it was close it
was very close he got the edge so uh
he
nepo is really laying down the challenge
to the entire chess world and say
show me how you're going to beat me
if i play the russian defenses very
solid russian offense duda and his team
you know has been working on this
problem not just for today or yesterday
but
for you know the months prior to the
candidates and dude replaces with black
but me duda plays this with black
also yeah absolutely d4
takes
takes now in the old days bishop d3 was
the automatic move here
that they would attack and now they
would consider you know moves like
knight takes e5 for example but
these days
takes
is
the choice which i think
you know the older guys were kind of
reluctant to do because
they they didn't consider
the pawn on e5 as being
an advantage and rather it could easily
be um
a liability in the sense after the move
d7 d5 if
it was what if it was black to play
pardon me right here right now the move
bishop c5 would simply be a very good
position for black so that was why
this position
was not popular in the 80s and 90s now
after the knight d2 the next move looks
really peculiar
queen d7
but
i
remember this has some very interesting
history and i think nepa was the guy
who came up with queen dc queen d7 first
alejandro am i right about that
uh first i'm not sure who came up with
queen d7 first right but it was played a
few times
uh let me see
i want to say that it was fabi i see
fabi has few quite a few games i don't
know who came up with this first but i
remember the first time i saw this game
uh this move was because favi showed it
to me back in 2018.
he thought it was a very interesting
idea we prepared this for we were
supposed to play tennis and instead we
ended up preparing this the entire
afternoon and then he used it against v2
when one uh i remember that about this
variation so who did it first i don't
remember but i think fabi was the first
one at the top
that played it at that level
uh kind of a borrowing a page from the
french defense it looks very
very peculiar to step in front of the
bishop and you might think to yourself
well gee i should just be developing my
bishop and developing my knight and i
should be playing a move like bishop f5
but there are very concrete reasons
why
you don't want to be walking into tempos
like knight to d4 and
conversely what looks like a very
desirable and normal move bishop e6 runs
smack into
captures captures queen takes king takes
knight g5
and suddenly oops
there are issues that black is facing so
this move queen d7 essentially
puts the kibash
on knight takes e4 because
now
black is simply fine he can just
recapture and he's ready to
equalize easily with the move knight
takes e5
so after queen d7 bishop d3
knight c5 uh this would be
what we might call a strategic howler
all you're doing
ask yourself why are you helping your
opponent right
right yeah exactly you don't you don't
want to do that and the move knight c5
uh returns the favor and asks the bishop
well are you going to
remain there
no bishop e2
huh and the players are actually still
following the dictates of theory
right to this moment rook
excuse me
spoiler alert uh rookie one um alejandro
jump right in uh that move
looks uncommon
well it's never been played before but
there's not a lot of games in this
variation to begin with the the move
queen d7 is not that popular there's
nothing actually wrong with knight takes
d2 it's the main line of the position oh
shoot really yeah i i hate that move i
despise knight takes d2 but go ahead
it's okay knight c5 is also quite common
bishop e7 is fine knight c7 knight c6
has been played plenty but queen d7 the
thing is this whole variation is just
not very popular at the top level uh
and the move rookie one already has not
been played but it's a logical move and
i think that duda still has prepared up
to this position just play the move
bishop d3 without thinking about it
uh try to test the structure a little
bit for network the engines are liking
developing with the knight to c6 i think
it's very logical somehow they like the
move rook d8 first think it's a little
bit more accurate what is white going to
do they're trying to put the pawn on c3
hide the bishop on c2 play knight g3
knight f5 you can see the attack brewing
on the king side you see the long-term
potential for duda on this side of the
board where's the counter play it's
going to be these two pawns actually
rushing down the board there's not that
much that will stop a pawn that goes to
d4 and then to d3 you might need to
block it with the bishop but the bishop
itself might be vulnerable
fascinating struggle here it's a
double-edged position black is going to
have some issues developing this bishop
on c8 is going to take some time while
you develop that bishop i'm going to
develop my initiative on the king side
so
still a lot of work here for young to
prove full equality i like this little
prep from duda
i have to say yeah me too i for me like
going bishop d3 bishop e2 bishop d3 is a
little out of my comfort level i don't
think i would do it if i didn't prepare
it but i like that attack it's a nice
king side attack you know um if i can
start going um queen up bishop c2
a little checklist battery and
knight g3 to f5 yeah that pawn on e5 is
really nicely has kicked away that's
knight on f6 i i like it the more i see
it the more i'm like ooh this might be
do this
happy ending for this tournament
maybe uh this moves bishop d3 back to e2
back to d3 um
would a move for example like b7 b6
get engine approval uh alejandro in the
sense that i want to just trade off this
light squared bishop if i could that
would kind of be
a dream
uh are we gonna would we see in that
case something
like
the following
and if so
uh how does the engine evaluate
the setup well the bishop going to c2
is not that necessary right you're
kicking me to f5 okay see why you
wouldn't put the bishop here because it
pins the knight immediately you might
want this knight coming to f5 but if you
can immediately put the bishop there
more power to you right because knight
c6 knight g3 you you start hinting that
knight g5 is an actual threat in this
position
so not don't put the bishop on c2 if
you're going to put your bishop on a6
put it on f5 that's much more dangerous
uh b6 is not approved at all by the end
not approved no no rook d8 or knight c6
are the move so it doesn't want to trade
the light squared bishop why because it
just can't do it the bishop will hide it
either on f5 or on c2 so don't go around
chasing it okay and of course we have
our our big names match up uh between
uh fabi and ali reza i mean prior to the
tournament you look at these pairings
and every pairing is a tough one no
question about it but you might look at
this pairing today
from three weeks ago and go hey you know
this could be a pairing that could
potentially decide first place because
bobby's a favor
you had to consider ali reza the number
two seat coming into the tournament as a
pre-tournament favorite and you would
think that this game is going to be a
huge clash
and
again maybe determine the outcome of the
of the events uh not what happened at
berlin quite unfortunate for
poor el erisa true
and the players are playing into a
rather popular variation king h1
um a clear indication that white is
playing for f2 f4 breaks
boy i thought there were more moves no
but that i guess that's about us
next next
they're still in uh they're they're prep
okay what's next that that leaves
timor's game right
as the last game
richie versus t moore and guess what
another berlin i have to say i do like
to set up everything on the sixth string
d3
sorry d3
come on
bishop c5 a repeat of the
how come my
sorry my
computer's keyboard is being tricky yeah
my keyboard's not moving look at that
how about that okay uh bishop takes c6
uh d takes c6
knight d2 just the game we've previously
seen
and instead of the knight d7
um
from that game we have
bishop e6
castles
isn't this where knight b3 was
sorry
isn't this where knight b3 was tried
earlier in the tournament i have the
feeling that this was a fobby game
uh
richard
yeah with knight g5 right
okay bishop to d6
knight to b3 richie
has his ideas c
five and i think we're up to date with
the players uh alejandro what's the
theoretical uh verdict on this line
i'm not sure what you mean with verdict
this hasn't been reached before
has not no takes takes knight bd2 bishop
e6's fine castles and bishop d6 is a bit
rare but everybody here plays
different moves knight b3 is one of them
c5 is the novelty as far as i can see
plenty of moves have been played here
bishop g4 castle queen e7 a5 b6
everything's been tried just not c5 so
this is why ritchie i guess is thinking
maybe teamwork's not familiar with the
position either
it's just a berlin you can play any move
and you're gonna be okay it doesn't
really matter which move order you do or
which variation you actually choose as
long as you have the understanding of
where the pieces go
there's different approaches to the
berlin which is what makes it such a
flexible opening for black
c5 is one of many moves in this position
it looks very logical to me you just
grab more space b6 is coming
absolutely this bishop yeah it's a
little trash on d6 it looks like a big
pawn but big pawns defend good pawns
including c5 and e5 and the more the
position opens up the better it's going
to look for the bishop in the long term
so you're not worried about this bishop
for the time being eventually becomes
good
and
the question will be for white
how do you put pressure on black's
position with a knight on b3 against the
spot on c5 the engines want to go knight
a5 which is a very typical idea in this
position we've seen it over and over
again in the tournament the idea is to
tether something to the defense of the
pawn take advantage of the fact that b6
is not possible because knight c6 is a
double attack against the queen and the
pawn on e5 but if you don't play this
move knight a5 right away maybe black
themselves goes a5 to kick out that
possibility from white actually the move
a5 is being seen in this position as
well a lot of people have played this in
this fashion including a certain linear
dominance against lemonade uh dominguez
won that game after move queen e1
hinting that knight a5 is going to be
played anyway so tons of games have been
played in this position knight a5 as i
was mentioning has been played by
richard rapport of these players are
very well familiar with the ideas and
structures in the berlin so knight a5 on
the board the engine is like white a
little bit but usually i don't pay too
much attention to what engines say in
the berlin this early in the game
fair thank you alejandra for that and
let's jump back into the game uh that we
think is all important this huge fight
for second place between ding liran and
hikaru nakamura we left it
pretty much just about here we just had
castles there should be seven bishop v2
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
no no no no i'm just going to mention i
remember if we left that questioning is
naka going to go bishop a7 or bishop e7
and oh yes right here after b4 i think
you're absolutely right so this was the
big moment of choice do we retreat to a7
uh do we retreat to e7
if we retreat to a7 we do leave
the e7 square open
maybe
making the move queen e7 more playable
but e7 was the choice castles bishop b2
and now this is
white has the move
he has his like if this bishop was
actually on the d6 square we'd be
talking about an identical situation
so white has the move and he has uh his
bishop on a slightly more active square
how do you parlay that into some kind of
advantage well
you really want to play the remove rook
d1
quickly as quickly as possible so move
like queen e2 with the ideas of rook d1
rook c1 come to mind i don't think
that's going to be good enough for an
advantage i can imagine queen bee one
it's kind of one of those sneaky moves
that you want to get in because you're
you're tickling the pawn on
on h7 and as alejandro said a moment ago
you can get in 94. like let's just put a
maybe a poor choice on the board you
could get in a move like 94 and you can
see that well maybe white's beginning to
get a little bit of a nibble the rook
will come to d1 and
somehow somehow
an edge in development and edge and
activity might get you somewhere
going to be awfully difficult to get an
imbalance a favorable imbalance in this
one alejandro
uh yeah i don't i don't quite see it
yasser i have to say yeah the engine
doesn't see it
i don't see it
dingley rain is now thinking he's down
to a minute an hour and 46 which means
he's not part of his prep just yet he's
not the type of player that shies away
from just blitzing out his openings
i don't
know why he would be better yeah if this
bishop was on e2 you just think that
equal but what is the bishop giving you
on d3 a symmetrical structure all around
you could play queen b1 and as you
mentioned there's a lot of ideas here
but if i just move out of the way
and you play knight e4 i don't see
anything wrong with taking to be honest
okay but
i could just play rook c8
and and start asking what what your
ideas are here this positions after rook
here and i play my queen somewhere to c7
and you take twice
right they're not
really dangerous the king on g7 is fine
your development is almost equal the
rook is going to go to d8 we've seen
these positions before and
they're not really that dangerous for
black
you can imagine there's a bit of a
nibble but
better structure but it's not very real
i think that hikaru is very close to
full equality here guys exactly uh
agreed um turning once again our
attention to the game of duda and
uh i'm just impressed by the depth of
napo's preparation because he's actually
just kind of blitzed out rook d8 the
engine's top move and against knight g3
yeah i think everybody realizes they
have f5 square
it's kind of got to be done yeah exactly
that's your go-to square and he's played
g7 g6 c2 c3 and what you were saying
alejandro that uh team poland
if you will came prepared with this new
idea nepo seems
ready to meet the challenge
absolutely i like that move g6 the
engine likes it as well the move c3
already on the board i expect knight c6
to come and black has pretty clear ideas
it involves avalanche of pawns in the
center i can imagine even c4 b5
preparing d4 can come in
what is white going to do on the king
side in the meantime you have
let's say forced me to make a weakness
with g6 it forces me to weaken some dark
squares it gives you a hook with h4h5
but is this sufficient is this going to
be enough to scare me into anything i do
have a lot of defenders on the side of
the board the moment i get the bishop to
f8 i cover a lot of important dark
squares not so easy to reach h uh f6 for
any of the knights e4 is covered h5 is
covered so i think there's still a lot
of work to be done for duda to prove
that there's real threats on the king
side as you mentioned nepo very well
prepared finds the best moves rook d8
and g6 i'm expecting the move knight c6
to come as well just because it's so
logical and team poland is going to have
to show us where the attack is exactly
exactly yeah
that's my feeling too uh you mentioned
and i always like those moves by the way
even when i was
in the expert master's class i prided
myself on
a move like h4 and in my
uh imagery of what i was trying to do
was pry open the king's side you know
like you're opening a tin
and i like these kinds of moves h4h5 and
it was played you know i every time
every time you're talking a lot of
movement players do it i just want to
look back
no i do i i and again i'll i'll get in
the comment once per practice these guys
are good they're really good dorset play
attention to how they play but uh what
else right uh
alejandro i mean
the the setups with the knights on f3
and g3 the setup with the bishop on d3
if you're not playing h4 h5
what are you doing you're not playing e5
e6
so
you're you're more or less
forced to go down this line and where
will it lead us you got to go for it i
don't actually know exactly where it's
going to lead us because black also has
a lot of ways of trying to bounce back
into the center and the initiative you
don't want to allow h5 for free right
now h5 is never a good move in this type
of positions it's not absolutely
terrible but weakening g6 so early just
benefits white what ends up happening is
that any sacrifice on g6 now means that
you get three pawns instead of two so h5
would be a strategical mistake because
of the move queen c2 immediately
targeting this pawn on g6 it does force
a defense because again the sacrifice
now nets two uh three pawns not two so
queen c2 immediately threatens bishop
takes g6 you need to defend of this a
little awkwardly
you could consider h5 the engines don't
like that move instead they want to
immediately start
pushing pawns in the center two ways of
doing it d4 i think is one way you might
shy away from that because you think
that out you have this blockading move
c4 right and i think that's what would
scare most people away from it did i
just think that it's okay anyway because
of of tactics you go knight before you
try to take this bishop you go b5 very
quickly you get this bishop to b7
engines think this is okay black gets
enough play because of b5 bishop b7 so
quickly that you counter this move h5
see how the game kind of
moves away from the king side this is
what this kind of moves d4 knight before
do they move the attention away from the
king side to another side of the board
was it the best way i don't know
nepal has shown that there is another
way this is the other version of the
pawn pushes that the computer wanted to
do c4 first and this is important
because now when i pushed upon d4 there
is no sidestepping the part blockade
that blockade on the on the center so
i'm attacking this bishop it has to go
somewhere the more logical way this way
why is this a more logical way because
you already put the pawn on h4 which
means that you're gonna put the pawn on
h5 if you're going to weaken my king
side this bishop needs to be on this
diagonal to actually exploit that as i
said that bishop c2 played grandmasters
they sometimes know what they're talking
about
d4 i expect to be the move why because
this is why i played the move c4 to
allow me to make this break without you
sidestepping it now what am i
threatening i'm threatening to just
close down your bishop with the move d3
if you take on d4 i'm going to be super
happy these structures are well known
yes the spawner c4 doesn't have a
defender no worries i'm going to play b5
solidify this pawn grab space on the
queen side this bishop comes to b7 you
have this great diagonal for it and you
can start to see the coordination of
black's pieces white a little bit
underdeveloped when things start to blow
up in the center the computers think
this is still equal anyway after bishop
e3 i think that black is the one playing
for an initiative but
instead of that i think that first of
all let me interrupt you and say i think
you just made a brilliant explanation
of why d5 d4 is the move that's the most
critical move
and if you're not playing d4 i
understand you're going to play b5 and
then d4 absolutely you know but you're
getting in d4 and aleandra i'll go i'll
throw it back to you and say
a7 a5
you know okay
discuss
discuss good morning saint louis
i mean
explain that one to our audience boys
it's independence day right i can ask
you
a coffee plus at this time of the
morning in
independence my what is a5 thank you i i
wanted to ask you that but i'm gonna
just let you enjoy the moment you know
it wasn't just me or did the alejandra's
face just change yeah you did yeah yeah
yeah yeah
guys
it's like way too early for this well
because he had made such an a
a passionate plea
for d5 d4 it was like please you know i
mean
play the obviously good move d4 i think
everybody would have played d4 there i
i'm completely
i mean the engine thinks a5 is fine no
i just don't get this move because okay
let's go ahead
spank down h5 that's the entire point of
white's play up to this moment right
okay yeah i mean
i guess right of course like what else
were you going to do with white
now go ahead and play b5 let's just have
some fun with just a moment
and let's take on g6
i'm assuming you and let's go queen d2
and just go over there and maybe pushing
my queen was on h16 exactly like let's
go and have some fun i don't know
this looks very logical to me
this is a real threat i have to defend
right
is actually kind of forced exactly and
then you go typical stuff knight h2 i
guess right that is well you mentioned
that we could get a knight to f6 life
would be good i agree
like what you've done as white is not
very good crazy uh that you can play
queen e7
and it just does not care it just simply
literally does not care
you go here and it thinks the knight f6
check accomplishes nothing wow and that
you just put the king on eight wait am i
saying knight's going to h5 on your
there's an air yeah knight h5 is the is
a top engine move here
and then you have to play bishop e7 this
game is just wild and complex and i
don't get it a5 doesn't make any sense
to me i'm sorry but
yeah yeah yeah nipple doesn't need to to
do this right
he can just play chess he doesn't need
anything he doesn't need anything
he can just show up and play chess right
it doesn't actually matter how he plays
today okay the engine even thinks that
a5 might prepare rook a6 to defend the
third rank one day
i don't know i would never have thought
of the move a5 the engine thinks it's
completely fine that it's a good move
wow it would not have been on my like
top
five moves radar
at all even like why do you start with
a5 instead of just going b5 right is
there something wrong with this move
nothing wrong with this move right
i'm just laughing i i think we're gonna
have to
uh send a defibrillator and resurrect
alejandro because this early in the
morning and
obviously b5 and d4 must be played these
are these are like the the old guys
would say come on what the heck is a5
that's just that's hilariously fun uh
we'll definitely keep
keep an eye on this i once again i do
want to go back to the hikaru game
just to see what may have happened i
tell you if if i didn't know better i'd
swear that ding lauren
was you know securing first place
version of anything right right
excuse me
94.
knight takes e4 bishop takes e4 he's
provoked f7f5 which is actually
considered
at times very useful i'm not sure about
this exact moment alejandro that looks
fine for me guys really after for
example bishop c2 let's go all right
let's try trading stuff just because you
know i really want the drop you want the
draw questions
rook takes d1
sorry
hold on i'm playing bishop c2 what are
you doing i i took on d1 and i you took
it with the africa and i went through
fd8 and rook fd8 and i went bishop e6
and you went king f7 i assume i bishop
b3 i guess bishop b3 pardon me hitting
e6 yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
right good enough
and
rooksy one with a another ah let's take
all of them rook takes rook takes i can
do this
i know how to play like a 2800
i can trade all my pieces too
rook d-a-b
this is what the soviets called the
chopping block right they would trade
everything off uh
i'm throwing up my hands you got me no
this is you got me but it's too easy you
know right f5
where do you go and trade everything
trade on d1 there's no choices right
right like you could play bishop d3 but
the bishop really doesn't want to be on
d3
it's just on the way of the queen it's
getting hit right bishop f6 comes too
naturally you want this bishop on b3 so
c2 is the most natural exactly yeah i
take on d1 why not
and channel
oops takes and rook d8
i don't see why white's better here i
don't see why white has anything at all
here right
yeah yeah this looks
i'm confused i i mean
doesn't it look like nepo is white
trying to force
you know first place and make draws and
give up the white pieces yeah this is
pretty bad i mean digler is prep today
maybe he does need to give you a call
after all
and he has to win guys he
for second place he needs to win of
course
it might be completely relevant
depending on what magnus says
right but you still want to give
yourself that chance right exactly i
mean second and third there's a big
difference there
well again uh because of this whole uh
will magnus play will he not uh
playing for second is so huge and just
even i i don't know this move knight e4
is really kind of confounding to me i
mean i wanted to play knight e4 i truly
did but i wanted to get the queens out
of the way so that when i do play knight
e4 there wouldn't be
you know this this this trades the
chopping block that uh alejandro
has demonstrated uh yeah either queen b1
or queenie so they're both comfortable
moves just get the queen out put a rook
on d1 just see what happens
now it's not that you know again black
is collapsing or anything like that but
you're keeping the play alive you're
you're activating your pieces and you're
hoping gosh knows i don't even know but
you're hoping that maybe a knight g5 a
knight e4 you'll get something going you
know there'll be a reason
why you have um a slight initiative but
this choice of 94
compounding
yes please
if if you know magnus was going to play
for sure and there was no talk about
second place it's an all or nothing yeah
um
would you would we still kind of be like
why is ding trying to make a draw or
like does second place have any other
the prize money of course uh the the ego
the elo uh all kinds of good reasons why
you want to cross swords with you know
the the premier players of the world but
yeah that that would be
so there's no other like benefits to
like you know he's not gonna get like
automatic invite for next year
or so it's exactly
none of those things but uh still you
would imagine that uh you you you you
wanna
do something with the white people
seriously impress your opponent and and
these
types of things but thus far uh things
are going very very much ikaru's way and
also when we came on the show alejandro
you did that very nice line score
of these two players
and in both cases they had
bad first halves
but great second half
you know and again here
through the when i say first half i mean
the first seven games it's a double
round robin
there you see ding at minus one
uh
starting with a loss to our eventual
challenger our champion nepo uh when
ding had the white pieces how this event
might have been
different
in the space-time continuum if that
first round had come out differently but
anyway
after the first half this bad first half
look at what he does he goes on this
tier
three in a row a hat trick
and then probably one of the worst face
plants we'll ever see in the candidates
he had all the moment some white pieces
and got destroyed by timor one of the
most confounding games we've ever called
alejandro
yeah it seemed that
everything was going for the chinese
player there and he just fell apart he
just completely fell apart against a
player that also showed a better second
half than he did his first half that's
timor rajabov
who came from the seller as was thing
loren into a pretty acceptable position
i think the team were is finishing ahead
of what many players expected him to
finish as no question about it and as
always throughout our whole broadcast
we've enjoyed interacting with you our
audience thank you very much for
reaching out to us through social media
and dorsa we have a social media
question let's go for it let's see which
channel oh twitter
nice what are the latest
rumors regarding magnus playing network
in the world championship
well that's actually a very good
question
very good we had our uh one of our dear
friend dennis barros sent around an
article that was done yesterday i
believe it was in spanish so i needed
some translation exactly well in that
case let's throw it to alejandra
and alejandro you know all tell little i
get that i get that but help our viewer
out what could you share
with our audience there's not that much
to share there is a rumor that magnus
will defend as long as the match format
is changed and we do know for a fact
that magnus carlsen had a meeting
yesterday a 40-minute meeting closed
doors with fide press and arcade
vorkovich so we do know they met we
don't know what they talked about
they we know there are no announcements
we have no schedule announcements today
either
so we don't know for sure what's going
to happen so far the match is scheduled
to happen uh so far magnus has said
nothing official and so far
the
likeliest rumor out there but rumors
change very quickly is that magnus will
defend but that it won't be a
traditional format whatever that means
that one is up in speculation land
everywhere yeah that was i think
yesterday that we were talking about you
know like it's logical if he wants a
change he should negotiate it he's not
gonna just be like this is not what i
want by he like he wouldn't do that he
would just you know try and negotiate
and it's nice to see magnus is listening
yeah well i mean
uh
a little late as far as um
uh making some suggestions uh but hold
on a conjecture and now we are in this
realm of we don't know we just don't
know but
just to clarify a point that you might
made inadvertently
you can't change
the match scheduled for 2023 to some
different format because all the players
have signed contracts about how
the regulations have already been
approved in other words i'm thinking
magnus is going to play
against nepo in 2023
with the traditional rules used in dubai
wait what do you mean the contract for
the candidates doesn't imply that there
is a
it implies that you qualify for some
world championship but it doesn't
actually say what the world championship
is i disagree i believe the regulations
the uh the regulations that are proved
for the entire world championship cycle
are approved by the fide congress
and can only be changed by the fee day
congress good thing we have one coming
up
we have an election coming up for sure
with the fedex congress i don't know if
this will be on the agenda but my
understanding is that they would play a
traditional match in 2023
and maybe based on the discussions that
magnus is having with arkady things will
be changed for the following cycle that
might be yeah that might be that might
be a more legal
way of doing things and the concession
might be the rumors are that he will
participate in this uh
this is our conjecture yeah our
conjecture right you asked for rumors
that's all we can give you we don't
really know nobody really knows i don't
think magnus really knows i don't think
anybody knows we're gonna have to wait
and see us spectators uh of course a lot
of it is
dependent on magnus's feelings i hope
that we get to see a rematch honestly
between nepal and magnus carlos and i
think that will be very exciting
now having said what you said which was
the spanish leoncho garcia
writing in el paez uh el pais a spanish
newspaper
uh alejandro you're familiar with that
article
he
leoncho is mentioning anonymous sources
who are saying that magnus wants to play
sets
of games
like tennis uh with four round four
games have played like in the magnus
carlson tour 2019 that was played online
could you help our audience uh
uh what leoncho reported
that's what he ran for well come on
break it down you know
you're the spanish speaker here
yeah
yeah
okay
but yeah that's exactly what he said
that he would rather have sets the way
that the other tournament works uh but
for them to be sets it would have to be
a faster time control i assume 15
minutes and 10 seconds something along
those lines but
we're gonna have to just wait and see
there was nothing on the spanish
newspaper that said anything more
specific than that
yeah but uh it would be
uh
well we're holding our breath yes we
don't know everything of course but
every day if they did play the four sets
would be an exciting new day four games
a day and uh well
this would be the greatest changes in
the world of chess since
forever before we get back to the games
i did want to bring something up that
you mentioned remember before we started
the broadcast
that you know if all these changes are
set in place and magnus is like all
right i will play
and then he loses
and then nepo becomes the new world
champion and he's like guys
i didn't want all these changes yeah i
like the old system right
so that's something that i think
i don't know for me if the now that
magnus has a challenger i think it would
be nice if while he was negotiating with
fide they also include nepal like hey
dude if we're gonna do this change you
know we would like for you to also give
us your okay
it might make things complicated but
i don't know for me that would be like
the perfect world of rainbows and
unicorns and everybody agreeing on
everything
yeah now having said that too uh
okay so we think that
following a traditional match being
played in 2023 it may very well be that
they play a faster time controls in the
future yay
i think
nepa would be the first to agree and i
think hikaru would be
also the first to agree with such
changes
jump in the jump in alejandro with what
you imagined for example somebody like
fabi who is
much more
classical
chess oriented would he be hello
who's the number three blitz player in
the world who's the number three blitz
rapid player in the world
fabiano i think favi doesn't care what
the system is as long as there is a
system he'll adapt to it and he'll just
improve in that type of trust i don't
think he's a weak blitz or rapid player
anymore actually most of his successes
this year have been in blitz and rapid
he's tearing through the rapid chess
championships the one that he plays
online on chess.com he does well on the
grand chess tours in rapid and blitz
he's been
him and levon aronian just destroy the
american cup fantastic stuff i don't
think that he's any weak uh in rapid and
blitz time controls i mean they even
destroyed the blitz right after that as
well
uh so i don't think that he would mind
if there's a faster change he'll just
adapt to whatever it is i think the only
thing he would ask for is that it gets
published in advance
absolutely i mean
me too and i just love the idea that we
would get a time control
that you wouldn't need you know three
minutes to explain
and in the first time control and then
the second time control and the third
time control quite fun that would be
very nice but thank you very much for
the question and we invite more social
media and i think we do
go for it let's see which which platform
now
another theater
goemon asks
can the expert panel see anything on
netflix playing uh this time that makes
them think he might beat magnus or would
we expect the same result
beautiful
jump right in dorsey i think for me i
mean we'll definitely see a better match
especially since you know nipples
already played magnus once and he's
already had a terrible tournament so i
don't think he will see that again but
would he actually be able to win it
i'm gonna take a page out of my
future coach and say only time to time
for me
my chess career has always been
i come into an event the first time
my rookie year if you will
i don't really have a full understanding
so for example my first u.s junior
championship i didn't do that well then
i won the u.s junior championship i went
to the world union championship i didn't
do that well but then i won the world
junior championship my first inner zonal
and my first candidates and things like
that so i think
experience is just so huge of course and
more than experience too i think
confidence chess i know it sounds so
funny but chess is a game of confidence
and you really really have to believe in
yourself the worst thing that could
possibly happen to
um
nepo happened of course and he lived
through it he survived and he's come
back
and he's stronger than ever i mean i was
a diver
and when you went splat
you know on the diving board and you
just hit the water
you could just got up and do it it did
it again and i think nepo is going to be
a much better player magnus is
exceptional i mean let's be clear he is
trying to conquer mount everest
but you know i think he's going to do a
much better performance alejandra jump
right in
well when you say a better performance
it doesn't get worse
it really does not get worse will it be
a good performance that's the question
and i think so i think that he has all
the tools necessary i think that they're
going to learn a lot of what went wrong
on the last uh candidates
the last match
you just learned so much and he's
getting the positions that he likes more
and more often even moves like a5 he's
just getting in this prep
where he's getting positions in which he
feels more comfortable and i think
that's a big part of why he's done well
on the candidates where i feel that
magnus he finagled him into positions
that nepo wasn't so happy with some dry
relopes positions that nepal just didn't
know how to handle and i think that nepo
has seen that he's going to improve on
it he's psychologically so much stronger
yes i think that this is going to be a
great match not just a good match a
great batch back and forth nepo just
needs to strike first and we're going to
have such an awesome match in our hands
also guys help me out here um was i
can't remember when was the last time
that
candidates challenged the world champion
back to back
yeah i'm gonna say it's like anatoly
karpov but uh
um that that challenger was the same one
that qualified twice in a row yeah i
think i'm going to say carpo but we're
just going to double check on that i
just also wanted to say a big shout out
to anastasia there in madrid who caught
up with magnus and asked him
about napo's performance and what he
felt
nep who was the napo today and
our world champion said that uh napo
what what what was his words criminally
underrated
do you remember exactly what i
underestimated yes
like
damn
that's uh big words of praise um from
our world champion
alejandro you were your reaction to uh
that statement by magnus
i think
i think everybody in the chess world has
seen napo and thought oh yeah we forgot
about that guy
including gary caspar including gary
kasparov yeah so we have players that
are expert panelists and stuff like that
that thought well nepal has an outside
chance and we always gave him an outside
chance
but then when he actually took that
chance he made us look bad because
everybody thought alireza ding and fabi
are such huge favorites depo i think was
always talked about the fourth dark
horse coming in and he just proved it so
so wonderfully and even then he was
definitely underestimated we always have
this
uh this feeling that after the world
championship what is the network that's
going to show up
and
i think he's proven to all of us that
that he's back in the game baby yeah sam
shanklin was a guest and by the way i've
i got the cat out of the bag about our
upcoming guests which is coming up this
one-a-thon and anand is coming up 10 30
local time
um
now now i forgot what
sam shanklin
we asked sam what he thought about nepo
and he said
he thought nepo a
oh yes was the second best player in the
world
no question about it but the problem was
nepo b you know he could be his own
worst enemy but when nepo's playing well
as he's doing right now today this
championship he's undefeated he's the
only player undefeated and he's having a
2 900 what what kind of tpr does he have
by the way is it close to 3 000
alejandro or is it just the mayor 2900
tpr
i'll look it up for you
i love you knows everything he just
never never shared his knowledge that's
very nice what do you have for us in
terms of nepo's uh position nothing
nothing nothing's happened in the last
25 minutes
like super stuck
25 minute thing a5 was worth it dingley
rant super stuck 25 minute thing hasn't
made a move after f5 like we went on all
this talk about nothing has happened
five minutes literally nothing the
moment that magnus wants to make the
world championship rapid you know what
go for it
this is ridiculous this is a 25 minute
thing after f5 guys wow i i get the 25
minute thing here after a5 because one
on earth is a5 right but f5 really
doesn't deserve a 25 minute thing i mean
you have to play something right this
bishop has to move that's how chess
works you're not going to move it to b1
come on
c2 probably so you're deciding between
d3 and c2 i mean you don't take on c6
and try for a win what is this
so you're looking at two moves neither
one which gives you an advantage perhaps
thing red is just coming to
the realization
that this is zero zero i don't know
right uh the other games that we have
going on we do have a few moves for some
reason the engine hates black's position
here why does the engine hate black's
position here over any other berlin this
is the game between richard rapport and
timora jabba if it looks like a normal
berlin sure does bishop on d6 rook on
eight you're defending the pawn on e5
the engines think blah white is almost
like on the verge of winning which i
think is yeah i know it's ridiculous but
it basically goes h3 doesn't like taking
on f3 thinks that this position is just
much better for white if you do i don't
think it's a big deal i think h3 bishop
f3 you can just play this position on
bishop h5 and it simply starts with the
move a4 to cement this knight on c4 and
at some point you prepare the move g4
you'll go queen e2 you'll play king h2
even you'll prepare g4 and the engines
say there's not much you can do about it
the moment the g4 comes in this modern
e5 is very difficult to defend and if
you ever put the knight on d7 then you
do go g4 here at knight h4 do i think
that this looks particularly dangerous
to black this looks like a normal berlin
too it sure does it looks like any other
run-of-the-mill berlin you know what it
looks like it looks like this position
oh yeah why is this position zero zero
and this position
plus 1.1 well it's all of the little
subtleties in the position e5 is weaker
i already got the pressure on it black
doesn't have a lot of counter play this
pawn hasn't reached f6 yet which is kind
of important because it does mean that i
can exploit some of the positioning of
your pieces also your bishop on g4 it
doesn't actually want to be on g4 you
see how alireza keeps it tucked in on c8
this actually makes the bishop a lot
safer so even though favi got this
knight to f5 the reason that i'm
comparing contrasting the structures is
because they're so similar but here the
pawn on e5 is defended the bishop on
fight f8 is doing a good job of
defending this side i haven't gotten it
in the move f4 and black despite playing
on these two ranks with the awkward rook
on f7 has a much much much better
position here
then
here and this is why people hate playing
the berlin and this is why it's
difficult to explain the berlin to lower
rated players because there's a lot of
subtleties in the position where
logically it seems like here black has
more space than the other line that we
just saw the other is again it seems
like black has more space in the center
that you have the pair of bishops more
active this bishop on g4 gives the
illusion of activity whereas the bishop
on h on g4 ends up being a target
for white's expansion and this idea of
pressuring e5 is actually locking down a
lot of black's potential activity the
more you sit down and look at it do i
think it's as bad as the engine says it
is never i would probably think that
white got a nice berlin a slightly a
slight edge in a berlin and i would
never consider this like huge advantage
that it's giving for white in the
aldereze game i would think yeah this
looks like a berlin i know that this
night getting to f5 in this berlins with
the bishop on f8 is not that dangerous
that even though i cannot kick it easily
with the move g6 because i don't want to
give up my dark squared bishop after
knight h6 that i can live with it i can
live with the knight there i can maybe
chop it up with my bishop on c8 one day
but i don't have to hurry because the
knight is kind of lonely in the attack
it doesn't actually threaten anything by
itself do you want to play g4 g5 that is
something that we have seen in this kind
of positions but usually the king is
tucked in on the queen side and those in
those kind of scenarios i want to see
what fabi brings to the game the move f4
screams to be played next move right for
the time being it seems like we just
have a fight in this berlin between
fabiano carano and alexa ferrugia
definitely richie with the advantage how
big it is i'm not sure alireza and fabi
there are just going head to head
wonderful those explanations about the
berlin i just i'm hearing the voice of
ben larson
like nobody believes that that position
could be that bad for black that it's uh
that it's so good we're getting ready to
go on break we've got a lot of things to
share with our audience first of which
is q boutique yes of course let's see
so today it's uh it's the check yourself
yourself i guess not yourself yes
and we do have a 20
off promo code for this t-shirt and it's
as a thank you for watching our
broadcast for the 2022 feeder candidates
please do enjoy twenty percent of all
regular priced merchandise including
appeal chess sets and tournament
merchandise with the code
fita20 at checkout valid today only at
qboutiquesandblues.com so everything is
20
off
just today wow what a deal what a deal i
might actually go and as we uh go on our
break the tpr thus far
for napos 29 15.
which is
much higher rating performance than
magnus
peak rating that is true that's a that's
an amazing performance by nepo
and our colleague uh
caught up with nepo and asked him a few
questions about well maybe a match with
magnus take care we'll see you on the
other side of the break
[Music]
in bucharest gary kasparov said that
probably uh the winner of the candidates
tournament is sitting in this playing
fault if you think about yourself at
that moment how sure you are you were
before this event but i think uh he had
a very nice guess because it was like 50
50 of players yeah like four out of
eight yeah exactly so he had uh
you know
chances yeah i mean uh even like uh if
he would like call four random names it
still like would be fifty percent
because
somehow i believe that before the
tournament okay everyone has like about
uh that's eight players so everyone has
like twelve and a half
and uh due to some uh i don't know
aspects like okay for me for second
candidates and so on
uh it was um you know maybe i had less
slightly more but i never thought about
myself as a favorite yeah so maybe this
also like helped me quite quite a bit
because
uh somehow through all the tournaments i
was i mean also because of the
tournament situation yes i took some
every lead but i just was trying to play
chess not to play for result not to win
games
uh and
i think it's
quite a smart you know mindset i would
say comparing especially to the second
lack of yakitori in burkhaven i was just
trying to hold my like plus two and then
okay i was
basically very lucky to
get some
easy
you know related to easy games against
so
uh saying and then against uh how yes or
some surprising queen we always like
uh was completely unexpected but uh yeah
anyway i was trying only you know to to
keep my lead
and uh uh i mean it was not a place and
no no space for you know for creativity
for uh i don't know if you're enjoying
but here i mean of course then you're
leading the tournament you can't enjoy
it because you are too much afraid of
losing the leadership
here somehow i think it was
you know corrected to the to the right
side also magnus didn't think that you
are a favorite because i just caught him
today on display in the venue and i
asked him if are you going to play the
match he said maybe we will see he said
actually so what are your thoughts and
you're looking well maybe we will see
the same ones yeah yeah okay so how are
you going to celebrate your victory uh
how special it is for you
i mean it's uh quite a quite a mixed
feeling because okay last year i also
managed to win okay one round in advance
and then they had a disastrous last
round so
hopefully i won't spoil my own party so
tomorrow i should play a good game
and in case if i want spoiler it the
chemical and i will celebrate
okay have a good game thank you very
much and once again congratulations
thank you
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of these
candidates 2022 we are in the 14th and
final round and we have a tournament
winner
a yon nepo has scored nine with one game
to go
can he avoid
his debacle of the final round that he
suffered in the previous cycle we will
see if he gets undefeated but the big
story of today's round is the matchup
between hikaru and oh ding loren and
hikaru as
those two players one of them is going
to be clear second and as they go into
today's match this is their head-to-head
dorsa well dink has although there's
been eight games between them seven
draws and
ding has lost one of them
so it's um
it's pretty close but
he must win today if he wants that
second place exactly now considering
everything we've been talking about the
opening and the position i'm not so sure
if that's we're not enthusiastic about
his chances of winning because it really
just feels like
he came out of the opening rather flat a
lot of trades the queens are going to
come off the board if they haven't
already i believe they have in fact you
know yes sir i was um so one of my
students asked me to start giving her
more stuff to do from my book and one of
my chapters is the power of preparation
and i was like you know what read that
one
the power of preparation yeah i don't
think that unfortunately i don't think
ding had a great prep here it's just
such a
such an
equal and just
yeah and it's not only that not only is
the position equal but it's so dry thank
you
that's the world i was looking for and
we're going to see very quickly the
rooks are going to be traded and the
rooks are going to be opposed
furthermore now that the king is already
on the f7 square the bishop f6 inviting
more trades of this long-range bishop
and it just feels like with each trade
hikaru is coming closer and closer to
that coveted draw because once again all
he needs is a draw
he finishes the tournament in
clean second place
and he starts to wonder will he play or
will he not that's quite interesting
magnus carlson of course um it was
two days ago that we were sitting
before the rest they were sitting here
talking about what if there is a
three-way
second place even yesterday there was a
moment that ticara was worse and they're
like oh you know what if there is
right yeah so then in that case the
t-more
uh rajabov game would have been very
important as would
fobby's game and there was the like you
say this potential of a three-way tie
we've just seen what i thought was a
kind of a cool move after the move a2 a4
by richie i like this move by t moore
bishop h5 it's kind of like
anticipating
this idea of h3
and after queen e2 he could play this
knight d7
once again you know you want to get the
f6 knight f8 knight e6 i've seen so many
of these stodgy berlins i've come to
think of them as you know mush they all
kind of as alejandro was also saying
that this is very close to this is like
um the dream position for this position
would be first just position so that's
also quite interesting is that how
everything can be because infuriated
position we do have a pawn on f6 already
okay yep that the bishop is on e6
instead of h5
okay and it's easy to imagine the bishop
being there yeah the other bishop is on
f8 protecting which
okay be easy to imagine that one too but
the pawn is not on c5 though the knight
is on c5 instead
let's have a look
we got a big deal you know like okay
so what you were saying is things look
really really similar but the pawn as
you mentioned is already on f6 defending
e5
queen d7 bishop e6 a slight
rearrangement of the pieces
you could put the pawn on c5 which i
really think you do want and then you
put the knight on e6 or c6 but in the
meanwhile
it's all about f4 and you
white
essentially needs to get in some kind of
a break and he's not getting in d3 d4
anytime soon so it seems to be
f4 or bust
and
if not now when and so i don't see
another way of really playing this
position i have to ask yes
the the bishop takes knight is
not a very pretty sight because that's
you know technically a good bishop or
exactly but that line is too strong so
how do you feel about the potential
trade-off of those guys
i think it's just position specific uh i
would be adverse at the moment i'm just
looking to see if
if something isn't wrong footed in
white's camp if you play the move f4
immediate
immediately so for example imagine i
take
now i think the desire is to recapture
with the bishop but i just want to make
sure that
something hasn't gone astray g6 i always
had been counting
on the move knight h6 to kind of bail me
out ah in this case i don't have to
protect the the knight i can actually
just swing back
and then
i'm happy with white i i've created some
weaknesses so i think it's f4
and i think it's takes and bishop takes
now sorry uh doris so let's take a look
more seriously what you proposed which
was bishop takes f5 that just bugs me i
just wanna i understand get rid of the i
mean you know like get it out of the way
lazy grand masters lazy grand master
chest now if i trade queens i'm not so
happy i don't think this is what white
wants to see
unless there's a move like b3 b4 that's
disturbing i don't think so
i mean i don't know this is a
weird
line
i mean it's certainly not a structure
you see
um
but
i just don't know if i if fabi doesn't
play f4 i just don't know what he's
supposed to do let's get alejandro uh in
on the on this conversation
uh how is fabie doing alejandro
equal
bishop e3 now a lot of ways that you can
play the berlin in certain variations of
the of the berlin black ends up slightly
better according to the engine like this
one point three don't pay any attention
to this it doesn't really matter what
matters is where are you gonna put all
the pieces and what are the plans that
the players are gonna follow there's so
many ways to play this position for both
sides it's not very clear which one's
best you can take on c4 ruin the pawn
structure here and get rid of this
knight but to check it out you can do
the same thing on f5 which one is better
you can move uh g6 force me to go knight
h6 and get rid of that knight for the
bishop on f8 or you could go king h8
preparing g6 so the knight h you see the
berlin it has so many moves so many
resources the one that you guys
mentioned f4 this one i didn't like and
i'm gonna tell you why because after
bishop takes pawn takes i didn't like
pawn takes f4 i think this is the human
approach and if you take with anything
on f4 i think you take with the bishop
black stars play rook e8 rook fe7
controls the e file and this button on
f5 a little bit more of a weakness than
a
than anything else in this position but
the edges thought you know what even
more direct to move b5 this knight
doesn't have a lot of good spots and if
you return it to d2 it looks logical
looks like black is now forced to take
on f4 there's this shocking move e4
taking advantage of the fact that
there's queen d4 tactics attacking the
rook on a1 and whatever lands on e4
probably a pawn eventually and actually
white is in very serious trouble wow
it's
not a mystery because you're not very
developed and if you're stuck with these
two pawns doubled pawns then you can
imagine your structure is really bad
this bishop is not playing it's gonna
run into granite here in the pawn on f6
and the pawn on f4 is stifling it on
this diagonal so the bishop becomes
really bad f4 not a very good move
bishop e3 probably better
long drawn out type of berlin
similar to what we have in the teamwork
game but as you mentioned dorsa this is
a better version for white it seems that
black has misplaced a lot of his pieces
the move bishop h5 i agree it's a clever
move i like it but this queen of c8 not
very good this knight on c4 it's
unkickable you don't have this resource
of b5 like alireza has in his game
there's not on d7 you want to maneuver
it to a better square but because of the
weakness on e5 you can't do so so easily
if you play f6 here i'll probably play
knight h4 it's very similar to the other
situation but you'll see that move by
move black is there is uh faced with
threats knight f5 comes with the temple
on d6 might come with the tempo on g7
it's a different situation altogether
meanwhile this is just a game that if it
had
less interest for the tournament we
would just talk about it for two or
three minutes and say it's eventually
going to be a draw we'll come back to it
when the tournament is over right this
has no interest at all
so what do we hear
it's perfect yeah he put his pieces
where they belong he got a symmetrical
pawn structure he's neutralizing the
activity with this important move f5 h4
was played to install a knight on g5 uh
none of that h6 immediately on the board
you're now getting your knight g5 in i'm
gonna start trading everything i'm gonna
go into an endgame i know that second
place is my preferred price at the
moment i can't catch nepal so let me
just not worry about it simplify this
into an easy draw and that's exactly
where i expect this game to be headed i
think icaru has won
the opening battle so handedly
that he is a huge favor to draw this
game and finish the candidates in second
that would be an enormous success in my
view for hikaru from
his
uh very difficult start again yes
lightning larry remarkably enough these
two guys are in second and third coming
into this final round but remarkably
enough they also both lost the first
round oh yes the worst possible way of
starting the candidates and they both
fought their way back to 50
and eventually to a plus score and for
hikaru to finish this tournament with
plus two after starting minus one
he'll look back and say yeah
tip the hat and well done uh
young man i have to i have to think
about it from you know a bigger point of
bigger perspective too so hicaro is a
huge streamer you know i think there was
an article
in the world yeah i saw just a snapshot
so uh don't quote me on it but i believe
i saw something on instagram that was
going around that takara has a like a 50
million dollar um
net worth
primarily due to his streaming which is
outstanding
right and so um it's very interesting to
see that he can still
play beautiful chess it's not just
streaming you know of course it wasn't a
doubt but you know two years of pandemic
not playing that many in-person
tournaments
nobody really well you did but
not many people really expected him to
play
you know that that strongly and that
sufficiently and yeah of course and
that's
that angry after his first round
yeah for uh for for hikaru one i wanted
to say one of the downsides and i think
uh we can talk to this with alejandro as
well
is his enormous success and i wish him
continued enormous success he says that
he's gonna he declined to play on the
u.s olympic team and having cairo on the
olympic team is huge i mean come on
you're gonna have
you know four players in the world's top
ten
uh on the team
you got a gold medal team there and
icarus says look you know i got to go
back and take care of my my streaming
because
my compensation for playing on the team
is so
little compared to what i earn as a
streamer
i'm going to go stream and well
alejandro does that leave a bad taste
for the rest of the team i don't think
so i think that the team is strong
enough i think that hikaru has to put
hikarus first i think this is how the
chess world works sure
let's be honest what we pay
for the american team it's decent
compared to other teams but
it's not decent compared to the top
streamer in the world right
in chess i mean i think he makes its
entire compensation of the olympiad and
you know like half an hour streaming
so i i understand why it's not
economically viable for him to go to the
olympia i it is far away it's a lot of
setup i know that and it's super long
the olympiad is a very long commitment
it's a two plus week commitment so i can
totally understand why he's not going of
course the american team even without
hikaru is a huge favorite on chennai in
chennai
we just had the list of players
published and team america is a solid 70
points ahead of team number two which is
azerbaijan
by uh
while the ratings is not playing even
with ikaro not playing and i don't i
don't think that hikar would have
actually changed those ratings too much
uh because fourth he would have been
fourth board
just by list of rating not saying
whether strength or whether he would be
put in first second or third of course
the
team captains decide that not by rating
uh but whatever hikar would have been he
would have been top four
his replacement lanier dominguez i mean
he's pretty high up he's not bad he's
not bad at all right he's the top what
15 player so certainly america will miss
hikaru especially with the form that
he's currently in
but still a huge favorite to take that
gold medal in chennai yeah wow could you
just uh
alejandro
the russian team was banned from playing
or that was a decision that chose
the russian and the bella russian team
are not allowed to participate in
chennai okay
the video made that ruling
i don't want to say that it was fit i
have to check on that i believe it was
from the olympic committee but again i
have to check okay now while we have
alejandro here let me also brag a little
about my coach guess who's doing the uh
head coach for the female team
i'll be me just a second let me think
about it
oh i can guess i can guess alejandro
looking forward to that duty i am
definitely looking forward to that duty
uh working with the women has always
been cool i actually coached them in the
2019 world team championship that we had
in astana kazakhstan we over performed
with a slightly weakened team i'm very
much looking forward to this olympiad
we're going to start ninth
seated out of
127 teams so very cool looking forward
to trying to get some medals and always
fun to go with team usa it's a big group
we hang out with the guys as well
there's a lot of team camaraderie there
so looking forward to the trip yeah i
was gonna say for the
ladies section is it the chinese and the
indian ladies who are number one and
number two again no chinese in this
olympiad right now in the not in either
section no russia no chinese so the top
i believe the top female team
i want to say it's ukraine you're crazy
with the two music
headed uh heading number one and two
anna maria yeah yeah and up there teams
that i can remember on the top india is
really up there georgia's really up
there kazakhstan with abdu malik as the
first board is really up there poland
just got alina kashlinskaya as they
transferred from russia oh i did not
know and they're going to be one of the
top teams as well they're also very
strong so tons of strong teams in the
female section as well despite the
absence of both russia and china
wow okay that sounds like china is going
to just be a lot of fun we'll be
following all the action from afar
absolutely wishing the team well i'll be
asking you a few questions about the
upcoming indeed
india as well again for those of you uh
uh
get your social media questions as uh
five-time world champion this one-a-thon
and nan will be joining us at 10 30
local time he actually won nine
feed a world championships but
four of those titles
were
not the classical title but they were
like the rapids and the blitz yes so
he's a nine-time world champion but
five-time
classical chess world champion he will
be joining us and we'll be asking
uh we'll uh uh
be asking him all your questions so
be ready yes and the answer um for me
it's funny because you have the uh other
berlin position i i saw that yeah like
i'm i'm making a a contrast
compare i just want to um bring up that
if we can get um
fabi's game first to just take a quick
look and then i want to switch it to
rapport's uh raj above because that's
such a
um wonderful comparison so they didn't
do the f4 as you did the bishop e3 yes
they were bishop e3 and uh
just went kingh now i wanna just well i
just wanted to point out the um
the the pawn structure and the
similarities so would you like to go
deeper in the position or should we jump
no sure so we can just uh freeze frame
this picture of the pawn structure for a
moment and then compare it with the
teamwork right
okay so you just see that the difference
is we're going to move this pawn from c6
essentially pretty much that was it but
it was as ali alejandro was explaining
it's all about the piece configuration
yes and which player can get their
pieces
into their best positions now
immediately by the way i think we do
have a few no that's
that's actually um sorry
no worries but i think it's just
interesting that's before uh we were
talking about how in
uh fabi first position there was a nice
attack on well potential for a nice
attack going on but if g6 there's knight
h6 and so on and
wait a second
so
we were just here and farouza did not
want to play g6
knight h6 check king g7 queen would drop
back and then presumably we're not happy
that we were induced to weaken our king
side fair
so he played the move king h8 now
he's threatening to win a piece g6
there's no check
with the knight so the knight dropped
back you can't play g6 i'll take that
and farugia basically with this move
said
i'm willing to make a draw
let's call it uh the tournament
if you played knight f5 i'll play king
h8 and so forth um actually he said no i
said um
what uh
uh fabi said is i still think i'm a
little bit better i want to play on i'll
drop back the queen and we're up to date
yeah
i i'm assuming f4 is going to come up at
some point but well it's still difficult
right because i need now that the knight
is stuck on h4 i'm going to take and go
g5 so this might be a time that i'll
take a timeout to play
you know i'll gain some space on the
queen side maybe move like a5 maybe move
like b6 maybe just developing the rook
that's the whole point about the berlin
is this great flexibility it seems like
on every single move
uh you know you have your choices of uh
what what what to play in in which order
um alejandro jump in
does fabi have something tangible no
nothing at all in this position that we
see between rapport and timor the
engines say yes because you can get in
the move knight h4 and g3 f4 nothing you
can really do about it and once i
establish that you don't really want to
take on f4 i have the possibility of
opening up the g file what's the
difference when we look at favi's
position and you get you try to get in
the moves g3 and f4
it's not as easy black is so much better
placed against that bishop on f8
protecting g7 the rook on f7 actually
surprisingly a good place for the rook
at defense g7 in the long term also it's
not so easy to get that in without black
braking with the move f5 look at rajav's
position you're never getting in f5 with
the knight on h4 the bishop is misplaced
white is the one that's controlling that
square in this position the knight is
here but when you play f4 takes takes
with the pawn f5 you're going to be
broken immediately in the center so not
so easy to establish any of those things
i think that black is doing perfectly
fine in this position no real worries
for him because what is white's plan f4
immediately doesn't work i can always
take twice and go g5 hitting whatever
lands on f4 and as i mentioned getting
in g3 r4 is neither easy nor does it do
very much in this particular position i
think that alaresa has solved all of his
opening problems going back to the
hikaru game a couple of moves played but
nothing relevant h4h6 rook dc1 played
rook takes c6 is a child's play type of
threat of course that hikaru will defend
against that in one of many logical ways
i think bishop f6 just trying to swap
off more pieces makes tons of sense in
my view
i think that's the most logical move in
the position other logical moves include
simply defending the move with rkc8 uh
so that rook takes c6 doesn't win rook
d6 is one of the engine choices i'm not
so sure about that one but bishop f6 to
me jumps like the best move absolutely
uh no question in my mind too that i
would be playing bishop f6 and looking
to trade and get closer and closer to
that coveted draw if i could bring your
attention back to the game of richie and
timor for a moment because one
of the players that made a huge
impression
in my growing up was paul carras
and paul carres in my opinion had this
really wonderfully clean
classical style like his play had just
this beautiful pure logic that i really
admired
this is a typical position uh for timor
from a paul carres game and for example
what
if paul cares was black and he was
facing knight h4
he wouldn't hesitate he would put the
knight
on c6
and the idea from the knight on c6 is as
clear as a bell
he
is defending the bishop on d6 a moment
ago he wasn't but what he really wants
to do
is
blockade this bishop on this diagonal so
whenever you play moves like g3 and f4
and you're hoping that this bishop's
diagonal will
open up blossom if you will uh the
knights is going to land on d4 lots of
trades if you try to go and harass
the king's side the bishop will just
drop back and stop that frontal attack
against the pawn on g7 so for me i mean
uh paul cares would play a move like
knight b8 and he would just say
your king sight attack isn't going to go
anywhere i'll put my knight on c6 and d4
and alejandro he his opponents
couldn't
uh impact paul
that's fine but paul wasn't playing
stockfish so
that's kind of a moody point
okay
knight of b8 is fine i think it's a
logical here jumping because to do the
same thing you have a better route in my
opinion yeah you could go knight fa
knight e6 okay if you want to go to d4
okay i think the knight is just better
in e6 than
c6 i don't know if you agree with me
maybe i'm not sure but yeah i like e6
too all right let's go knight f8 knight
f5 in this position let's go knight e6
right something along those lines i
don't want to exploit the move knight b8
because i think this one's a bit awkward
because the engines here is just like
here here g4
g
let's go
that feels like a move right out of the
ali raza playbook
g4 g5
right right right yeah you can't take
because knight g7 and if you don't if
you just if you just retweet then rook
g1 g5 might actually be an idea but
let's go to something more normal by the
way richie played rook g1 immediately
so an indication where he's coming of
what's going on g4 and g5 on tap for the
hungarian grand master i think this is
pretty clear and i think this is also
why the engine doesn't like black so
much is because these threats
actually do present some problems now
the engines don't love them with rook g1
they did prefer knight h4 they thought
rook g1 was unnecessary because of so
many variations g you can play g4
without prepping it okay but rg1 seems
logical i still think that you either
retreat with the bishop on f7 or you go
knight f8 again i don't think that black
is doing as badly as the engines think
but i think knight f8 looks logical to
me you could play g4 bishop f7 g5 and we
get this style of positions where you
block with something on g6 whether it's
a bishop or a knight probably a knight
in this one and then we see if white
actually has anything on the kings and
the more i throw the pawns forward the
less the engines like the position but
this is how humans play chess you don't
play rook g1 without playing g4 g5
uh in the other game let me see if
there's any updates we need to yeah it's
it speaks up volumes to favi's fighting
spirit right he's really not playing for
very much in this game he could have
just made a draw with knight f5 right
but he said nope now time for a drug we
need to gotta put my foot down while i
can alvarez is having a bad tournament
and favi wants to take advantage of it
yeah especially for fob since he hasn't
really won he hasn't won a game in the
second half so if he can finish the
tournament true
wow i was talking with my brother
yesterday and we brought that up but oh
my gosh he had such a marvelous first
half and he hasn't won a game in the
second half we talked about that we
thought it might have just be
a complete loss of energy yeah that uh
he's been playing back to back to back
and he's going to play in zagreb then
he's going to play an olympiad yep then
the world cup and
st louis as well and wrap it up
i think he's skipping right now
and then the fisher 960.
and then
wow he's got a very busy yeah i think
he's going to be able to take his next
vacation in november with alejandro
now alejandro has already
let the cat out of the bag he's going to
go to croatia he's going to react he's
going to have a wonderful three days of
uh rest and relaxation very deserving i
might add uh
uh alejandro before the big zagreb and
olympia right those are the big
tournaments coming up and
those are the ones that everybody's to
be watching nepo versus magnus carlsen
when does it happen next it's at our
event the grand chess tour in zagreb
we're going to have that great match up
don't miss the other great matchups fabi
magnus is going to have ali reza in the
tournament that's going to be an awesome
one and they fly straight from zagreb to
chennai wow there is there is no break
there we finish on zagreb on the 24th
people are grabbing their flights on the
25th or the 26th the olympia starts on
the 29th
there's no break here guys
yeah it's just uh
constant in fact
by the way um sorry to say that how
could we have done this but we kind of
lost track of duda versus nephew and all
of this good stuff that was going on and
again
our shout out to
nepo for an absolutely
stellar performance a 2950
tpr tournament performance rating coming
into this game he's he's won tons of
rating points
uh is is he like number three or four on
the live rating he's really sick he
climbed nepal is currently number two
it's three sorry number three number
three yeah closing in on the 2800 he's
gained almost 27 points in this
tournament
fantastic and we're going to jump into
his game in a moment but could you tell
me of course what nepo's
peak rating
career high
has ever been
think it's on the extreme right there or
is that wrong from what i see nipples
i have it in my mind that he crossed the
2800 barrier i don't see that here so
from one
i don't think he did from what i see his
best
before this one was 27.97
oh no he was three points away from
crafting that magic 2800 barrier and he
just didn't make it he's having a
wonderful tournament so he's close to
his speed yeah but there's no way he's
going to cross 1800 here even if he wins
this it's he like he's too too far away
too far away okay
let's jump into the game because we left
it after this remarkable moment i think
it was actually right here c4 bishop d3
and i think every
old manual
would be talking about two and only two
moves b7 b5
and or d5d4
uh breaking in the center you know
countering an attack on the king side
with a break in the center that's been
the traditional formula a7 a5 mystified
and tasered
our panel i don't think we recovered
h5 getting on with business and
jan does a rook lift and says okay
there's some
in some distant far away galaxy
universe this rook on a6 may or may not
be needed to defend the pawn on g6 but
rook a6 is useful do your worst
do to play bishop e3 and finally now and
only now
did uh eon play d4 made this break in
the center said okay
you still haven't checkmated me in fact
you haven't really even
hit me with anything ah it's coming
knight e4 here we go okay this is very
exciting i i can see
i can see this beautiful square in the
not so distance
knight takes f3 check queen takes f3
knight d4 this is a
a pleasant fork of the
queen and a bishop
okay six when it was played i was i
thought very distant future but it
wasn't very distant actually it did yeah
came
right after like
it came quickly yeah i thought it was
gonna take another maybe like this is
something that might happen in future
i'll leave it there for the time being
but no napoleon and confoundingly enough
i'm looking at this position
alejandro i'm thinking black's better
like nepo's doing great
even though he hasn't moved his bishop
on c8 you know
the bishop on c8 remains uh glued to the
board
i have to say that uh but
what alejandro what
what do you think is dude doing great
the edges think that he's doing fine at
the very least really bishop takes it's
kind of a sequence bishop takes queen
takes and now here we have a couple of
options we can throw in knight d6 let's
look at the top engine line first knight
d6 is a possibility but d1
yeah and i was thinking there's a pawn
i'm not sure which one b2 e5 you don't
have a choice if you take on d6 i think
knight d6 just wins right oh well that
kind of hurts well just a second
okay yeah this loses the knight c8 right
and then i have queen takes b7 yes and
this is the check on e7 clear so it just
straight up blue says you have to take
on b2 all right give me that one yeah
you got this one and it's saying takes
takes i understand this
rook d1 tempo against the bishop you
don't want to trade bishops because c8
is hanging on because the king of g7
probably dies who wants that who wants
that so bishop e7 right absolutely the
problem is that i give you this check
okay what do you take with
uh pause why do i have to take it at all
all right you want to go what king h-a
king and jade gets made it no way
straight up made it uh queen f4 is
strong
with the idea of queen h6 okay knight d5
the engine 6 is also very good you
attack the bishop and queen takes f7
yeah i was trying to get in queen e5
sorry about that yeah okay so knight f6
check i have to take with the exchange i
have to give up the rook you have to
give them the rook because if you take
take then you have these problems
on d8 right right so that's easy to see
so you have to give up the exchange and
then i got two pawns
and the bishop you take with the bishop
right presumably yeah and how do we
evaluate this one because the problem is
that you have this move queen e4 at the
end
takes here and queen eight is a threat
okay h6 also i guess is a threat so
there's still things to solve in this
position i think that if you got both
pawns for free
you're happy if you don't mind just
continue king g7 kg7 queen takes bishop
e6 and then i assume it's queen
yeah queen e2 or d3 hard to see this
moves honestly
seven also
aren't i getting two pawns for these you
would think so the problem is that i get
in this movie h6 oh i don't want you to
have h6 i mean i'll do anything i can to
avoid that and i think that's the issue
if you maneuver the queen to somehow get
this move in i mean you don't want to
take on h5 yeah it's annoying it's
annoying because you'll go queen d3 and
take on h7 it's annoying and that's
where it's at is it bad for black i'm
not so sure and it's really down a lot
of variations but this position is maybe
not that great for black the edges do
think that white is a little bit better
after bishop takes d4 give up the pawn
and start the complications the question
is will duda
evaluate this as favorable for him if he
doesn't take though he is a little bit
worse and i think that a lot of the
moves that he just played don't make
sense right i think bishop takes is very
logical and after that i do think that
you kind of have to play rookie d1
knight d6 was the only other version i
was looking at because bishop takes i
think rookie d1 is strong okay uh if you
take i had this idea of taking taking
and i was hoping queen yeah queen f6
works wow with the idea that you
attacked this and you have h6 not the
hardest line to find and it can be very
dangerous for the black side that's why
i thought maybe knight d6 is what duda
is looking at but you definitely i
definitely think that he has to chop off
this knight on d4
yeah if you don't mind going down that
line one more time bishop d4 queen d4
because it's a very forcing risky one
queen b2 rook takes bishop takes rook d1
bishop e7
knight f6 check
yeah and then rook takes f6 i i mean i'm
i'm feeling peter svidler around you
know the grunfeld uh specialist who
would play bishop takes f6 here and
peter would feel
good
yeah i think the initial impression is
that black's doing great uh two bishops
two pawns especially a pass pawn here
but some specific problems with the king
it all comes down to whether the king is
fully safe and it turns out that because
this pawn is getting to h6 so often the
king actually feels a little bit
vulnerable especially with the fact that
in the last rank there's no longer any
defenders right
wow okay uh
thank you for that i mean again these
these engines can be so confounding
sometimes they will just take that
ending and put that pawn back on h2 and
they would say you know black's fine and
maybe black's even a little bit better
put the pawn on h6 and the evaluation
goes whoop
and uh
very very big difference what are you
looking at
i see you guys looking at the beautiful
screen i am i am i was trying to um read
like look at dude's facial expression
and like he knows there is something
fishy here but i don't that he's
thinking very hard about it that of
course you know he's got to because
everything that alejandra just showed us
um but i i don't know his face doesn't
look like i just found something
but
on the other hand nipple is just chill
walking around enjoying his life was why
wouldn't he's he's won the tournament
right
sometimes it's hard to get motivated for
these last rounds when you have
achieved everything you've wanted
already in the tournament you've already
clinched first it's hard to get you know
that that that that feeling like i've
really got to drill down and try to win
um
because i i'd like to bring you back
alejandro to the position after the move
rook a6 in the game of duda because
i
don't like the position that dude has
achieved in the game i'm thinking that
the position was actually good for him
prior
to
um his 17th move where did duda go wrong
or has he
duda yeah i mean i don't
okay maybe the engine says he's slightly
better here couldn't he have done more
like in in this position that i have
wait but
he went from equal to slightly better
yaser wants more yeah
what do you want from the man
what could he have for example gone
knight d4 it's since since black i
didn't play d
the poor guy played every move the best
move really you're like unhappy with him
yeah yeah i mean what did you plan 94
here yeah just i i was hoping that there
would be something more on the king side
like i mean this is strategically
horrible you take on d4 take on d4 you
got queen g4 you already trade the
queens
and you have this weakness right and b5
before is coming unless you have
something immediate exactly this is a
disaster okay so yeah no you don't you
don't play knight d4 you have to play
something that covers d4 you can play
knight e2 once one move bishop b3 was
another the engine was suggesting queen
d2
um
hghg queen d2 we were looking at hghg
queen d2 that's a perfectly good way of
playing right but what he did is also
perfectly fine i mean remember the
engine is like white
and i don't i mean yeah
but that's not the engines i know i know
okay
thank you quite interesting because the
tournament's winner is actually playing
with the guy at the bottom
oh i i student really miss allah
are tied for the seller but it was like
i was looking i'm like wait i mean i
know nepo is nine and i know dude is you
know not doing good but four point
difference four that's all
by the way isn't that our magical wasn't
that our magical number at the start
like nine if we could scored nine no it
was eight and a half eight and a half we
thought eight and a half could get at
least a tie yeah nine was way past it we
thought nine clinched well i feel like
um
earlier in the second half when fabi was
still you know on nipple's back it was
kind of going nine nine and a half but
since bobby kind of um
got off of nepal's back then nepal just
he's having a good time man yeah yeah
he's gel he's a very good just coming to
the game of richie versus t timor for
just a moment because we did see this
move rook g1
by richie which is like clear indication
here i go
i'm going to do a farouza i'm going to
lift my kimono i'm going to go g4 g5
let's go
and
timor says look if you want to play the
move g4
and weaken the f4 square i will probably
reroute my knight
to f4 and then you know you've got to
prove that your g4 g5
is really
good
i love it it's a battle of ideas and
timor's challenging
richie to give him his best punch
now it's this is also quite again fun
for me to compare the two berlins and in
the other berlin uh
if you was just bishop is on e6
and uh in the other berlin the bishop's
on f7 he's trying to bring it to e6
and
here yeah i was thinking like like you
bring the knight to g6 or e6 or as paul
cares often did
he brought the knight to c6 and d4
either way
uh from e6 you're jumping maybe to the
f4 or d4 square and from g6 well you're
jumping here and i think this is
this
it's now or never right uh alejandro if
you don't play g4 now
uh you may not
get the chance
uh
yeah i guess this is the time that you
want to play the move g4
you don't have to do it now i mean you
can play knight h4 first there's nothing
really stopping you from putting the
knight on f5 first
you can play g4 you can play knight h4 i
don't think that you have to do it right
now it's just a logical follow-up the
way that humans play chess usually is
like that right but i don't think that
knight h4 ruins your chances
g4 does look like the most common like
the most logical move in this position
and i do expect the move knight fa to
follow it up they're taking a lot of
time to reach what is still
a position in which there's not a lot of
tension there's no real tension between
the players at the moment no structure
is going to be
challenged for the time being g4 is only
preparing the move g5 so we still have a
lot of time to wait before anything is
proposed in this game could i just ask
you a question after the move g4 it
seems to me that g4 is a prelude to your
playing g5 trying to blast open the
bishop b2 diagonal could i try g5
for black so the idea of g4 g5 is i'm
just trying to shut down the king side
stop f4 i've already stopped d4 thanks
to the pawn on c5 and if i could just
get my knight to g6 or e6
yeah it's a way of playing i mean i
probably have to try to break this or
get the knight to f5 but i don't think
getting a knight there gets gets me that
many brownie points right here h4h6
yeah the engine just wants to
re-maneuver the now the knight all the
way to e3 with knight e1 takes a long
time it takes a long time but probably
what it's only white playing for an
advantage at this point because i get
the move h4 and any king walk rook h1 i
think is easier to do for white than it
is for black like king g7 rook h8
doesn't really have the oomph it doesn't
have the oomph of the rook on h1 because
i can get the king all the way there and
i think this king has to stay on the
king's side there's no path for it
to cross over exactly
one thing i haven't really seen in this
tournament was a
full king walk from h1 to a1 i would
love to see that yeah we haven't seen
that uh you're right you've seen some
nice kings well the king i remember one
where the king moved all the way to h4
oh yes and that forced an immediate
but also oh no wait wait wait wait
fabi's king walk
all the way to h5 yes and then to g6
okay and then he came over to the middle
of the board e6 that is true and that
was where the queens were
was that who was bobby's opponent
timor
yeah that was that was great that was a
that was a decent king
but that was the center involved king
watch this king walk just just be like
he went north south and then he kind of
moved over east uh
you're welcome to join us we love our
social media we're getting prep because
once again this wanna found anon is
going to be joining us get your
questions ready
what
oh we've we've got some social media
let's go for it i was going to ask you
what would you like to ask
vichy okay from
youtube let's just just say you do
that's
tough on me
sorry i got it
do you think terrible names paul morphy
would be in the candidates of alive
today we always get these questions
different generations different strokes
i don't know morphy was great i mean he
was just he stood he towered i want to
say above his nearest rivals much in the
way that bobby fischer did
and we always get these questions would
paul morphy would bobby fisher
win these candidates if you gave him a
database and stuff like that
there's no question the guy was a genius
he he was really really good but there's
no answer to the question because it's a
difference i agree generations i mean if
he's standing if it gives him a computer
best energy in the world and like a
three months of training yeah yeah and
all that i mean maybe if he had some
time to catch up and you know learn
everything that everybody else already
knows because
there's no question that the engines
have made the chest much more stronger
and more challenging all i can say about
these questions about the generations is
a story i'd like to share yes please it
was a lone pine lone pine california was
this tournament
that louis statham was the sponsor and
it was like really one of the great
annual tournaments all the juniors
journeyed to lone pine california where
we would try to get our norms
and we met you know some of the greatest
players in the world tiga and petrossia
and best beslies mislove miguel neidorf
they all played
at the lone pine tournament
and we were the young lions
joel benjamin john fedorowitz michael
wilder nick defermi and larry
christensen myself
michael rhode
you know we really fancied ourselves
like you know like we may only be ims we
may only have one gm norms but where's
storming the chess world and we were
analyzing
these great games
so all of these young lions like i think
you should do this i think you should do
that no you you're you're wrong no no no
no
this old geezer man he's like watching
us as all years are standing back
doesn't say a word he just reaches over
and goes plop
we look
damn that's a really good move we missed
it we all looked at him like
that was pretty good
lucky shot grandmama you know and we
analyzed bang bang bang bang
old geezer reaches over
and wipes us out with yet another move
like we're stunned like
chess is a young man's game who is this
guy like get out of here
he's killing us he's killing all of us
and this continues for like 15 minutes
finally the guy leaves i'm like jesus
we got rid of him who was that guy max
irva oh
former world champion
just schooling the boys
and he was from the 30s you know like
and he was really really good and he was
in his 70s what was he doing in
he was the president of the feed at the
time and and the lone pine tournaments
had such people as victor korchner yes
that he bent larson
that he the feed a president journeyed
to lone pine california to literally
talk to all the players simultaneously
that's very well that's such a such a
good option and this was max irvin not a
name like a paul morphy or a bobby
fischer that comes readily tonight and
yet you know even though there was
generations gaps between us
these guys knew how to play alejandro
jumped in with your thoughts i forgot
about the question
uh would paul morphy do well in this
candidate's event
no come on i mean no it's a silly
question right
let's say three months of preparation no
i i mean you think you give a guy from
the 1850s a computer and the first thing
he does is look through the chess
databases
i mean the guy's like what have i got a
computer
this is great okay two years give him
two ears together
no way we stand in the shoulder of
giants we've learned too much i
understand that irving can get in a
couple of shots here and there right in
analysis but let's be real 1850s
compared to 2022 if i didn't beat paul
morphy every single game that we played
i'd be embarrassed but that's because i
learned
everything that he did i know all his
games i know how he develops i know what
mistakes he makes i know that he's over
ambitious in his tactics i know that he
lays strong
foundations but i have opening theory
given to me by anish giri
by magnus carlos and by fabiano caruana
i have 150 years of improvements over
his chest more than that
it's not a fair comparison i i just
never like these questions because you
can't answer them paul morphy is not a
competitive player to today's standards
that's the end of the story he taught us
how to play chess from the beginning he
gave us all of what we stand on
but it was so long ago i mean well that
your answer
sounds in stark contrast to bobby fisher
who opined completely differently that
paul mooreview was one of the greatest
players
he called paul morphy i believe his top
10 in the ever greatest players one more
question from social media before we're
going to uh take a break and here it is
uh dorset from the twitter oh this is a
long one for players that were so hyped
up before the candidates like dang iran
what was the main thing lacking
do you think they can have another shot
at the next candidate
um no ferocious is done he's done
[Laughter]
[Music]
what does this talentless individual do
19 year old get out of
[Music]
it'll here happen defend him sorry guys
you think hershey and bloodman i gotta
defend him don't don't don't get dorsal
roused up
it's a tragic sight yeah
but first of all let's just be very
clear getting into the candidates is
enormously difficult we hope
that the dean lyrans and the farouges of
the world and they all get in the
candidates but think of how many great
players are not in these candidates and
lavon for me that was a shock i mean uh
shaq miami-daro i mean there's so many
players
wesley they're just on the outside and
just getting into the candidates is hard
enough so you know when you do get here
you really really need to perform well
and well i mean
for me i i
think and i'm being unfair i i think
ding lyrin really needed to show more
because he's he's experienced this is
not his first rodeo he knows the
ups and downs he came to this event i
think very unfairly with no prep yes i
mean he didn't get to travel and uh you
know he was shut down by the pandemics
so there was a lot of difficulties i
think that ding
laren had and this
wow this loss to timor i mean would that
just through him
way off um if he had done something
different so it's tough it's i i don't
know how to how to explain it but you
know it's really really hard to qualify
it's really hard to qualify and you
never know how they're going to perform
i think you said it best some time ago
alejandra somebody's going to take last
somebody's got to take class in this
tournament exactly we didn't expect it
to be furuja there was a lot of hope
riding on this young man's shoulders
as the challenger potentially nobody
really knew what his level was so
inexperienced compared to everybody else
clearly he wasn't on form for this event
i think it's typical that when you get
thrown in with the lions for the first
time you kind of get mold
and this is what happened at the
wrestling now 19. he turned 19 during
the tournament he was actually 18 when
the tournament started right
he won the grand suez to get into this
tournament of course he did it even
though he lost to fabiano caruana he had
such a dominant performance over the
rest of the field that despite that loss
he still won that tournament he is an
incredibly talented individual he still
has a lot of work to show he's currently
number six in the world after dropping a
couple of spots in this candidates but
i'm sure that he'll be back he's
completely fearless and that's what you
want to see from some of these players
now what did what lacked in ding and
fabi i think for fabi was energy a
little bit of luck it feels that favi
sometimes wasn't getting the gifts that
nepal was not only in terms
the play itself
but easier
games every favi game was a tense fight
every single point that he won
he had to win just sitting down and
grinding his opponent for hours whereas
nepo some of his wins
like against richard rapport
it's not just that he won with black
against richard rapport he won without
having to spend energy yeah and that
really accumulated towards the end where
snapple keeps finding stuff and finding
things i find that dinglerand and fabi
both keep missing things in the second
half even though that dingley ran had a
streak there of three games that he won
even in the game that he played against
favi he missed this knight f5 takes d6
and actually landed himself in trouble
um
against timor he just got crushed
and fabi missed a million things in the
second half of the tournament so
we can certainly think
that ding and fabi are more tired than
yon nepamya she is despite the fact that
jan is the one that is leading the
tournament why because look at jan's
quick draws
where are the dingler and quick draws
where are the thing learned wins they're
just such grueling tournaments right
and i think that the stars aligned for
yannis let's not kid ourselves he's
played amazing he's played the best and
on top of that the stars align that's
why his performance is so crushing so
devastating
and that's how i some tournaments go and
at this moment dinglerand yeah he
started too slow to really put together
a fight for first
everything you said i just want to
re-emphasize that in a interview that
nepo
had with anastasia she asked him well
what accounts for your success
and just echoing the words of alejandro
nepal said i didn't get involved in any
of those incredibly long games my games
were four or five hours
not the six hour brutal games that fabi
and others were playing so
he basically said the fact that he
wasn't spending enormous amounts of
energy
on each and every round was a key factor
of course success yeah now before we go
back to chesapeake i do have a question
i can't recall
um firster is very young right
18 19. yeah um
who is the youngest ever candidate
to play in the candidates it might very
well be for ruja i know that
gary kasparov was also very young
michael tall was also very young
fisher i sure was 19 right
i can't recall i just thought they were
all like young i just don't know that
exactly we'll have to ask vargas
but those are the names that readily
come to mind yeah michael tall gary
kasparov
and ferrogen fisher nice yep
wonderful all right uh we again special
guest coming up uh we're gonna take a
break we'll see you on the other side
[Music]
when you visit st louis you'll probably
want to watch the cardinals or the blues
what about after the game
heading back to the hotel would be a
major error
instead boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the blues
their name at the national blues museum
broadway oyster bar or even the
legendary blueberry hill so whether you
love the cardinals the blues or the
blues come play with us
and you guys know i can't play this
right
st lou is always exploring
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's our show now go play yours at
reasonboat.com
[Music]
hey st louis the ascension charity
classic presented by emerson is back
this september don't miss the excitement
when the pga tour champions best compete
again all for charity september 9th
through the 11th at norwood hills
country club pro-am spots hospitality
packages vip tickets and more available
now at ascensioncharityclassic.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of round 14 of the
candidates we are in our last and final
round our congratulations to nepo on his
wonderful success as he is clinch first
a big fight currently going on between
dingler and with the white pieces
against ikaru nakamura the winner or a
draw will decide
who is clear second dorsa and we have
other games that are actually heating up
especially i'm looking at the game of
richie rapport versus t-morse
richie has just thrown down
uh the challenge with the pawn sacrifice
g
for g5 things really getting heated here
right i think as you put it you called
you did you said that he's pulling the
first job
lifting the kimono and away he goes g5
uh challenging black now uh the
desirable capturing towards the center h
6 takes g5 h2 h4 is what
richie is definitely looking at and
should you capture this well
somebody's going to die with a full
tummy here as these uh
what i think it was reuben fine who said
uh
such combinations are as natural as a
baby smile
in such positions so you can't be greedy
and after h takes g5 you're going to
come up with something else i suspect
we might even see something like f
6 takes g5 h4
something a little bit more defensive
minded knight f8 takes and maybe try to
close the king's sight for a moment with
h6 h5 trying to get the knight to g6
might be the way that timor goes but g5
is definitely the challenge dorset so
i'm thinking the line that you showed
with h635 h4 yeah and if we take you
know we get between h6 yeah so um let's
go back and and the final position you
know just keep going all the way through
and that's how we would die basically
now imagine if the bishop was not on f7
yes i could defend that
with the rook uh coming to e7 or the
queen after h4
yeah why not just bishop take c4 good
question let's take a look at that one
so i'm assuming i have to
i mean
this looks
ridiculous so i'm assuming i'm going to
take and now what you're saying is
that takes queen h6
bishop back
uh to g7 any rook sacrifices that's
gonna be a no-go it is absolutely i mean
this is still very scary i don't really
so i would probably have to pause my
enthusiasm
let's say and do a move like night takes
but then
uh i've got more bad news coming i'm
going to really be uh focused uh fully i
mean you
you might go full
you know like what we would call seizing
the defensive
but um this is not looking very pretty
it feels like uh something is pressing
badly uh i i wouldn't
you're suffering a lot for a pawn let's
put it that way
i i mean i feel like h6 g5 is you kind
of gotta take that g5 with something i'm
gonna go f takes okay okay uh with the
idea of what i was saying like i wanna
shut down the king's side i will still
go h4 yeah
moves like
g4 bishop g5 but really where i went
originally knight f8 just felt like the
most natural
to try to
close i'm not saying that i'm going to
succeed i mean you might
keep throwing stuff at me please
e5 pawn yummy yummy oh shoot
excuse me
uh good morning saint louis
sorry
breakfast time yeah wow okay yeah
somehow i thought
if i if i wouldn't close that i agree
that would be very no no no no that's
that's what it's all about that's why
we're getting in g5 and h4 aren't we
could we join a bishop c4 at this point
but true if we do that then our h5 pawn
would be kind of lonely that is exactly
right uh
here if i ever do something
now if i go like i don't know g6
i'm not saying that you you might even
have a sacrifice on uh g5 coming i was
trying to shut things down forgetting
that i was leaving my e5 pawn hanging
shame on me no no no no absolutely
sneaky some challenges uh
that uh
richie uh as as uh posed to his opponent
we're gonna put ourselves on pause
because we do have our special guest
doris yes we do
very very welcome
hello hello
thank you for joining us hi how are you
both
wonderful how are you
i'm doing good
here i am in uh
madrid i just got back from the hall and
uh
wonderful tell us about chennai tell us
about the olympiad what all
you're doing vishy i know you're an
ambassador for fidei
ambassador for the chess world but uh
tell us what's
what's going on in chennai in the
olympiad
look everyone's very excited the
state government the central government
the federation obviously everyone's very
excited they're all working together
um preparations are
uh coming along quite fast
and it's nice it's the most
pleasant part of the city
along the beach road um
should be relatively cool there uh they
found a very good venue
and
they've selected the massacre and
everything going very fast because we
had to do everything in a few months
and they're looking forward to the event
so
how many teams are how many teams are
expected uh
to uh descend upon india for the olympia
so this year will be 189
whoa
that's and because of that india gets to
even it out with the third team so
that's nice for us as well so we have a
third team playing
wow
and it'll make it 190. wonderful
record participation dursa
had some nice questions prep for you
well speaking of the um chennai olympiad
um i saw in the news a few weeks back
that you were
you initiated the might have to help me
out with the wording here the the flame
of the olympic carrying of the torch yes
thank you yeah that we call it the torch
relay flame whatever
olympic flame touch delay yes
this was a new idea they came up with to
promote the
olympiad in india
and it's it's a brilliant idea because
the prime minister started it in
new delhi
and after that it's gone to many cities
it's gone to our northernmost and
highest
uh town lay
in
the northeast then it went to
it's been slowly winding its way through
the country it's going to go to 75
cities wow because it's the 75th
anniversary of india's independence
so to commemorate that it's going to go
to 75 cities and in each city
they have a very important function
there's a lot of press coverage so it's
a brilliant idea i think to
make sure everyone in the country knows
that the olympia is happening well
that's
certainly wonderful wonderful yeah and
well i i have way more questions
well let me get one in first vichy good
to see you my friend
i expected you to still be on your
running shoes but i see that you have
visited madrid
does this tournament came as a shock to
all of us not just because one player
ran away with it but because we saw
lackluster performance from a few of
these players did you expect that you
yourself came back asked somebody that
lost the world championship crushed the
candidates did you see nepo doing the
same
um yes but he's uh over he's overdone it
a bit he's
gone and done plus five
which is ridiculous
um
and i was really shocked by fabi i think
because nepo yan was keeping the space
it put pressure on others even who had
very healthy scores i mean it's amazing
that fabio on plus three
felt he had to take so much risk
to
catch him because
for a couple of games i felt he lost his
objectivity and um
something went wrong to fabian it's
clearly pressure which
is thank you not from some
self-inflicted pressure it's quite a lot
of strange performances from the others
right which which game did you feel that
five lost objectivity in
certainly the ding one i mean i would
normally expected him convert that
efficiently right though it was maybe
slightly unexpected that it became a
winning position but then
uh normally this should be well within
fabie's grasp
right um
his opening choice against tekaro i
would have to agree with hikaru that
he had better options but it's this
feeling i think fabi was looking for
something where black would have
substantial winning chances
to my mind he chose something without a
lot of winning chances this open rye is
not really for that
but maybe he just thought an unbalanced
position would be what he wants against
[Music]
[Music]
you have to icaru even more and
but ian made it look very very easy so
full credit to him there were
only a few moments when he was
challenged and he
came out
he got out of it quite easily so we
shouldn't take credit away from him from
for that and tell us your thoughts about
it you're now involved with fita you are
running in the ticket of course you
can't tell us exactly what's going on
behind the scenes but your opinion will
magnus actually play and if he plays
will it be under the same circumstances
what everybody is buzzing about these
days
yes exactly
so um
magnus was here yesterday in madrid and
he met
with uh
the president and uh i think also with
emil a little bit they discussed some
scenarios so for the moment i think
he's uh come up with some
changes he would like to see
luckily he tweeted about it so i didn't
i don't have to worry about whether i'm
betraying some confidence he
he wants
a different format something that he
thinks
allows one chess player to show his
superiority over another chess player
quote unquote
and
[Music]
that's where it's at so he's not made a
final decision he will still revisit the
theme and he's agreed to park his
demands but he's not said yes either
and that's the current status and um
uh
obviously now
his opponent has a name and a face under
permission so he'll have to be consulted
as well there's some work ahead but
let's see just be clear with both sides
of keeping it open would this be for the
current
world championship cycle that would be
this demands would be for this one or
for the next cycle itself
i think it's for this one because he's
his participation is in question this
one that's true so he's he's negotiating
for that
he basically feels that um
more
you need to mix it up a bit more maybe
more blitz and rapid something like that
was along the lines of what he suggested
so um
yeah uh
we'll get to that
if if i'm in office in august then i'll
also deal with it but we'll i'll [ __ ]
that i'll hold that thought till then
if i'm in office very nice
spoken like a politician a gifted
politician very very nice
and
i learned from the best yeah
but
for you vishy you have represented indy
your entire life i remember playing
against you in fact
in i think it was dubai in 1986 so you
have been leading the indian team for
some
decades
nostalgic feelings about not playing for
india this go around especially
the olympics being hosted in india
not too much because i will be there the
whole time and i get to hang out with
everyone and i don't have to prepare for
my games so
not too bad
and
by the way this decision i made earlier
it's
part of it
a plan i'm not playing the world cup
anymore i'm not playing the grand swiss
anymore i'm not playing the grand prix
anymore i'm not playing the olympiads
anymore i'm playing much less and
so
[Music]
clearly my
career is kind of transitioning okay and
this was part of that and i didn't feel
like changing my mind just because
unexpectedly they even came to
india but uh look i'm every much every
bit of the fan i was and i will be there
all around and try to enjoy the olympiad
from the other side
wonderful
um sorry now that we've got you here it
would be it would be wrong of us not to
exploit you
and turn you into a chess commentator
i'm looking at the game of richie
rapport versus timor
and very unexpectedly for us
the game has continued with a pawn
sacrifice g5
followed by a p sacrifice knight takes
g5
and you're just
kneed your
reactions to this sacrifice
do you think it's good
my knee-jerk reaction is that it's just
wrong
[Laughter]
isn't bishop takes c4 and hit g5
just
great for black rice
i mean what else do am i going to do
any nonsense i didn't take on g5 first
because maybe you'll play rook takes g7
or g1 first right and this
look my first impression is this is
wrong
um maybe as i look at it i'll say that
white has this plan with uh
rook a g1
and then queen h3 maybe rook h5 so there
are options
but i would guess that um
black is now also able to bring quite a
few pieces to defend right
well actually i would like to start with
queen f6 instead of bishop f8
yep
queen f6 because after i play rookie
seven i don't want the queen to be shut
on the other side okay and if i go
rookie seven rook f8 how bad can this be
you're getting a lot of defenders
over right uh so white white still has
queen h3 and rook h5 maybe right but i
would assume that i can play
knight f8 and g6 or maybe rook f8
threatening queen f3 check
so there are quite a few options for me
i mean i'm spitballing but um
i could easily get into more specific
lines but uh
it
my first reaction is i don't believe
this exactly uh
me either i was like what the heck
is richard uh
miscalculated but
you've always been
super fast at seeing the tactics so i
thought i took the lazy man's
commentator approach i got this sheet
i'm gonna
i'm gonna
ask him to calculate the complications
i'm gonna sit back and
and
applause wow
we were talking about punish four before
the movement exactly
so your first reaction is
this should not work this is like
ridiculous
yeah
and
we will see if uh if that's the case
dorsa um alejandro
yeah we have him here i mean come on
with the nepo game the nepo game is so
fun so cool right now send them to that
one okay put the camera on me we got
bishop to calculate this crazy position
yesterday if you could bring that game
on your i do have it on a board and we
left it around these parts with queen
takes b2
so far the players have played like
engines top choices up until this moment
i think vishy
alejandra was saying rook to d1 without
hg6 just
without hg6 exactly because why not keep
head six and reserve exactly and that
was actually a key point that the move
h5h6
was really putting some pressure on
black
we're just going to jump
basically to the game position bishop
takes g6 vishy
f takes g6 queen e4 on the board and
once again
just your kneejerk
impression is this
good for who
um
i want to play rook takes d6 but queen
g6 you start with queen g6 check first
yep that's a problem if i go king g7
then you have rook b1
rook b1 yep oops and that is not going
to be good kind of crashing through
right
well hang on a second so
king g7
rook b1 let me go bishop d5
wow
cool
but uh i even have rook takes b2 and
knight takes e4 so
uh what's the body count though oh well
maybe good for now we had about equal
but yeah maybe good for white actually
yeah
slight edge
yes rugby six roxy two
maybe maybe it's equal for black i don't
know okay
um but if you don't have bishop d5 then
you're lost so that's a problem but uh
yeah bishop g6 and queen e4 was clever
in fact
i was
checking this at uh a few moves ago at
the point when he went queen takes a b2
or right before that
we were trying to find scenarios
and bishop g6 and queen e4 we didn't
examine we kept trying to make hit six
work with something or the other bishop
a4 e8
and we were not really managing to get
this work but bishop g6 and queenie for
very decent ray and
if
what should black play
um yeah i was thinking bishop f7 perhaps
yeah but then i can take on uh f7 if i
want
aha
yeah i mean just simple king f7 e6 check
exactly and now you either have to
blockade it with your king which is not
a good idea or
feels
feels like i'm on the precipice of
defeat right
yeah now
queen h4 check queen at 7 check exactly
yeah no i'm not a happy camper at all uh
not at all no bishop f7 oh for me sorry
queen e4
um yeah bishop f7
also knight f7 and b1 might be still
unpleasant
exactly
well
the desirable bishop f5 unfortunately
takes in queen d5 czech spears the
bishop if not
anything worse
you're you're definitely
uh not
happy there uh
this looks right
all we have left is this king g7 and
bishop d5 i don't know yeah this look
this could be very very frightening
actually uh your impressions of dudas
event
the candidates it says there were three
players coming
out as rookies uh vishy
including duda he came in with high
expectations having just won the warsaw
grand chester
rabbit and blitz
what do you think about
duda
i think
uh duda and ferocia
um felt a lot of pressure mainly from
themselves
i think they really wanted to do well
they were very motivated but
sometimes in the candidates you also
have to see what happens after the first
few rounds you know what situation turns
up
um
especially ferocious i think
had this mix of just feeling that he
could
take a lot of liberties
and uh things will work out if he just
went by willpower or something it
doesn't work like that he got punished
multiple times
um
and then it feeds on itself his form uh
dropped and uh
you know once it starts to go wrong as
we both know
you find ways of making life difficult
for yourself
um
rapport for me is harder to say what
he
never
he never got going but i don't even know
if i really considered him one of the
favorites he's unpredictable so in both
ends you know he can have a very good
tournament or a very bad one um
[Music]
fabi for me was a bigger surprise
because when he was going to plus three
you felt
um he's very much in shape but what are
you doing and someone who's plus four
and then you feel you have to take these
extra risks
um
but yes a lot of people playing there
for the first time
and alejandro any more questions for our
illustrious guests
you gave us a lot of i'm doing politics
here i'm in madrid but vichy people miss
seeing you play you mentioned you're
playing less but what are you playing
this year what are your fans looking
forward to
well i'm
right after this tournament i'm
traveling to leon so in fact day after
i'm going to leon and i'm going to play
a tournament there that's myself the
mahistora de leon it's myself girlfriend
esipenko
and jaime santosa
uh
after that i will uh visit beale
and uh i don't be playing but i'll visit
dale and then go on to dortmund where i
go for my annual no castling tournament
no castle
i expect to play something later this
year but not yet announced and so on
uh
how is it vichy for you when you
have an old rival
like boris gal fan i mean and you see
one another and you go i remember when
you were a young boy when when did we
first play i mean that was a great world
championship match that you played with
boris and i especially remember your
quote
i won because i won
[Laughter]
well boris
boris's presence automatically means i
am the
only the second oldest participant after
a very long time which is wonderful
right it's wonderful
and this uh
i just saw that people who played with
me in the juniors in oakham have now won
the world's senior steam championship
it's weird out there yes you you got
that before but you know it's weird
still when you go through this
and uh but it's nice yes
um
with boris and me uh we go back such a
long way
and uh it'll be nice that he's also
competing and in fact it's almost a
senior versus junior's event because the
other two uh
maybe just 20 each or 19 inch or
something kids kids oh
yeah
and the two of us i thought they so
normally the way they split the pairing
is they have two people who cannot be
paired with each other
and then they draw from the remaining
two numbers right so
let's say i couldn't play girlfriend
then i could draw from one of the other
two
um
that would be obvious by age but it's
not the case by rating so
from ages i'm there leon man
we're gonna watch out there but
it's gonna be a great event i always
loved this battle of generations from
these talents that you've mentioned you
have so many in india of course we have
asi panko coming up he's a strong 2700
but from the indian players
we you have so much talent you got to
pick one this is the one that you feel
is going to be head and shoulders over
the others five years from now who is it
um
i want to say two names but uh you're
really putting me on a spot okay i'll go
with uh
i'll go with pragnanda
what about the women
um
women
why shelley is doing very well right now
and then i think we have a slight gap
amongst the
juniors so
we need to work a bit harder to have
some
top talents there
there are two girls there's girl divya
deshmook and
vantika agarwal
both still juniors but
some hope
you know some talent there and um
i but i think you know our bench is much
stronger in the
on the male side in juniors there i can
easily give you six names
who are very very strong we have now two
of them are in the top 50 and pragnanda
is just a little bit behind
so there's
quite a few of them
who are just very strong and very
comparative
but in the girls yeah we still have to
work a bit all right
vishy uh we are on behalf of the whole
panel we really want to thank you for
taking time out of your day to join us
it was really great pleasure
and to wish you and india
the greatest of successes for the
upcoming olympiad it was it will be an
event the whole world will be watching
thank you yes uh
of course what knowing that the
the dream team is from the us again
right the dream team yeah yeah
30 years later and you guys have a dream
team again it's just in chess this time
so
but uh
you know it's great day you're coming
full strength and it should be a great
event i
can i push you a little bit to come and
visit but
you can ask me anything
was funny that you should say that
because uh our friend eric hansen he's
like he's with the canadian team he says
come on come on chennai is going to be
great it's going to be great
but i for one seriously i
i have never visited india uh
and uh
it's a great excuse for anybody who
loves chas to go to india and see all
the great players and i know your being
there and your welcoming presence
will
inspire
many many to visit
i'll take you to some nice places i'll
throw that one in
[Laughter]
thank you vision are you coming yes i am
going to be the uh coach for the olympic
team for the women so i'll definitely
see you there fantastic good
all right
thank you again vishy uh
always a pleasure
yeah thanks cheers
wow uh
my goodness three
teams from india they're they're like
yeah exactly they're really really
really really strong
teams and uh when vishy was speaking
about the junior talents uh
you could see he was really proud yeah
um
please correct me um to the best of my
knowledge he is the first grand master
from india ever that's correct so you
know he's like the father of indian
chess exactly
these are all my babies
exactly that's what makes him such an
outstanding i have uh i grew up in iran
so i iran and india we played many many
many tournaments
oh yes like all of my youths um
opponents were like indian and that was
not an easy win let me tell you
i could imagine
it was quite interesting because i had a
lot of indian friends so i would always
ask them like so like how do you guys
you know make a living and do chess and
um to the best of my knowledge this is
again like five years back um they were
telling me that they have these amazing
sponsorships with different like oil
companies not just but i'm paraphrasing
and that they would just be
fully financially covered as long as
they're you know they do what they love
and they bring more pride back to their
country and i think that's such a great
um support system that's you know
sponsors you to just
go play events right enjoy your life
do what you want dedicate yourself yeah
and to again to the best of my knowledge
um i i know
virtually nobody who uh who's a
grandmaster or a woman grandmaster and
transferred out of india
i can't think of a single person because
you know translating federations is such
a common thing and we see it every time
yeah and you're right that the
india i mean i think of hari krishna as
maybe somebody living abroad but he's
definitely continues to represent india
he's very very much so anna must be
doing something good to keep him they
must be doing something good indeed uh
alejandro uh sorry that uh got to bring
you in and ask you to bring us up to
date all the games are still in progress
usually we have a draw by now they've
all changed though oh okay this one is
the one that we analyzed with vichy
richard against timothy sacrificed a
piece the engines hated it with the
passion but they did think because h4
was so strong by the way right they
thought h4 was super strong in this
position they do not understand why you
wouldn't go h4 richie said give me the
sacrifice but the engines thought that
the path towards advantage was extremely
narrow and the more they thought about
it they said you know what richie that's
actually not so bad
what you're doing in this position they
did think however that it was important
as vishy said to sacri sacrifice
to include bishop takes c4 b takes c4
uh pawn takes rook takes and in this
position neither queen f6 nor bishop f8
gave black an advantage the only way to
get an advantage was actually to stick
the bishop on f6
which maybe is a little bit scary first
of all you have to calculate rook takes
g7 immediately right but the engines did
feel that putting the bishop on f6 and
the queen re7 was the way to go because
eventually white's plan is to play f4
and open up the bishop once the bishop's
on f6 that plan loses strength the way
that we have it on the game right now
with this bishop still on f7 you have
this pressure on g7 rook takes g7 is
actually a thread here so if you play
the move bishop f8 which i expect
the move f4 might be seen anyway wow the
idea is that on queen takes yes i cannot
take on f4 because after pawn takes and
bishop takes g7 i kind of ran out of
material right i do have some threats
but takes takes king f8 no problem for
the king i need more material to check
this guy not something i have on hand
but the angels are saying take sorry
queen takes f4
whoops queen takes f4 just move the
queen to h3 and renew some threats rook
f1 or rook f5 being a threat against the
queen sometimes bishop c1 if you retreat
the queen remember the queen oops
remember that the queen on h3 is
attacking the knight on d7 that's also
an important tempo a lot of hidden
resources here for richie perhaps he's
oh he's uh understanding the position
better than timor hard to say the
engines think it's equal
easier to play for white in my opinion
because the attack plays itself the
defense not so much i think in that
exact position that you have on your
board vichy would include bishop takes
c4 if you
allow it bishop takes c4 b takes e4 and
he wanted to play rook e7
and he felt that if he got in the
defending move rook f8
life was good i think it comes down to
the same thing can i get the move f4 in
now
since you in this variation if you take
take rook g7 i pick up something right
right rook takes
picks up the knight and if you move the
king rook g8 you must pick up that rook
on a8 so f4 is a little bit of an issue
you can't take
i lost my
i lost my leg let me go this way uh so
in this position after the move f4 you
have to do something a little bit more
clever let's put something like rook f8
on okay but the problem is that this
move queen g3 and it's kind of hidden
resources in my opinion queen g3 tethers
you to g7 you cannot take with the pawn
because the queen's hanging and you
cannot take with the queen because rook
takes g7 uh i'm simply taking on e5 you
don't have enough defenders this just
loses to rook takes g7 right
so
there's still practical problems that
rajabov has to solve the engines really
wanted to stick this bishop on f6
because f4 is coming in every single
position wow now let's go back to that
if the bishop was on f6 would we just do
like a king walk bye-bye type of deal
once the bishop got to f6 that was let's
say bishop e7 bishop c4 bc4 bishop e7
way back when yeah instead of accepting
like this yeah yeah
idea let's say i get the bishop to f6
let's say the rook moves first of all
and then bishop to f6 yeah and then
doris is basically asking is is black
getting on
his sneakers and just running i i don't
think so i think the rook the king just
stays on between f7 and g8
no real chance of bringing it all the
way to the queen side there's too many
pieces for white especially a queen
coming to h3
remember the king itself is a good
defender the king itself holds the g7
pawn so there will be we there will be
many sacrifices that i cannot execute
but the king is still there i think
queen e7 rook e6 are the type of moves
of consolidation that the engines like
and they really don't think there's any
compensation
as it stands right now
very difficult for black to beat bat
the initiative perhaps a more deceiving
initiative than one would have thought
at the beginning all right i'm just
going to turn our attention to the game
of ding lauren and ikaru because again
such a hugely important game to our
standings it's the fight for second
place the players have reached
this position a little bit earlier i
went back a few moves
rook d2 knight f6 and again from cara's
point of view every trade yeah you know
every trade gets them
closer and closer
to the coveted draw
rook takes knight takes d7
rook to d1 inviting by the way knight
takes c5 how how many trades do you want
to make garu said
not that one let me go over here knight
f6
and scare you a bit that i'm going to
grab this pawn you want to trade my h5
pawn for your e5 pawn ass dingler in
no
knight g4
wow okay uh
bishop back to c5 and
is this an invitation to repeat
the position
with knight f6
um
it could simply be hey my bishop is away
i want to go with d7
yes exactly so the night job back just
to kind of like
cause that little hiccup i'm not going
pardon me i'm not going to allow you to
drop in on d7 in the meantime once again
i'll just kind of scare you that i'm
going to be making moves i don't know
like a5
potentially but also
like i am not adverse to
grabbing this pawn knight takes h5
um
it still feels like the game's finally
balanced uh i don't
maybe white's a little for choice it's
it it's tough for me to say
um and finally
what was the other day you're going to
have so much fun with the nepal game
no
you don't want the net poking yeah i do
want the napkin no i was going to say
this game between fabi and farouja sure
looks locked up
look at this they played exactly
what
that guy was pretty
good who was that probably the first
ever grand nation of india
was that geezer was that what you called
him what what was that geezer senior old
teaser get it right get it right you
know like
should be you know pin perfect
um the old geezer got it right uh was
that
he you know what the really crazy part
of this position before king g7 is in my
opinion yeah
is that
every logical move is zero
what every logical move is here kg7 i
think is the human approach calculated
this variation that vishy did right get
into this end game give the piece back
but there are some insane moves that i
thought this just has to lose
immediately and it's just a draw queen
d2 was one
allowing queen takes g6 just moves the
king
crazy and it says that you need to make
a perpetual check here
and since you're up that's this much
material it's white that actually has to
find the moves which is kind of crazy
rookie three only move you would think
that this is a killing blow not only
does it look like a killing blow check
this out the top four moves of the
engine all zeroes you can chose bishop
g5 you can choose bishop h4 you can take
on d6 you can throw in queen d1 first
all of them zero
wow i know it's kind of funny uh instead
of queen d2 which looks completely
illogical this move was also fine
yeah you take on g6 this was i think
vichy's first desire was to play rook
takes d6 and the engine thinks this end
game you got two bishops yeah my king's
exposed but who cares you don't have any
pieces pawn on d6 is dangerous i think
this is dangerous right the engines
don't care they think black's completely
fine what nepo did
zero zero as well it seems that unlike
the previous candidates where dingleran
took advantage of the fact that nepo was
celebrating his victory this one it
seems that it's still a game
but
favorite result should be a draw both
sides with connected past pawns
eventually f4 g4 f5 coming black still
has b5 before coming as well you can see
some scenarios in which the pawns get
swapped right so draw heavy favorite i
think
in this game between duda and nepo
wow
quite a wild game it sure is i mean i'm
just i i'm amazed about that uh
zeros and there's four ways that black
could make a draw and white should make
a perpetual are you kidding me i would
actually terrify a little back to where
alondra was saying is all zeros
yeah this was this moment where queen e4
and king g7 so what alejandro was saying
was like you played this move queen d2
reminding uh white that the rook
give me that pawn are you kidding me and
give me another check and
you know i think a lot of playful with
very
zealously you know get those checks and
maybe they might pause it right here
instead and they might get in the remove
rook e3 right so basically what he said
was that after check on e8 king g7 rook
e3
black has four ways of making a draw i'm
like what right and they include bishop
g5 just
getting ready for a rook check they
include bishop h4 gift me the pawn
stopping rook takes g3
and
if you want this check also draws a game
and i'm like every single move i like
really really really
wow alejandra that that's crazy that
that's just
insane to me that uh black has
four different ways of forcing a draw
like i'm tasered
[Laughter]
i would be terrified to allow queen
takes g6 king
g7 looks very logical and the players
quickly
went to this position where
uh a draw is
the expectation
yeah
well i mean
my world is rocked that was a strong
what can i say exactly you just won the
tournament really really amazing dingler
in hikaru uh whoa uh
things actually heating up in our our
very key match up here
um
icaru did not
go for knight f6
and uh attack the pawn on h5 why not
like why why did he repeat i have no
idea he he jumped with
bishop to h4
inviting rook d7 check the king dropped
back
and now because f2 is well on pre
g3 bishop
back and we're caught up with the
players
and first impressions are
dingler in this happy he's he's
he's put his
rook on the seventh ring for crying out
loud alejandro and he's walking with his
king and he's preparing king to e2 and
f3
um
what's going on they just think this is
still zero zero but you gotta find a
move here for black i think that if you
get the move king e2 yeah then the
moment that you move this rook from a8
rook a7
is a reply and then you start bothering
the pawns right so probably you have to
play rook d8 right now okay so that
looks logical yeah so that one rook for
example here yeah you have rook d3 and
you start harassing on the third rank
something you don't have if i get my
king to e2 that's why i think this is a
tempo dependent move okay uh but i think
that if he does play rook data black has
no problems like
if rook d3 is pretty strong yeah it's
kind of an annoying idea and if you take
i think you have absolutely nothing
yeah the engineers don't think you have
anything at all i have to ask if not
rick d8 yes
is there any other tempting idea not a
lot of logical moves in my opinion the
only thing i can think of is knight f6
attacking both pawns yeah but once you
see rookie seven it's an awkward move at
the beginning but when you once you see
rookie 7 this pawn on e5 is much more
valuable than h5 right and if you ever
push this pawn this knight just loves
life right this knight is currently
stuck on b3 would love to be on d4 you
do not want to push the pawn e5 you
start realizing not so easy to defend
this guy you can land on the move rook
e8 but since the rook is not on the
default it's on the passive e file here
i can go real k7 harass this guy rook d8
is neither a difficult move nor do i
think there's too many options hikaru
has this still well within drawing range
but he does have to play this move i
just don't think it's a harder one for
him exactly i
completely agree with rook d8 i love
that move
rook d3 as an answer
uh to rook a7 but rook the eight and if
i can get rid of this guy right that's a
strong guy then i'm really happy my king
will
make a quick dash to the center of the
board knight f6 will harass the h5 pawn
and i wouldn't feel at all
uncomfortable as black in that ending so
i think rook t8 is an easy
is an easy find let's just jump back to
the game of fabi for just a moment
because again a couple of games easily
kind of got away from us
and these two players again if
if it was a different tournament and
it would be very easy to for us to
imagine
that
this game could be for first place but
you're decisive in a different universe
exactly exactly and
well
first impressions are the fabi's a happy
camper he's got a majority on the king's
side
this knight on e4 is doing a great job
protecting f2
stopping the bishop from moving and
first impressions are that he could play
like f2 f3
nail the knight in the center of the
board
um
he's got a number of moves rook d3 rook
d1 i think a trade of rooks one trait of
rooks would benefit white and on a
really good day
uh dorsa you put a pawn on h4 and a
knight on g5 it does look nice and uh
the king could easily come under uh
duress so i like white's position but
it's still
there's a lot of converting to go i mean
i don't think
um
it's anywhere decisive but i i would
prefer what i have to ask because of the
pawn structure i don't play berliners
black i tried
not my thing i always disliked the end
games um
and so for me the one thing that
berlin had
as black was that
the pawn structure yeah what do i do in
the end game i don't like this pawn
structure sure so now that this is a
stuff it's a little bit more traded off
piece less pieces available now
my thinking is i would love to play
opponent game as white absolutely so
it would probably be a good strategy to
just get pieces off the board trade yeah
but also uh
you know
one of the things is is is you have this
static advantage you have this majority
uh this long term advantage so it's a
trump
and it's a trump that you can look
forward to but at the same time you
don't have to necessarily rush and say
that's the only advantage i have in the
position is this majority you gotta look
around and you kind of say to yourself
okay
maybe i could on a good day go h4r
knight g5 put my rook i don't know on e8
maybe black's king
is vulnerable so in other words
look as deeply into the position as
possible say what can i do what what
what's good for me
about the position and conversely from
black's point of view i think
black might be looking at his bishop and
saying you know like how can i
you know
redirect my bishop should i be looking
to bring it to i don't know the e5
square should i be playing for h4
and h3 and you know you develop these
ideas and for me that's what chess is
this is a great battle of ideas and
whose
trump is better than the other players
so i i like this game i i will
definitely keep an eye on it and i
wanted to go to the peace sacrifice game
yes richie's game
and to see what has happened so they did
the the things that
no
i mean we were actually thinking that
we've gotta somehow get rid of this
piece
bishop f8 rook f5
and we didn't see
f4
felt comfortable when they were looking
at us but that looked
okay in this particular case because the
bishop is still on the board we don't
have this
automatic and very nice that would be
nice yeah the knight on d7 is not
hanging
in this case we could go king f8 so
the desirable f4 was prepped
by the move rook f5 now what is going on
here
yeah exactly
so what i was thinking was instead of
rook f5 why not queen h3 i'm preparing a
four i might want to do a little nice
five i'm it's yeah that's that's a nice
piece that i'm i think
thank you
and so um the i'm trying to see like
maybe something like rookie seven
preparing more defenders uh
well first of all defending uh the
knight um
there's also bishop but one of the
things that rook f5 uh definitely i find
attractive why because i'm a pawn
grubber if i could get the queen to go
to stuart i'm picking an incredibly bad
square i'm doing this purposefully just
to
express laughing about the pawn grabber
yeah exactly uh you know i've won a pawn
it's like i've played f4 i've opened up
the diagonal and i feel like
i've got black on a back foot
queen g3 rook g5
again queen a6 is a really really
egregiously bad move um but this feels
like white's getting some good
compliments going
you know
this reminds me
on our rest day i had one of my students
he's a nine-year-old kid very nice and
you know we're doing the in person
instead of zoom and we're talking and
talking and we get to a position and i'm
like explaining to him how there's
always a but you know there is whatever
you do in life there's pros there's cons
it's not that different in chess and
this uh and i think i broke the kid a
little oh but he was just like what
there's no perfection but that's a
different story here rookie five is like
that you are kind of kicking the queen
away to eat the pawn but you're giving
that queenish form to the opponent so
it's really it's such a hard balance to
figure out
well
where is my good where is my um
oh
we're hearing stuff so we're just gonna
give the table to alejandra take it away
alejandra enjoy enjoy thank you for that
transition
this game between dingle and ren and
hikar nakamura we expected the move rook
d8 i thought that solved all of hikaru's
problems instead he played the bishop
very awkward in my opinion bishop d8
what what what what strange i guess the
idea of bishop i guess i really don't
like the idea anyway is to play a5 i'm
still trying to decipher this move the
engine was adamant about it but even if
you didn't play the move you can play f4
try to simplify i didn't like that
either because it gave access to the d4
square as i had said for the night
knight f6 i found weird and i thought
just rook d8 has to be the move so
really the only thing that you're scared
here
is that this endgame is bad
and it does require a little bit of
finessing bishop d6 here and once you've
realized that this knight lands here and
that pawn is on a6 attack then this king
can't really
walk in
maybe you get a bit scared but
well you realize a5 is a move if you're
hikaru nakamura the best one of the best
calculators in the world you realize
that knight b7 takes
looks really dangerous
but this pawn is just running
so you can't actually play knight
anywhere
you don't catch the pawn yeah and even
if you didn't have the move a5 this
actually works as well just swap the
bishops and when you take on a6 put this
king on d6 this king is on d6 perfectly
fine holding this one and remember
there's a pawn in h5 i can pick up later
right it's not going in it's not going
anywhere it's not gonna be defended by
anybody this one was on h4 we talk about
the zen game differently right even then
i think that black has plenty of
activity but with the power on h5 this
should be an easy draw retreat the
knight pick up this guy because this
knight on c on a6 is very far away from
the king's side action
instead he's played the move bishop d8
immediately
digler and replied with the move rook b7
and quickly f4 on the board which is the
best move by the engine but the engines
already hate black's position
not a surprise because this rook is
locked in
yeah it's kind of weird to explain these
moves uh not only that but i like 14th
round you're you're winning the d4
square you're winning the yeah maybe
even the c5 square for the knight on b3
and every white piece
is superb right you have to take i mean
if you take twice i think you have to go
knight f6 otherwise why are you playing
like this correct but you mentioned it
yourself knight d4 takes f5 not a lot
not a difficult move actually put the
knight on e6
i mean the rook on a8 makes a woeful
impression yeah you have a couple of
good pieces so it's black no you have
one good piece of black the bishop on f6
when i put my knight on his six your
knight's actually trapped this is
looking bad for hikaru he's looking
really bad for hikaru i don't know it
was yesterday or the uh earlier in the
tournament you mentioned something like
rooks like open files right yeah rooks
like seven trains they love
the seventh rank i mean
the whole point of the open fire was to
get to the uh invade
and our
hugely critical game between hikaru
dingler and that's a huge stumble i
thought rook d8
uh is so
suggestive i i i it's really hard to
comprehend uh what hicaro was thinking
i mean
i'm confused my brain hurts looking at
ding's space he's like wait a second am
i having a chance and also help me uh
alejandro with the game of a team or for
just a second
it i mean i understand this is a very
nice little
uh trap where you can go
uh for bishop f8 and it's sort of like
you get to hose and trade uh a lot of
things but
is this
no i i believe that was the best chance
that white had with knight takes e5
because the way the game is going down
in the game oh boy oh boy for white
he played knight d2 yes
followed by rook e6 so i just want to
bring my rook to h6 and just check my
channel okay uh i'm i'm confused uh
what's going on maybe there's something
in the air like like is this a strange
round or is it just me it's the 14th
round
in a in a game three of these games
don't matter right let's be honest they
just don't matter right okay nepo can
lose he can win he can draw we won't
remember
do the same we won't really remember how
this game ends
we will vaguely remember
i will i mean this isn't nice i mean
this is not a very good game by richard
right right but i feel he's just playing
chess he's just having some fun he threw
in some pieces
he's getting wrecked i mean there's no
compensation for this piece right you
put this in an engine the engine just
says come on this is ridiculous right
you shouldn't play like this
uh
the only game that's really relevant to
our standing is going to be the digler
end game okay so
when you look at these games 14 rounds
of chess
people
kind of mentally checking out
it's not a mystery that we have really
weird games
and i think this is what happening to
richie richie is having trouble coming
up with
the concrete ideas this is also like
this doesn't come close to working every
move that black can play here is minus
four
that number behind you yeah minus 4.7 is
very serious
you're up a piece rook h6 rook h6 is a
queen h6 is the easiest move according
to the engine just don't allow takes
clear and you're also more or less
trapping this rook rook g6 at some point
will come the engines are pretty
cold-blooded
after f4 they just take
show me show you where the money is
right take queen h6 again an extra piece
where's the real threats in this
position you got
nothing right you got one pawn that's it
yep
there's no compensation i mean in under
normal circumstances team or rajabo
should just win this game easily right
uh for our international audiences
missouri is the show me stake
so i mean timor's asking this alien
question what do you got i mean show me
what you got for the queen h6 looks
really good rook g6
just came on uh the board and you were
mentioning that that this rook on f5
might feel a little trapped
ideas of rook takes g1 and bishop e6 uh
yeah white's attack just feels like it
just went belly up and it rotated a
little bit
yeah i just
agreed uh this extra extra piece team or
rajaboff what a second half remarkable
we're going to take a break door set i'd
like and it's a commercial break in fact
and we will see you on the other side of
our brick
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to our live
coverage of the 14th and final round of
the 2022 candidates we have a result and
yes we can confirm
that jan
nepo our tournament winner went through
undefeated uh quite
an exceptional result and our
congratulations to him yet again
as uh he's done something that no other
player in the field has done
undefeated plus
five
wow you have to go back
to um
juan
here's our challenger of course uh yes
but i'm thinking vessel and topolof you
have to go back to vessel and topolof to
find as good a result even our uh
guest vishy said he overdid it
with his plus pie very very impressive
uh great result and he makes a draw
today with duda a very interesting game
actually
it was a fun game i mean no it's okay
what i was looking for that was not a
solid game it was a fun game
that had uh
plenty of content in it um i want to go
very quickly to the game of ding
versus ikaru because this game is
for
uh the second place
and whether that's going to be crucial
or not we will see
but after the move king g2
uh knight e
95 we were just
on our break we were looking at this
uh variation
with alejandro rook takes e4 king f3
knight takes f2 and at first blush
you're thinking
well that's two pawns what's going on
there is this very powerful move knight
e2
threatening bishop takes c5 the rook is
trapped and that would be a huge
advantage for white which explains
knight e5 knight f5
f3 check and knight c4 on the board
during our break we really really liked
ding's position
alejandro how good is it it's very good
for ding the engines are giving him a
plus three advantage it's a humongous
lead with the move bishop e7 currently
that is the most logical move because
this rook is currently attacking the
pawn on e4
if i take on f3 you don't take that side
you got an id to check and you take the
central pawn and that's why the engine
wants to stick something on e7 i think
bishop e7 is the more logical it comes
with the stronger threat yeah bishop
takes f6 just wins the game so you have
two choices you can go with the bishop
somewhere you can go to b2 it doesn't
really matter but here i take on f3 i
give you one of the pawns on the queen
side and the central majority especially
with the weakness of the king and the
pawn on g7 this pawn on h5 is awesome
clearly black is in a lot of trouble
here
not just dead dead but definitely in a
lot of trouble and if you take on e7
then after knight takes e7 you're gonna
be checked no matter where the king goes
so king f7 knight f5 is a disaster king
f8 is a little less bad but after this
exchange of this pawn again for that
pawn you can't really go knight d2 in
this variations because when you drop
uh this knight on e4
then you have knight e7
is that a winning king of planning games
yeah it's not close it's not close the
take take take king f5 here and you'll
go here eventually and because you have
an extra tempo
with the pawns wow you get f3 in this
position uh you have to go
kinky at some point yeah and we all know
this pattern right yeah you put the pawn
on f6 and eventually as i said you run
to that side right after picking up
something on the king's side so
easily winning is this end game not that
hard to calculate at this level
even if it wasn't winning you can
imagine that bishop b7 is correct
meanwhile in the rajabov game
this one is over
uh
richie just resigned he was down a piece
lost the compensation completely here
after the move bishop e7 e6 we left it
off somewhere here right this move rook
fade was killer uh if you take on d7 i
take on f5 and remember nobody is
defending this knight on g5
it's what we talked about though if you
have more pieces tactics tend to end up
working for you
but knight f7 was played bishop takes f7
why not pawn takes bishop e6 and that
was the end of the game because if you
trade off i'll just capture on d7 in the
next move and you are up are you down a
piece for a pawn at this level of chess
no contest whatsoever
richard just threw in the towel another
suicidal game by him with the white
pieces and timur nom nom nom thank you
for the point he is currently in clear
he has he finished the tournament with
plus one how many people would have
looked at this tournament and thought
timor jabo is finishing with a plus one
score not a lot
yeah wait did i hear that currently is
it clear third
clear
clear third because somebody is going to
take clear second we just don't know who
it is
nakamura well he'll be tied for a third
right if ding passes him yeah i guess
bobby wins that always three were three
right there
two two players tight but i agree with
you wholeheartedly if i was a betting
man and and thinking about timor's
results say after round eight or round
nine and you said timor was finishing
plus one
you'd go okay what are the odds and i
would have thought they were huge but he
comes out of nowhere he destroyed
round twelve dingler in with the black
pieces and he wins again
with the black pieces when you force
timor to play
he will lie
he will bite right oh yeah wow
congratulations to
uh timor on a superb
finish and let's just check in on fabi
versus
whoa alireza the whole
did the board just like disappear like
what the heck we were more or less these
parts
and i was trying to explain that i
actually liked
the position of fabi bobby captured on
h4 i'm a pawn grubber but
really
uh
messing up the structure that badly
um
whoa
um
things really had changed dramatically
in this game
it's one two three
and it's whoa
holy smokes uh
fabi's in trouble like serious trouble
here
what the heck just happened
he's down a pawn and this a pawn is
actually a real bruiser
hold on what am i missing knight e
six rook f7 you're not missing anything
if i was just in trouble
really yeah oh i mean he's up he's down
upon and that's a bishop against the
knight that's all you have to look at it
whether you can convert this easily
that's another question there's
materials very reduced you have to make
sure that you keep all your pawns kind
of tidy but
it's a pawn
taking on h4 was just weird so did i
completely misjudge the position though
i thought that was better f4 here on
white is for choice according to the
engines f4 was a logical move because it
puts uh the pawn on g3 as the base
which is not being attacked by both of
the rooks right that makes a lot of
sense king comes to g2 so
yeah white was a bit better in this
position you had the majority on the
king side you might as well push it
but this move gh
strange he didn't have to get in trouble
necessarily afterwards but he kind of
lost his way after the move b5
when we were on um
right yes uh when opponents when black
played h4 could white just be like okay
i'll let you be you'll just go king g2
sure i i i actually liked f3 followed by
king g2 but maybe king g2 immediately
um
yeah it's just this move g3 takes h4
that really messed up the
white's entire
kingside structure and
eight
this could be a very costly
loss i want to say uh suddenly
i'm i'm just catching up with the
players because i'm still kind of like
shocked that uh
that uh
things have turned so dramatically here
and it's an extra pawn and like you say
it's bishop versus knight this is a very
nice combination of pieces so
ali raza
sh should be winning this should be a
technical ending
what's going on with fabby i didn't see
this coming at all uh alejandro
falling apart yeah he's falling apart in
the second half unrecognizable is
fabiano caruana ever since the second
half started it felt that he never
recovered fully from this goose egg that
hikaru nakamura
imparted on him right right and since
then he's not been the same favi and
just to echo the words of vichy as well
that he felt
that fabi had the type of position that
he would regularly convert against
dingler in yeah you know he's a pawn up
uh he didn't deserve to have this
winning position but he got it
and then he lost it yeah and he lost it
he didn't even draw it wow
so
second half of time something really not
really uh we'll we will ask fabi when we
get the chance um you know when he's
recovered i think from next tournament
alejandro should just be next to fabi
right they're best friends right kind of
work together
nursing him exactly at the very
end of the event we should put alejandro
and fabi what
exactly bishop e5 on the board but we
think that this is bad i want to again
uh turn to the dingler in
because that move that you prescribe
bishop e7 is on the board by dingler in
is he's eyeballing
the pawn on f3 very greedily
saying give me that pawn and yeah later
you can have my a3 pawn so we were
sort of like here and what did we do
we did
i'm not sure what we did actually i'll
just yeah and can i eat yeah and this is
where
uh we got into a lost
uh rook and uh pardon me a lost king and
pawn in game like this that's how it
happened i think alejandro was gonna say
okay you you get to eat over here
but then
these central pawns with the king coming
to e4
uh it's all white and how big a
evaluation does the engines
suggest
uh white's advantages three exactly
three
three three
a whole piece that's what it says
we went through some of the variations
and you're lost in every single one so
it's not
that surprising is it
no but it's just a big number too
it really is it really is oh my goodness
so
whoa um
we were confused we didn't understand
why
um
hikaru didn't repeat just around these
parts
okay just right here we saw this move
bishop
to
d6 knight to g4 bishop back to c5
and we all expected that hikaru would
play knight to f6 repeating the position
securing a second place if ding doesn't
play on instead we were mystified by
bishop h4
and where did it really start to go
wrong or has it already alejandro no you
know the answer you know the answer to
that one yesterday was not playing rook
d8 that's right i beg your pardon you're
absolutely right we do we it was here
where we expected the
this really great rook on d7 you've got
to trade it up
because the rook is ready to come down
on d3 if you go after this pawn rook d3
is black's answer with great uh play
instead
bishop d8 that was another mr
mystery move and
then suddenly
things have gone
in white's favor every move i if i was
playing as black that knight on f5 i
would and i would keep thinking that
knight used to be an e3 man exactly what
what did i do it's transformed into what
i call a thor
a nordic god of thunder i mean the
knight on f5 is just really strong like
like uh terrifyingly strong
and that is why the engines actually
think three
an advantage of three and for dingler in
uh i mean after this
this very very very painful round 12
loss
that's that's admirable that dingler in
comes back
uh
probably to take second place alejandro
it's a crazy tournament oh yes it is a
crazy unpredictable every single round
thank you
second timor rajab third what what what
what happened in the second half dingle
red and team were starting the second
half in last place wait a second
teamwork did not lose a single game in
the second half
he lost to fabian in round seven then
drop it to ali rizzo one naka draw with
nepo yeah it's only two losses are
against the americans right on the first
half in the first half he lost to hikaru
and he lost to fabi both in long drawn
end games he drew everything else in the
first half and the second half maybe
she just came back a whole different
person wow
yeah kudos to timor i mean he shows that
he's capable right i mean a much better
performance than his previous candidates
so
kudos to him
it's that fighting name it's a tamer
name man
the warrior there we go
the warrior wow um yeah
yeah i mean
this
uh we i asked uh gary kasparov a
question when he came on air i said
gary let's cut to the chase what did you
have that was right oh yeah and your
predictions because
our predictions have been so off the
chart wrong as to who
as to what we expected but
he said
that nepo's performance should not have
surprised him that the preparation
that it takes to
play a world chess championship match
the team is creating entire new
libraries of course in that from the
dubai
um
uh world championship nepo carried with
him
a lot of
understanding novelties energy that he
didn't get to show in dubai
and he came and he brought it for the
performance of his life yeah it's been a
wonderful
it's been i'm so glad to
have caught this candidate exactly it's
actually it's very wonderful but
i don't know what to say the man just
had everything he had all the answers
hopefully he also bought a few lottery
tickets exactly exactly he had all the
answers and uh bishop b2 on the board as
definitely
[Music]
hikaru is very very aware
how difficult a position he has suddenly
and
i'm seeing on your
screen
that ding is looking and there's hikaru
i mean
cairo always has these looks with the
scowls yeah the thousand faces of uh
hikaru nakamura he went to indonesia
to barobuda baraboota is the site where
they have this pyramid with the 10 000
faces of buddha
right so they have these buddha statues
on on each level of the pyramid as you
climb all the way to the top 10 000
faces of buddha this expressions of
beatific
yoga
meditation
and i'm thinking
hikaru and half the ten thousand faces
because he has so many facial
expressions but this is not a good one i
don't know if
i'm having a hard time imagining the
poker face
right
and we do have more moves i just saw
king takes f3 bishop takes a3
on the board as uh
wow oh you know what i want please i
don't know if it's gonna happen or not
but i wish i could put my king somewhere
close to their king and just go whoop
rook takes g7
and uh i'm just drinking yes no it's
okay it's a
it's a good dream thank you yeah do we
do we go like king e2 f4 e5 and
or do you i don't think a5 is any kind
of a threat by the way because once
again this bishop on e7 is is nicely
protected
covered but
okay
um you just like to move the bishop and
go whoop
that looks well
okay if we did this
first of all we got to look at knight d2
but also bishop g7 right that was why
i'd really love uh
if we dorsa i'd really love it if we
could get our king
to
out of the way play f4
e5 and then move the bishop and do what
you want rook takes g7 splat i think the
only thing that black could want is at
some point a5 hoping that white is busy
playing with the king side so black can
just eat some pawns and push them i
think that's the only thing available
for black now so for example if i i went
king g3 i'm just moving away a5
like i mean it's not like it's a dream
or something like this but uh
i mean at least black is fighting
in this kind of a situation it's you
might just still be losing by the way
this knight on f5 is so strong i gave my
opponent some chances maybe maybe uh
fair that's fair
so uh here i was thinking about
checkmate
okay how did we do it what would you
like
for
dingler i mean again
it's nice if we could get our pawns to
f4 and e5
how are we
how do we go about doing that
well if you want those you probably have
to go king g3 that's fair okay
and i like what you're saying about a5
okay
now you don't have to necessarily react
over here because you always have rook
takes b5
and nobody's going g3 was played on the
board now what i'm thinking about is i
still want that dirk takes g7 okay so
can i just move my bishop away yes
yes then
and if it's your turn i get it oh and
follow with bishop d4
now we're talking
okay
i like it i love it in fact but i may be
forced to play something ugly but then
you're welcome to take this looks
terrible maybe that's why it was plus
three
right right king g3 but we can see what
you're saying the bishop moves rook
takes g7 bishop d4 and it's shish kebab
yeah
i have to ask have you had persian food
i love persian food
and in phoenix they have an unbelievable
restaurant the persian room and i had
the most wonderful ice cream
it was a rose water ice cream
that was handmade
and it's like some ancient formula
from uh iran
and it was just so good i was like
it's to die for it it was just so so
wonderful i love middle eastern food
thank you thank you so
ice cream there much have it guys find a
local persian restaurant hit it
exactly with the rose water ice cream
look it up it's just
it's killer uh alejandra jump right in
what
what's your take on the two games that
remain
well it seems very difficult for both
sides here the americans are in huge
trouble i just don't see how hikaru gets
out of this one f4 e5 plays itself if
you give white a free hand they're gonna
go f4 e5 move to bishop and when this
bishop doesn't return to b2 that's game
over a5 is what you guys were looking at
terrible for black right b takes a5
works bishop c5 even stronger
this is just lights out
because of this move bishop before you
were mentioning yuck it's it's really
yuck you have to give up the exchange
it's completely lost so if you play king
g3 and you throw an f45 what do you do
as black he's he car is very busted
it doesn't look like it in the first
appearance of the position but the more
you try to make a couple of moves for
him it falls apart very quickly once the
spawn gets to e5 it's lost so you can't
really let it reach e5 but how do you
prevent it how do you stop it right you
can't that that's the end of the game
this one is just going to be a ton of
suffering for fabi because alaris is not
even thinking in this end game he's
bringing in the king the question is how
do you survive
how do you even put up resistance in
this position the rook's already on the
correct
position behind the pawn bishop is
better than a knight you can imagine if
you take these pieces off the board okay
probably you resign right right i mean
it's just very lost so this king is
coming in this knight has to somehow
hold the spawn
i don't see it the engines are giving
less of an advantage than i expected i
expected this to be lost lost the way
that hikaru is but the engines are
thinking it's only minus 1.6 perhaps
there's a couple of ways of finagling
difficulties for black to make progress
this is what fabi's trying to do at the
moment somehow try to make black
not easily step into the light squares
and kick out this rook on a4 once the
rook leaves a4 that's game over so very
close to a victory i think foreign
in this tournament
man
i don't understand why the engine is not
saying that white is just dead i look at
this position for my human eyes
bishop better than knight rook in the
right place came closer than the other
this should be winning anything
to be suggested for knight c5 with the
idea knight b3 yeah the issue and this
is the top engine move the problem is
that i saw this far
and i thought unless i get in d3
how about c3
c3 but if i oh no no no uh bishop i was
going to play rook c4 and i was thinking
i was trading pawns but you're not
playing pawns right because the bishop
comes back ouch
and you know what the engine says have
the pawn
have the pawn
it goes to f6 like whatever have the
pawn
yeah this one is not getting stopped
with this one with this bishop on this
long diagonal
game's over okay i i'm surprised at the
engine evaluation but it's not as over
as i thought it was
wow wow and i'm saying that
day for team usa i mean i didn't see
this coming this round 14.
what a setback uh hikaru coming into
today's round with a half a point lead
clear second and we thought
that he had almost a dream opening
trading queens training rooks
and like almost cruising to the draw
thing was
considering a professional or a
reputation yeah let's say thank you
repetition did you know he played the
bishop here the ship there and naka just
shot himself to the foot
right
and uh again i'm looking at your screen
i'm seeing a very forlorn looking hikaru
just
trying to calculate his way furiously
but recognizing
white has everything
unfortunately for
and yeah
well besides knight c5
and knight b3
what the heck could uh
can i just hopefully bring in my king
sure for the moment i'm a little bit
worried i mean okay let's go upon this
tree okay
and black is bringing his king i mean he
kind of makes a beeline towards
the
rook i want to say
check
here here
and this is this is where we're
stuck that the bishop is going to come
here and the king is still
marching towards the queen side and will
escort the pond's home
i'm i'm grasping at straws here uh help
me out alejandro i
i don't see that this looks terrible
fabi looks
gone that's what i said yep
he wants to put this knight on he's just
wonderful
and they remind me to invite him to a
party whenever we i was a student for
five years thank you though
let's let's play like an engine okay
you force let's say this bishop here and
then you try to get in with the king
okay so this king shoulders this one yes
the bishop is a bit uh passive okay the
bishop is making this rook passive but
at the same time you are kind of
tethered to the pawn on a5 because the
moment i take the pawn this bishop is
under attack right
that's why you would consider a move
like c5 but
c3 right now just trades pawns okay
doesn't really help me that much they
just want to go for the other way g5 go
rookie shape
change these pawns so not so easy just
yet to make progress there's even
checking king of five somehow this
knight is doing a good job and the fact
that this bishop has to get stuck
defending the pawn is what might save
white in this position without this
maneuver of the knight to b3 it it might
be just game over though okay
well at least you're given uh some some
kind of hope of uh
drawing the bishop back uh
that's a nice point that you were making
that when black plays c5 with the bishop
on b4 then the move c3 does just trade
pawns which is going to be very useful
for right in this position when you have
c5 i always go c3 so that this bishop
isn't anchored if the bishop's anchored
i can move my rook somewhere you take on
a5 i take on h2 i trade this pawn for
that pawn
g pawn goes cheapon goes home because
the knight's too far away gotcha
wow all right and uh since you
opened up a window of possibility there
for fabi
uh
try your hand with the the game of
hikaru no i can't i can't
that don't
machine plays this you might as well
resign really it is involving this rook
takes e4 rook takes d4 it's just
completely lost so wait wait wait wait
wait what
how do you play rook takes we analyzed
this we went here
yeah takes check here here takes and we
said rook goes somewhere and then you
take on d4 right but we also said nobody
plays like this because that's three
science right that's true so i want to
see what hikara actually comes up with
because he's on the verge of defeat he's
just a couple moves away from losing
it's these couple of moves that he needs
to figure out some kind of trick or some
kind of
is there any chief i don't see it i i
really don't see it there are some
positions in which the activity of the
pieces gives you something but again we
have also seen positions in which your
activity is so squashed
that there is no mystery that there is
no counterplay in here with this rook on
e8 close down from the rest of the
position also this bishop currently
offside you're basically down to one
good piece your king on j8 is a target
not a not a strength this knight on c4
is probably the only good move that
black the only good piece that black has
at the moment exactly and time is not a
an ally either i mean i mean
an hour
dingler in under no pressure whatsoever
and they've made comfortably their first
time control they earned their second
time control oh i see cars
nope nevermind i thought he was about to
make a move he he he did a little oh i'm
ready to make a move but
he's back thinking again
it's such a devastating position for him
i can't even well i mean i can't imagine
i've been there not candidate wise but
that that's that one game that you're
like
you know what i'm good everything has
been working out
all i need to do is just go draw right
just don't lose and your position is
helping you out and that reminds me of i
told you i i played in that um the world
youth championship 2014 in durban last
round i needed to win different
situation but i i
made my move and i didn't realize i had
made my move
uh that's you know that that pressure is
so severe that's at to this day i still
don't remember making the move that cost
me the game right i can put blackout for
like a minute or two right so that's
just such a such a
terrible pressure
i once had a experience in manila i was
playing in inner zonal and we were
playing in this
i want to say arena a basketball kind of
an arena but
it was
more like an open arena where a lot of
fresh air comes rushing through which is
very nice except we were going through a
heat wave
so you're sitting at the board you're
trying to calculate it's really hot you
know sweat is building up on your
forehead
and you close your eyes and you start
seeing stars well i've made a move
that i don't remember making something
similar to what you experienced and it
was just sort of like
looking at my score sheet it's my
handwriting
i wrote down the move and away you go it
wasn't uh
yeah that that particular inner zonal
that was that was a tough one let me ask
you yes uncomfortable question please
worst opponent you've ever had and when
i say worst i don't mean like uh
cheating or anything i mean like when
you're sitting in front of them they're
stinky or they kick you or
i've really really really been fortunate
i think my worst was probably gary gary
at the board was really ferocious but in
truth i had just the opposite
experiences i've had
people like dr john nunn alexander
beliavsky predrag nikolich
and just a whole lot of names yawned him
timon whose presence at the board
was
very welcoming right right off anderson
it would be like
you know alpha's making sure his part of
the board is clean but he's also like
excuse me could you help him you know
like
they're not there to disturb you they're
not even thinking about disturbing you
so i must admit i had the the opposite
and playing with the ladies too judith
polgar susan polgar
playing against them they were
they were incredible ladies at the board
i mean that's really wonderful i'm
assuming high level just everybody is
wonderful nobody tries to kick you under
the table scratch your hand
it was
i'm helping the guy victor korchner he's
playing against tigran petrosian
and they literally had a barrier under
the table they had a wooden barrier so
these two guys wouldn't kick each other
and i was like what
how does that even happen i've had
kickers
they hurt like my shins would hurt so i
developed a method that i would just
bring my feet under me like i would
literally you guys can see but i would
like to put my feet like this so
i just yeah exactly i just sit like this
with my legs crosstalk couldn't kick you
it got really comfortable i have to say
i still i'm so good sitting like that
right i had one player in
1975 us open i'm i'm
playing on some board it doesn't matter
200 and i'm trying to find my name did
you uh-huh
oh there it is
and it was a nice elderly gentleman
and
smartly dressed
beautiful
teeth big smile
and we started playing
and it was a very strange time control
i'm thinking 50 moves
in two and a half hours each side not 42
to 50.
and we're getting into time trouble each
of us both of us had maybe 20 minutes
for the last 20 moves and it's starting
to get uncomfortable and he had been
grimacing a lot with these beautiful
teeth and he got this glass of water and
he took his teeth out
put it in the water next to the board
and i thought well
i'm like
trying not to look at these teeth that
have been smiling at me for the last
four hours
that was a little disconcerting
i must say
yeah
so it was like like okay uh
but i've had people who are snacked at
the board i really don't like that yeah
eating at the board uh
smokers yeah i've had friends who would
be like um i had this friend and like um
i think it was yeah
this is years ago but it's like um he
would cut his chocolate before the game
so he wouldn't you know crack it or open
it so he wouldn't want to disturb the
playing hall so he would make sure that
everything like the chocolate is cut so
it doesn't have to like open the foil or
like break the chocolate i thought that
was very nice
that was not yeah i had this one i i
still laugh about it so so much uh so
anatoly line lane he's this chess
grandmaster for the soviet union he'd
come to the united states and he played
in all of these tournaments he's a
really really strong player he would win
an enormous number of open events he
played in the u.s championships but at
the board he's incredibly hyper
sensitive like you make any move with
the table like a little shake please
please stop shaking the table you're
disturbing me you know what i'm going to
say
you know you you you write your score
sheet please uh your your pen it's too
heavy why are you
pressing you know you you move the
pieces you hit the clock please don't
move the clock i mean everything the guy
is hyper sensitive he complains about
everything
so he's playing against cyrus
lochtawala the famous chess author
and cyrus had brought a snickers bar
to
and he put the snickers bar on the score
sheet and there's lane
you know just
waiting to pounce like whenever cyrus
does anything with the snickers bar
please he's disturbing it
cyrus takes a snickers bar
at a critical moment in the game of
course
and he very very very carefully
slowly tears it so that no noise is made
nothing
nothing and he does this meticulously
for minute after minute
and hannah tully is getting more and
more wound up because he can't wait to
say stop disturbing me when the guy's
doing nothing
hilarious i mean uh hilarious uh it's a
terrible fun but uh
yeah
let's update on both games uh where do
we stand we have zero moves there's
nothing zero
zero moves oh no what
what we can take a break it's all right
good update thank you
we'll be back on the other side of this
break
[Music]
st louis university celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st louis
slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe
in 2015 slu partnered with the saint
louis chess club to start a top-tier
collegiate chess team on the very first
year of the team's inception slu
obtained second best university at the
pan american intercollegiate chess
championships
higher purpose
greater good
st louis university
[Music]
founded in 1839 the university of
missouri is steeped in tradition the
recently founded mizzou chess program is
a partnership between the university of
missouri and the st louis chess club
collegiate chess has been experiencing a
meteoric rise at the national level
through its tradition of excellence
mizzou has always strived for the best
mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar by bringing our institutions
ethos of respect responsibility
discovery and excellence to the chess
board
[Music]
we're the corey family welcome to our
show
[Music]
[Music]
you guys see
[Music]
this our show now go start yours this is
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
coverage of the 2022 candidates
tournament the tournament that continues
to confound us with our predictions
nepo has put the finishing touches on a
masterly performance as he makes a nice
draw an interesting draw with duda to
complete
a great event where he goes undefeated
richie rapport as white committed
suicide
wow else to describe it against timor
rajaba
unsoundly sacrificing a piece timor
coming out of nowhere and currently in
second position of course waiting the
outcome of the game between ding lehren
and ikaru nakamura karu entered the
round a half a point to the good all he
needed was a draw bit and now
it appears that dingle ring will win
this game uh shocking once again
everybody and fabiano is actually in
deep trouble as white
against ali reza so
not a good day for team usa and again
around round 14 where
we didn't expect these types of
fireworks but we could easily have three
decisive results dorsa out of the four
games played and
that
lost awards yeah device predictions we
we keep getting it wrong
i mean
i thought i had it i truly did think
that coming to this round
um
hikaru was just gonna
make a draw go home pop a champagne make
a youtube video to have this like you
know the usual exactly but he just kind
of just imploded and exploded at the
same time
he is in really really bad shape uh at
the moment you could just
compare the pieces oh my god that's the
simplest thing to do bill o'malley
is better much better my knights better
better
the bishops better the kings
better better your king is actually and
look at the pawns this pawn on h5 e4 f3
black's pawns are stuck and in fact one
idea for white that's very suggestive is
to play the move rook eight seven and
rook takes another move for white that's
very suggestive is okay i don't even
know what i'm supposed to do is black
let me make a move for black okay just
for a moment
check and
well
it's nervy
okay and then i'm gonna go put f4 and e5
i was also a concern i'm improving
everywhere exactly no
i'm just thinking that knight on f5 is
wonderful but if we want to push it we
could also just put that knight to d5
and just put it in center [ __ ]
opponents
oh sorry that that's uh
also a very nice idea as you're just
eyeballing you can't even go to e5
knight f6 it looks terrible it's just i
mean everything in white's favor
no real counter play no real counter
chances i want to say white's king is
just excellent
and uh again uh for ali reza he is a
pawn up and he has got a very nice
combination of rook and bishop versus
rook and knight and furthermore
his rook is actually behind
the past pawn so it's all going
technically
very very well and i see
every time i see um
naca
at the board you know going back and
forth
your eyes are drawn to his
expressions even though i can't read
them
he always seems to be suffering
yesterday he was happy you know he was
laying back and you know just like well
the point when he really had the game in
hand
he often looks like he's scowling even
when he is
in a superior position yeah poor guy um
anything you can offer us uh alejandro
it's just it it looks bad for team usa
yeah uh i think the only chance really
is favi saving this game hikaru is just
very far gone yeah it's a plus five
advantage we don't even wanna look at
that right this one
perhaps a little bit more on the
holdable side we have a couple of moves
kg2 king f790 whoops
knight d2 and after bishop c3 this move
knight e4 a little bit kg not going to
b3 directly instead going to e4
attacking the bishop right away if the
bishop goes here then maybe i can move
c3 and perhaps in one good day get this
knight to c4 before this bishop finds
his way into defending this pawn so
that's why i think alireza is stuck a
little bit after this move knight e4
spending eight minutes already the
engines actually want to repeat moves
the move bishop e5 knight d2 and here
just go king e6 knight b3 you do have
bishop c bishop c3 and we know that in
this kind of positions even if you lose
the c7 pawn this is going to be a very
powerful pawn the trick here go bishop
e7 so you don't lose this pawn as well
right you don't want to lose this pawn
as well bishop f8 also works but this is
more natural to get on the f6 diagonal
and start pushing this guy as long as
you can get the rook out of there the
pawn on c7 is not that important
remember you do have to keep
g7 alive it's your last spot and this is
what is giving favi those drawing
chances let's see if carlos made a move
hikaru made the move bishop c1 the
engines well they give a lot of ways to
win pretty much immediately bishop d4 is
one rook a7 looks very logical 97
everything everything wins here for
dingle run
absolutely we do have a move on ali raza
he did play bishop b4 encouraging c3
does that mean
perhaps yeah i i would think that
that if we could for example we just
play c3 and drive the bishop back the
difference is now as we were saying you
want to get the knight to c4 and the
pawn
is being
captured
maybe something like bishop to d6
would like to see knight to the b3
something of this nature where
um the bishop but this is a different
animal when the then when the bishop was
on b4 the bishop on b4 was a lot more
aggressively placed you could go king
here king here and easily break up
white's coordination
um
okay
fabi
may be getting some chances here
king
king
f3
to come to the game so fair well one of
the things that we were thinking is that
it would be probably in black's favor to
trade off the a-pawn for the pawn and
get this pawn on g5
uh okay king f3 pardon me is on the
board why did i take that back
i'm assuming king e6 actually let's um
i'm curious what if the rook does go to
high it's just c3 and just kick that
bishop yeah
sure okay okay uh you're i thought that
the king
might be over here by the time you were
trying to push the spot so
pawn trades definitely white would be
happy about king of three king e6 on the
board c3 also
sorry king of three
king e6 c3 we've caught up with the
players i don't think that time is a
factor no i don't believe so no um i
believe they have what like 40 minutes
uh yeah fabian's 40 fear is just 36.
okay so this bishop is coming back we
don't know where let's just put it on a
square for now logical and let me
make an attempt to try to win this pawn
knight to c4 now again you can play
c6 and drop the bishop back for
defensive purposes
um
okay
what else right
what else to do c6
knight here
gift need the pawn
bishop here oh
i wish there was a check
pick up something
nice horses
king e4
it's it's going to take some effort
still for uh farouja to break through
right uh alejandro as i mentioned it's
not
the move bishop b4 was not the one
preferred by the engines right and at
this point it does seem difficult to
make progress it's basically nice to go
back as you mentioned
and i think e3 is
fine king here king here and the thing
is this it doesn't matter where this
king reaches the only thing that matters
is if it reaches b5 okay because that's
where it kicks out the rook but it's not
so easy to get there even when you get
that there are some positions where i
will have some counterfeit here i think
king c4 is the more natural move
keep this king at bay
and then try to make black make progress
in this position it's not so easy you
can target h2 but i always have row k2
to defend it if i need to this king is
going to come to b3 and i finally have
this pawn more or less under control
because it is pushing on a light square
on a4 not easy in my view to make
progress already for ferruja the engines
went from minus two to minus one
exemplifying that they also don't think
that the progress is obvious anymore for
the black side okay so something for
us to cheer about a little bit
um
hikaru's position it's almost like it's
such a
disaster you almost don't
want to see yeah like what's going on
here
because again
everything about the position uh you
know the comparison of the pieces is
just so
in white's favor the knights the bishops
versus one another
interesting that the okay
no complaints about this move
but uh
i must say that for myself personally
it would you want the other
if we eat a6 first then bring the roof
to g6a and then eat g7
we have in america the u.s united states
department of agricultural the usda
department they they give their seal of
approval nice you know this is
definitely i like what you said the seal
of improvement and he did it rook takes
a6 slide your rook over to g6
and that
is just
bad news if you let me of my next move
i'm going to pre-move rook g6 unless you
play knight e5
right and then in that case you'll go
back pretty much uh
yeesh uh losing the a6 pawn for
absolutely nothing uh
alejandro
no me gusta i'm just excited if even if
let's say you know we can't eat g7 plant
right now would you still want to eat
beef five pawn also also uh
can i have another
uh b6 you're you're absolutely right i
would be
very very tempted by that check doesn't
seem to bother me i think uh we'll just
step back
king g2 should
be fine
don't see any problems here
it's it's all it's traffic all
all in one direction and unfortunately
for hikaru's fans it's terrible
uh we do have our colleague in
madrid anastasia has caught up with a
couple of the players we're going to
feed you some interviews but first
one with duda
[Music]
the tournament is over
so what can you say what would be the
what was the outcome of this event here
yeah it's kind of happiness it's over
because um i think i actually played a
little bit better than the result may
indicate but
actually i don't know what's the reason
why they were here
it's kind of difficult to say that's
resistance
um i guess i just
maybe i wasn't withstanding the pressure
at crucial preferred moments because it
was usually like around 14 moves so
um
yeah however there is and
i will have
i mean a lot of conclusions i guess from
this tournament so in that that aspect
it's it's fine yeah as you mentioned it
was actually um you can just tournament
it was the first time that you
participated there so the difference is
this enormous pressure probably but can
you say that you have done everything
you prepared a lot because we heard the
news that you were preparing for a few
months
so what do you think yes yes i did uh
perhaps i should have played some
classical tournament along the way
because my last uh classical tournament
priority candidates was in bygone z
actually was in january so that was
i mean every year and perhaps i was
playing a bit you know like so
intuitively like playing faster time
controls so um
i mean it was kind of i guess difficult
to adjust so
yeah definitely i mean i have done
something wrong because
otherwise i mean
i wasn't in minus three
yeah but today's game was a very
interesting fight and uh very happy with
the special g6 move to it
yes
yeah actually it seems so surprising and
so
um so in that aspect it was fine now i
mean
[Music]
i mean we got kind
kind of tense position after the opening
and
my opponent was under pressure but so
was i
and uh
yeah i wasn't feeling like particularly
you know like happy about my position
like i knew he was just okay but
acquired a lot of calculations and
i mean today i wasn't i was kind of
sleepy actually
so
probably wasn't like the best position
you know to get but
yeah i mean i guess it was kind of
probably a very logical game i mean
relatively in taking into account
uh how complicated it was
yeah uh and what are your future plans
what are they going to do for this event
yeah they were playing olympia in
chennai in two weeks yeah poland
actually performed quite well in the
olympics and what are you looking
forward this time
yes you are looking to
have a good time again
in chennai and hopefully i get some
model
thank you very much
in the next tournament thank you
thank you anastasia and thank you duda i
mean uh when you've had a bad tournament
you just want to leave you just want to
leave so he was being very gracious and
sharing his time
but
the polish team uh alejandro
that's going to be a very very strong
team in chennai i mean
they have wichita yes
the
the fellow who's always helping
uh
i'm running i get his names wrong
he he he helped
vishy kayowski
again kayevsky yes yeah no but is not
playing i know he'll be like a coach a
trainer i think for the team yeah i
actually don't know what the polish team
is i assume it's voitacic duda i want to
say purune right maybe bartel
oh bartella forgot about them
i'm trying to just go down the rating
list and see it's on chess results so
you can see the sales results
that's much easier yeah the teams have
already been submitted for the lineups
so if you want to if you're curious and
who's playing the olympia and who's not
playing the olympia go to
chessresults.com uh there's a dash
somewhere between chess and results and
it's got it it's already got the lineups
for the men and the women right for both
sections we got the open and the women
sorry and we have all of the players
already
189 teams plus the last indian team 190
teams already uh figured out so no
mysteries anymore uh i wanted to ask i
mean with
vishy
as our guest when he said 189
that sounded to me like an olympic
record that's 189
an olympic record uh
i mean what there's only
200
202 countries in the entire world i
guess it depends how you count them but
yeah something along those lines we got
we got most of them well yeah we sure do
so uh that's going to be one of the most
well attended uh events and we we
we're looking at the open section for uh
for paul
yeah because we were talking about it so
i i brought it up but i might have some
point on scene
casper uh yeah put your prune right
thank you yeah that's
and uh bartel
and bartow matus and for for the women's
section it's also quite interesting i i
knew that
is married to kashlinskaya i remember
that from years ago but i didn't realize
that she'd switch federations and good
for her i think she just switched i
think alina kashlinskaya traditionally a
russian player right um
transferred very very recently a few
months ago she's been
married to wichita's likes for like
seven years now and she's been living in
poland but yeah they've been married
forever i remember they were married in
qatar masters seven years
that's forever
she's relatively young so that's that's
quite a long time but yeah quite a lot
of fun
wonderful alejandra will have to give us
all updates from chennai when he's back
um i'm just looking at the game of
dingler and hikaru i was a little bit
surprised after 97 check king h8 for
some reason what was really going on in
my mind was your maneuver knight d5 to
just
hunt down this bishop essentially and
try to
drive it off the long diagonal if you
could successfully
reposition your bishop here you're super
charged you're super happy
i mean uh alejandro will say like you
know it's overkill already at this point
i agree yeah
and you're totally overkill
it doesn't matter guys you don't have to
put your knight anywhere just pick up
the pawn on b5 like nothing's defending
it
it's not
just just pick it up then you're up two
pawns
yeah then what do i do
and then you push them and then you push
them and then you go back you you you
take the pawn you go back and you push
it there's no way there's no way to
improve black's position yeah i mean you
got your knight to e6 so what you get
you're you can't get your king out of
where it is you can't stalemate it
either we know the rook can't leave the
eighth rank because of the checkmate
patterns on f8 and h8
there's nothing there's no counter play
this this game is dead dead we wouldn't
be looking at this game if it wasn't so
important for the results exactly i'm
still in shock that naka allowed that
truck to come to d7 and stay there
a while back after we we invaded the
seventh rank yes it was such a
comfortable just like okay this is a
better rook my rook is kind of sucky
sucky let's just get him off the board
for those who are joining us late this
is the specific position that dorsa is
speaking about this you look around
strategically speaking this rook is
really really good
this rook is not in fact this rook is
actually very bad
therefore the rook d8 is very suggestive
if you try to maintain your rook on the
seventh rank
instant counter play after rook d3
hitting the knight hitting the pawn
if you're forced to trade the rooks
who is favored by that trade well it's
no question it's black because the rook
on d7 is very good yeah
in fact rook d8 is so obviously
needed that we didn't look at anything
else and most
certainly we did not consider
the actual move that fabi played uh
pardon me that he played that hikaru
played uh bishop d8 this was a stunner
and to be fair for dingler
if this was a online chess i would think
ah he misclicked he wanted he clicked on
d8
yeah yeah
right like for sure
and uh it wasn't
it wasn't uh
just a very very few moves later that
everything has already gone south
and
the position is so one-sided there's
nothing to talk about
and by the way alejandro the question
has fabby done enough to save
his bacon certainly seems that ali reza
has misplayed this position the engine
is hating how he's become so passive in
so many positions had the bishop on b4
and c3 but not only was the bishop
defending the pawn it was also locking
out this rook right currently it seems
that
favi got his pieces exactly where they
need to be the king could go to d5 but i
assume this knight will return to b3 you
could also put it somewhere else but i
like it on b3 because both pieces are
now stuck
defending the pawn on a5 so what is the
winning plan here
i'm not sure i really don't know what
alirez is planning to do because i can
always make a passing move king d3 at
some point i can give a check and return
to a4 i don't really have any zooxant
possibilities
so i'm not going to be worried about
that i'm just going to put the king on
d3 and i'm going to be waiting for you
to transfer your rook to h8 to hopefully
do something
but the immediate even immediately this
idea of just giving you checks is not so
easy to
to repel yeah and when simple things
like that are difficult to repel
it becomes exceedingly hard
to push the pawn
so
i'm not really sure what where alireza
is going with this the engines think
that the advantage has hugely dissipated
it's now down to minus 0.5 not even a
full pawn
so it's pretty high chances i would say
that favi ends up saving this one
uh continue that variation you were
saying king d5 knight b3 c5 c5 i would
just put the king here and then i want
to go rook c8 i want to threaten
c5 c4 check
and i assume that after this take you
have rook a8 that was what it's all
about i'm banking on this shot the
problem is the shot doesn't work right i
have this check and where's your king go
i gotta go to e6 and then here i have
knight b3 or knight b7 i don't know if
there's a difference oh
those
the tricky knights rook takes knight
takes c5 is actually even better for
white probably not winning but better
oops so you don't have these tricks
available the knight is pretty kind and
piece in this in this kind of position
this king doesn't have that many squares
i understand you want to play the move
c4 it doesn't work out ali ressa i don't
think has played this amazing uh by any
stretch of the image imagination i think
fabi is closer to a draw than alireza is
to a win wonderful and yes sir yes
another small bow down to you no no
remember how few like two three minutes
to go you were saying hi you wish that
knight came to d5 in this game yes he
listened
he checked again and went down i was
listening to you i was very clever the
knight did get to d5 very good uh
wow um
beautiful beautiful play so what we were
talking about is this knight which is a
thor
on
uh
f5 because it it was hitting a g7 this
bishop patrolling this long diagonal it
the thought crosses your mind
that if you could drive this bishop this
dark square bishop away from the long
diagonal then you could take over with
bishop d4
alejandro with understanding thumping
the table rook d7 pick up the pawn then
figure out what you want to do next i
like this maneuver a lot just
kick this bishop off this diagonal you
really don't want to play
bishop to f6 i could take that bishop
and go bishop to d4
again positional overkill all of white's
pieces doing more than their
counterparts and if this bishop is
driven away well you can just see how
wonderful this is going to be for white
black is going to get himself
all tied up in all kinds of knots and
f4 f5 is going to win the game well um
knockout did play we should be too to
keep the bishop in that diagonal right i
was going to tickle it some more
another no no no no no that one is easy
that one
but it was just perfect timing while
you're saying you're trying to make the
movie and there we go
the problem is the the the e5 square is
a landmine you're just walking into f3
f4
and uh losing a piece so that's why
uh the bishop has to go to c1 c1 this
horrible square
and then again
many things but i think the simplest is
just to redirect the energy
towards the g7 pawn and that should be
all she wrote
uh
i'm a little surprised that fabi
is getting away with what we thought was
[Music]
it's getting i mean is this an
indication that
ali reza really needs to improve his
technique uh his endgame because
he was doing really good uh
ten moves ago
i mean for me i just feel like there's a
checked out of this tournament a few
rounds ago and he already did a few g4
g5
suicidal attempts
and i mean it's really hard to
get yourself that that motivation that
you're like you're literally fighting
for
nothing you know you had everybody had
so much hopes and dreams and i believe
even another mention that these younger
younger participants really um expected
too much from themselves right and you
know it's just really hard to come back
from that when you feel like every this
this is my year i'm the i'm the number
two in the world i've crossed an 800
even magnus wants to play with me right
and then you go to candidates and
exactly well uh
vishy he himself said that
look
um somebody like ali reza he comes into
this tournament he wants to just impose
his will of course on the tournament
like i will win it by the by the very
dint
of effort of you know the fact that yeah
it's my birthright and i'm going to win
it because i i understand chess
that's not the way it works says uh
vishy you know you come to the event you
discover your form
are you calculating well are you playing
confidently
what is your opposition doing and uh
you play your way into the event
and uh well that was that was the voice
of experience i mean certainly vishy has
played
a lot of you know the
other factors not just how good you're
in chess
there's so much psychological factor
environmental factor
physiological factors you're training
you're wrong
so many things yeah
your mental state
and
and how bad is the hikaru game alejandro
is it is it uh
are we throwing it are we reaching for
the towel and throwing it in i think so
this bishop e3 move looks like a
clincher to me because look at that
bishop on a3 it's strides
it's just trapped right okay
yep that picks up a bishop yeah i could
take on g5 if i felt like it but this
bishop has no moves whatsoever right now
the engine recommended knight takes e4
trust me knight takes e4 is not
happening
uh we do have some moves i think okay
update me i don't know i'm not sure what
to say
no it's not i apologize bishop e3 was it
was indeed
the last move bishop c5 to e3 just
exactly what you said
and it looks i'm seeing a very forlorn
hikaru looking to the side shaking his
head i mean this one's over he knows
it's
if you don't mind i mean
hikaru has had just an incredible
rollercoaster ride in this event could
we give that line score again because
every win
seemed like he was pulling
the tusk out of a rhino and every loss
was like this long lengthy painful
losses i mean
he's had a very very difficult
tournament and here it is he
he lost this game against bobby to start
he came back with an incredible i want
to say a superhuman grind
against timor
where he righted the ships he's 50
percent he finishes the first half with
50
then he goes oh he resigned and he
there it is shaking hands uh a win loss
win win loss what a crazy tournament it
has been for hikaru it seems like he
came back from the tournament after
people gave him a game
when he lost to favia a lot of people
said yeah streamer
then he came back with a win against
rajabov a great didn't finish the sec
the first half saying i'm a favorite
but important game for him to keep his
chances beats fabi exactly huge
congratulations to dingleroon for being
the runner-up of this tournament
absolutely
yeah ding also with four wins
out of the last five games including a
total collapse and disaster in the last
round against timor rajab right but he
finishes in seoul second it might mean
something we don't know that yet right
but if for some reason the negotiations
between fiji and magnus fail
guess who
i guess who this is the man chinese
superstar dingle ren is second place in
the candidates nothing that can be done
about that fabiano even if he wins and
he's not going to can't catch him and
that's the only game that's remaining
eight points for ding lorenz starting
with the loss with white against
janupomnyachi it almost felt that
everybody wrote him off of the
tournament and take a look
alejandro you did not write him off the
turtle i have a choice you were loyal
just putting it up there every every
round you are loyal to a fault there
even when we were all you know chiding
you and laughing and uh making fun of
you and joking what a i didn't say it's
a long tournament
tournament it has been i'm drained andre
i am very much looking forward to this
tournament ending it's been fun it's
been exciting but you can see it in the
players moves everybody's tired yeah and
by the way dorset
i did want to get this in you were
recruited at the last minute you came in
and you were terrific no seriously
on behalf of alejandro who won't like
you saying this you did really
production team thank you thank you it's
been it's been a wonderful event and you
know especially since i'm starting med
school
actually in less than four weeks
scary it's very scary i'm moving over
the weekend
so it
yes yes so it's been a wonderful i had a
wonderful time being here i look forward
to
being around saint louis as much as
possible and i've always watched you
mm-hmm it was a pleasure working with
you well thank you so
enough oh yeah get out of here get out
of here
we're jaded with him but um we're going
to jump over to madrid as anastasia
caught up with our tournament winner and
now challenger nepo
[Music]
yan so you didn't manage to spoil the
party today but at some point it looked
a little bit scary what about you
uh
well i have some wonderful
uh analyst in my team here who came up
with this a5 rookie six idea like very
very nice and uh i think
i mean the only drawback if you didn't
repeat this like uh
the morning you play the game yeah uh
you could find yourself in trouble but
uh
okay i just
i i could barely remember what's like uh
what are my moves but i thought like
okay five rookie six and then okay what
happens happens yeah
uh but somehow i think what he did is
quite natural and it's it somehow leads
to some
you know a bunch of forced draws but
uh
i only like i have to help but i want
i won't mix up everything
yes so at the end of the day plus five i
mean now it's time finally to enjoy now
it's time and indeed now it's time to do
so what are the class for the evening
uh i won't tell you
okay
but we will probably see something from
social media and actually yeah yeah i
realize you don't have time to rest and
the grandchild story will start very
very soon so are you going to play and
what are your plans we are going to meet
magnus also uh
i have no idea if he's playing there
yeah uh
okay then i was good
uh
well i hope hopefully as far as i
remember it's not starting tomorrow yes
i'll have
i don't know about 10 days break
and
yeah like
you know exhale a little bit
and uh i will see but
yeah i'm looking forward to finally you
know some some guess without some
huge pressure what what are you going to
do now this will be
believe are you going to go back to
russia or you will stay here for some
time
no i think i already like had quite a
long journey like for the last couple of
months yeah so
a lot of chess a lot of work a lot of
journeys so yeah i guess it's time to go
home and
yeah
have some rest thank you very much
thank you
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
2022 candidates tournament the
one tournament that has been impossible
to predict
nepo
goes through undefeated drawing today
against duda to
make
one of the most formidable
career highlights of his illustrious
career as he becomes challenger to
magnus carlson dingler in
wins a grind against hikaru nakamura to
surprisingly steal second place all by
himself
hikaru falls into a tie for third with
timon
what the heck timor the happy recipient
of a full point against richie rapport
with one game remaining fabiano versus
alireza actually this is a double-edged
super sharp position
and i've been i've been thinking about
the position waiting for us to return
and i'm thinking right here right now
there is a chance with the move rook g4
so what i want to do i want to play
check
and then when the king is driven
backwards i want to play another check
so that i can attack the bishop and when
the king is driven backwards once more i
want to take that pawn i like that idea
and i feel like
fobby could be closing in on a draw with
the move rook g4 am i completely off the
the
off track oops i guess i was um with
this move rook g4 alejandro gotta let
the commentators play the players
because you're right yasser and fabi is
still played a good move but not the
best rook g4 you're absolutely correct
was the best way to draw if you go c4
you still have other opportunities but
c4 is the
good enough clean yeah you go here if
you go king e5 you just give another
check clear so importantly that you
still get dragged back into the sixth
rank so it doesn't really matter where
you start with this
check here check you can start here it
doesn't really matter you if you
eventually hide on the a6 square right
you go knight c1 hold on to a2 it looks
a bit scary for a second but you're
running out of pawns exactly and once i
get my rook to g2 and cover a2 no real
problems that king is penetrating on a5
a3 king a4 so it does look a little bit
scary for the moment but no problems the
agents say this is zeros knight d2
played instead
i guess we keep going around uh this
does prevent the move c4 it allows white
to put the knight on c4 and keep
attacking that pawn the edges don't
think this was the cleanest way to draw
but still think that black does not have
a decisive advantage
wow it seems like every round we're
confounded by the results
and the two decisive games out of three
that we've already witnessed we thought
it was going to go three out of four
actually
it's been so hard uh predicting the
results uh
and i didn't see hikaru losing out of
this opening what did he do for those
in our audience who are joining us later
where did it all go wrong alejandro for
hikaru
uh
i guess it was all the way back here
yeah sir
let me pull that game out and the
correct move
a little bit further because because at
these points we were really just
thinking draw even at this point where
we still think that he should have
repeated right we thought that in this
position if you play the accurate move
rook d8 the end game does look a bit
scary after takes takes bishop dx knight
c5 but you can calculate it out to a
draw it's not actually that hard because
in many variations this knight on f6
will pick up h5 more or less for free so
this was the crack move rook d8 the rook
trade is not dangerous and if you move
the rook somewhere else rook d3 skewers
this knight on b3 and the pawn on a3 and
again black is fine in this case more
than fine so king f1 threatening king e2
the correct response was rook d8 in this
position after the move bishop d8
leaving this rook on the seventh rank
this is where it all went wrong for uh
hikaru the move rugby 7 was very good
prevented a5 type of breaks and the rook
is just doing a wonderful job at cutting
the king at attacking this weak pawn on
g7 that's now tethered to g7 because of
this structure and it just became worse
and worse and worse from hikaru starting
in this position
and the chinese superstar ding loren
goes to ana to claim second now we know
of course
that um
nepo is the challenger full stops within
the story but you also need first
reserve a player that in case either the
champion or the challenger
health problems or otherwise they can't
make it
dingler in is steps in this first
reserve
my apologies i was just doing um
financial calculations
yes financial calculations could we get
the money uh money half a million euros
in prices
seven thousand exactly for each
point uh-huh that the player score so
the first place it gets
plus nine and a half times it's like 66
16 3 67
yeah so it's like 48 plus that
66 and a half 3 6 5 right yeah
114 000 five euros 114 500 that's for
first place payday what about second
seconds 36 he got eight eight times
seven is
you got this
[Laughter]
don't wake me up
when you figured this out dorsa i'm all
yours oh yours yeah
you had me at 96.
but
uh alejandro this is a lot of money
it sounds like a lot of money but uh
tell our audience the the god's honest
truth these players are hiring seconds
they're doing training camps they're
paying
months and months of salary months and
months of expenses
they are lucky if they make anything
from the candidates i think that nepo
makes something from the candidates even
though he has quite a team 114 goes a
long way does go a long way okay i think
ding considering that his seconds are
left back in china you don't have to pay
those all of those costs right uh but
some of these players yeah they pay for
their own seconds and they bring them to
spain they didn't get that much money
right i don't think reza is exactly
making bank out of this tournament right
so there's no like price or the last
place it depends on their points right
no i think there are eight prizes
as well as the points as well
yeah but the the overwriting
yeah it's not that's not true there's
only three prices yeah sir is that right
and it's points only after that however
many points you scored times seven
thousand i thought we were showing only
the first three prizes as a way of
abbreviating the you know
glad you're glad to uh
talk about this in the 14th round
i mean they never really talked about
the money
we didn't talk about fourth prize
we didn't talk about it after the third
place so was i guess i was used to like
u.s championships where maybe the last
player gets six thousand or something
like that and everybody's looking at
uh first second and third so seven times
what is ferocious
getting five points maybe five and a
half so like 35 or draws this one
35 000 euros i mean that that that's
stupid and again but i mean
just for argument's sake yeah
as a trainer it doesn't go a long way i
mean trainers are pretty expensive
because these are accomplished
grandmasters themselves
yeah i mean you're not you're not
throwing them minimum wage per hour
right so
it it
adds up pretty quickly now fida does
cover a lot of the cost of the travel
and accommodation in these tournaments
so they don't have to worry about that
one but that doesn't include
accommodation for seconds it doesn't
include what they're going to be paying
for seconds it doesn't include what it
costs to have a training camp somewhere
the accommodation for that whoever is
cooking the groceries it adds up man
right it doesn't go as far as it used to
35 grand when you're preparing for a
tournament as serious as the candidates
if you imagine that you had two months
of preparation total a couple camps here
a couple of camps there it's not really
unreasonable and you're paying five
people for it you can blow through 35
grand
no problem pretty easy
yeah
wow
uh so there you have it career in
medicine doesn't sound too bad
can we hear medicine
nice but it's
good to see that you're keeping your eye
on the ball i mean you know i mean
you
need to i need to keep these uh chess
players in check you know make sure that
they don't
over spend the budget
we do have c6 c5 on the board after
a few moves of play just a second let's
go back to where we are
right here the rochefort would have been
wonderful but what no that didn't happen
it would have been great i've got the
wrong position on my board we have
we have pardon me we have c5 knight d2
bishop c7 kingy
rook
over on the board and bring us up to
date alejandro uh
i still want to eat that g7 pawn yeah i
do too something like rook chief
yeah rook g4 looks forced i don't see
another move but you can't you can't
play this passively right right rook h4
i'm i'm worried that the king might
somehow
uh get over to b5 and advance the pawn
so i was thinking rook g4 i also just
realized if okay sure there's pawn g5
haha
even
that's a little bit embarrassing too
like oops yeah um so what what would be
the
expected
uh variations after rook g4 alejandra
rook g4 is the star rook takes h5 i
don't think there's anything else
logical the problem with bishop e5 in
this position trying to hold on to the
pawn yeah is that i simply pin it and
you don't have a good way out of this uh
knight c4 knight f3 i don't know why i
said knight c4 c4 or knight f3 is a good
move depending on where you put the king
on tap yeah so you don't really want to
pin yourself you probably want to take
immediately okay work takes and then you
got to figure out how to push that pawn
on the a file not so easy just yet for
example if you uh because the bishop is
hanging if you put the bishop on e5
which i think is the most logical move
you attack this rook and the pawn you
have to reckon with check rook here rook
d3 is the only way to defend but the
engines are thinking it's sufficient for
white you'll be able to
pretty much
get the king in front of the pawn just
in time
when this k when this pawn starts
running so for example a move like a4 in
this position re knight c4 it stifles it
just about enough this pump can't go
forward uh because the knight just takes
it and
it barely holds on
but it holds on for a while you do have
to find rook g4 though there's no other
move in this position
that i can see because otherwise you
just lose h5 for free right right a
little bit
is there anything else
maybe knight b3 try to pick up the pawn
a pawn yeah but it would be a bit weird
at least in my view to try to pick up
that pawn
instead of g7 i agree especially because
that one can stop running i might even
be be winning a rook ending suddenly
because i've got an active rook and an
active king
knight b3 rook takes h5 knight takes a5
take it
go king c4 and
you might be picking up c3 well we can
take a look at your board babies okay
sure
so
just
again
we're at the current position after the
move rook h8 we think rook
was played yes yeah not uh not a big
surprise i think
it's been a long tournament yeah a
little worried that knight takes b
knight b3 takes a5 might run into
something like this
where suddenly oh i see the um the table
base just kind of it's going losing yeah
it's losing dead dead
so rook g4 as you were saying alejandro
forced and not surprising uh there is a
took on his fine that happened quickly
yeah not a lot of choices either i think
yeah
right uh-huh and i'm hoping fabi will
take immediately i'm sure he will you
could throw in c4 i think that's the
main difference that c4 is still okay
c4 check right you want to play c4
before you take because the king doesn't
have d4 yes and that way the king has to
be dragged back and this might also be
okay for bla for white
it's funny to me uh to play the move c4
because i'm thinking with rook takes g7
i'm actually gaining a tempo against the
bishop that's true and to push the king
back to a position where it will defend
the bishop like i'm doing
myself a disservice i feel uh rook takes
g7 i think i would be
johnny
johnny quick
to get that move in
and also
maybe in a position
i'll just put some moves on the board
forgive me for just a moment maybe in a
position something like this
i might find it useful
to own the c4 square and not to give the
bishop
necessarily the d4 square so i i would
be more tempted to keep
the pawn on c3 we'll see if it makes a
huge difference
again i saw
there in your on your evaluation it was
less than a pawn less than a pawn which
means that this is close to a draw if
played properly but right still work to
be done by white and not
not a lot of
time left there's not that many moves
left to move 60 so we're going to have a
ton of time for both players remember
they get 15 minutes
both
uh on move 60 and the increments start
sticking yeah as we get ready to close
out our broadcast a few things that we'd
really really love to shout out first of
all a big thanks to the saint louis
chess club for their hosting
of ourselves and making our life so
comfortable and uh so very helpful so a
big big shout out to all the staff
at the st louis chess club and
scholastic center
thank you for all that you do our
production team
yes tom's a pain in the you-know-where
but the rest of the people are really
really nice
including our friend
well we forgot him anyway
no we have a wonderful time with the
production team and it's tough because
we have been coming in very very early
in the morning st louis time
and tyler and the people on set here
they just make
our lives nick tyler finn uh
much much much happier to yourselves it
was great to our colleague
uh
my other coach var varusia
who keeps us on our toes as well uh
thank you to each and every one of you
it really really is great
and mostly
thank you to rex and genie uh rex and
judy singfield for uh well sponsoring
all the things that the wonderful st
louis chess club and the world chess
hall of fame does for the city for uh
the community
and
for the players
we have a summer of chess
dead ahead
we've got a few days a break before we
bring you the u.s juniors the u.s girls
and the u.s senior championship starting
july 7th
and then we're going to have the
granches tour back again
the super the united rapids yeah
and zagreb with magnus and alejandra
whoa whoa you had me at magnus
you didn't have to throw in alejandra
and then alejandro and most other
players are going to go to chennai that
is not us related but we'll keep an eye
on it the olympiad finally we'll be back
in saint louis for the rapid emblets
well saint louis rapid ambulance for
branches tour in second half of august
followed by wow pretty much immediately
the sinkfield cup again and saint louis
absolutely and even following the sim
singfel cup i do believe we have a chess
9lx or a chess 960 the bobby fischer
version and i can assure you there's
going to be the who's who of chess
for the bobby fischer as well so we've
had a very very big busy summer i was
just going to say i've heard rumors who
sparked might be playing that i don't
know anything i just said i'm just
saying rumors i don't know anything
i just i just
it's always nice when when he throws his
hat into the right yeah yeah buzz
were you around here for that alejandro
so that there's this great story so the
idea is you've got the bobby fischer
position but before the round begins
they draw the position
and then they say okay guys you know you
got 15 minutes go prepare yourselves
you've got this new position
so somehow birds of a feather flock
together and
there was our friend peter svidler
working
with gary kasparov over the positions
right and struggling
so they're that they're prepping one
another for the game
and i think
it was
who
i forget exactly who was walking by and
and they said
peter you got the wrong position that's
not the bobby fischer position
and they had been looking at the wrong
position
he was like furious because peter was
the one who had gone and got the
position it was pretty funny i uh
we enjoyed that
i wish there was a clip of that song i'm
sure there is a clip somewhere wow
well
they've reached exactly the position we
kind of predicted they would
and uh
eat the pawn it feels like white is far
closer to making a draw now that the
position's so reduced oops that's our
analysis gosh darn it that's not the
line
this is the life position sorry
yeah this is where i was trying to bring
the rook back i mean i'm assuming this
would go on because bishop e5 feels like
a national name can't imagine not
playing bishop e5 right yeah rook d7
also kind of kind of forced because c4
can d4
feeling very very nice yeah natural
light so
bishop b5 rook d7 king 663 it all feels
quite natural
so i'm just
waiting for the players
and then uh
again if we can get our king
nicely over to uh stop the a-pawn that
would be
that would be it um
alejandro something to share with our
audience i'm being told that we have a
cool little graphic of how everybody did
in this tournament let's take a look at
what the producers have prepared for us
check it out that's their position in
the event throughout oh man that is that
looks like that's right that is a red
line
yeah that i love it that was like a
ceiling and
some statistical improbability everybody
kind of tiptoeing around but
there are some clear things there are
some clear things
this awful
awful green line
that just kind of disappears in the
second half stands out but the red line
for me that is the ceiling
the ceiling the ceiling yeah incredible
it never moved it never moved nepo
from literally uh start to finish was in
the lead
yeah and actually he car didn't change
that much he was tied for third after
second round
uh with 50
and you just kind of stayed near the top
but
there's some curves and bends and uh
broken lines there in that blue
from uh
from nakamura and a graphic artist was
stephen matica
wonderful a big shout out to steve for
making such a colorful graphic i have to
say this still reminds me of metro's
metro lines that you're looking at right
the london subway right thank you i was
just thinking about that
that subway is confusing i'm gonna
luster so much
i was shocked the very first time i ever
went on the moscow subway by the way i i
really i was used to the new new york
city subway uh graffiti and everything
and the moscow subway was a museum it's
so long there was statues everywhere no
it was just amazing uh but uh yeah the
the london the the the london tube
uh system
uh they still time's not a factor when
are they going to make their second time
control are we there yet
king c6 i mean not not i don't think
it's going to change anything about the
position
but king c6 kind of
makes you wonder can i just go knight c4
and knight tackle your pawn a little
king d3 all
anything that's getting close to the a
pawn so you can kind of
block it up
would certainly get my uh stamina yes
stamp of approval usda staffer for
approval
so alejandro what's your stamp it's so
close to a draw now for favi the
material is so reduced the only plan is
to pass this pawn
but it's not going to happen
yeah i think d3 is fine when you were
mentioning c4 i'm not so sure about
knight c4 seems to be the cleanest
according to the engines okay because
you just don't pass through the fifth
rank you go king b5 and
rook takes a seven alright that loses
but
rook g4 is cool because knight e3 check
will bounce your king back
right away
and that's it
there's really not that much more to
consider in this position no progress no
progress to be made so fabi very close
to a draw i think if he finds a move
knight c6 king d3 always looks
completely fine to me i the game is
close to a draw no matter what five he
plays okay you know what i'm gonna do
i'm just gonna keep an eye
for on their hands ready for them
they're still thinking i mean
it's so hard because
i feel like fobby had a an edge earlier
way way before before the queens got
traded but then uh ali rizzo was just
advantageous
and then
it's just man it's been a long two weeks
it's truly uh also i just did want to
get once more another shout out in with
anastasia she is
she's catching the players at various
moments she caught up with magnus
carlsen
had a very short what are you going to
do i'll let you know and out he ducks
did you know that gotten like 350 000
views
in under 24 hours i mean that that
interview with magnus went viral and he
said nothing nice i mean when the world
champion says we'll see
we will see we will see
we will see that's all he said
um and
of course as always a big shout out to
you our audiences uh thank you for
joining us sharing your days with us
thank you more for your questions and
being
a part of our discussions uh sometimes
these broadcasts have lasted a long time
and it's your
uh questions that are kept is on our
toes and forced us to think and
recalibrate our thoughts so thank you uh
one and all and again you know who you
are i can't call out names
yeah i've been trying to um scroll
through some of the youtube the
live chat yeah and yeah it's nice i see
a lot of uh wonderful questions a lot of
support a lot of just everybody loves
your stories oh yeah right
i mean
the oldies but the goodies um
boy i was gonna say uh
now that we're coming to the end it's
really kind of uh sinking in that you
know i'm not gonna have to wake up at
five o'clock in the morning tomorrow
this is good this is a good thing
everybody i mean you know there's a
celebration
uh to be had here uh remind me when does
junior start
when is my the junior year commentary
starts the seventh i believe okay so you
guys get like three two three though
he's actually giving us a little slack i
mean i don't know
about you alejandro
what are your plans for this fourth of
july how are you going to celebrate
america's independence day i am going to
go sleep
face plant
the floor is looking very cozy
i mean nice carpet around
i think it'll hold
right
this one is the one we're just finally
waiting for and it feels like the curse
of some of these tournaments right that
you have these super long games in the
final round and usually they're not the
one that is meant for very much king d3
finally played by fabi after a
five-minute thing
i can't imagine already winning this
right
it's just so the material is so reduced
is there a trick could he go like rook
shack king seats
rook h3 i beg your pardon king c2 rook
takes
c3 check yes hey yay i went upon
that's very good yes you see my tactics
yes and unfortunately my sharp keen
tactical eye and unfortunately knight b3
picks up not one but both bonds
but
look all i can say is i won
i won one pawn i mean you know right
true right yeah it doesn't actually work
so check king both king c4 and king c2
are completely fine probably king c4 is
a little easier yes but it doesn't it
doesn't matter if the king gets in front
of the pawn
we're in a magical world as white as
his eyes
as light i choose to give up my rook
for your bishop and both of your pawns
are we still good rook knight rook
versus night versus night well can i get
work versus night i know it's the
seventh hour of commentary but root
versus night is a draw yes no no no no i
was i was trying to be hopeful in a
magical world that i can push pawn but
never mind scratch that can we keep
going
any any any danger anywhere
for anyone
well i mean blacks up a pawn so there's
some danger for white but it's not it's
not very serious at this level
uh as we came into today's game uh we
talked about the importance of being the
first reserve and or possibly
getting into the world championship
itself
magnus
for many years
many years
really i'm going to go back i'm going to
say at least for five probably more
years
has
made it very clear he doesn't like the
feed a cycle
and he had intimated that he wouldn't be
playing
the winner of this
candidate's tournament unless he got
somebody he was facing a challenger he'd
never faced before
which raised the question that if he
stepped down
then
whoever one second now again our
congratulations to dingler in his name
is known
dingleran would play nepo
and then the question as we came on the
show we got a broadcast question from
our audience what do you know
about
the world championship situation
well we know that arkady dorkovich uh
the president and the fiji had a
conversation lasted some 30 minutes with
magnus he also magnus spoke to emil
sutovsky
fide executive and
we
think that magnus has agreed to play in
the world championship 2023
under the provisio that the fidei take
it very seriously to change the format
for the world championship to something
like
four rapid games or game 15 plus 10
seconds per day
and you do that for x number of days and
that would be the most radical
revamping of the world championship
in forever
that was a lot of conjecture but there
is a lot of conjecture there was nothing
talked about anything about sets or
rapid or this is a lot of conjecture yes
sir i think that was actually
we don't know what they talked about the
only thing that we know is that we
know that carlson is scheduled to play
nepogniachi what they will play in we
don't know we don't know what magnus plo
talked about with our caddy we only know
what his preferences are
we also know that he would like to
include more time controls but whether
it's a set it's not a set we have no
idea
and he has to decide by july 20th
july 20th 20th is his deadline so he's
got actually very easily two weeks yeah
and i don't think it should be any
longer well well it's a match that's
taking place
taking place in 2023 yeah but you you
want to know who's playing
negotiations no if you want to sponsor
you don't want to go up to a sponsor of
a tournament be like maybe magnus maybe
some other guy no you need to know have
the players ready you have to make sure
that magnus has to commit so that they
can go out and find a venue it's very
different for a country or a big
corporation that's going to sponsor
something say hey it's going to be
magnus carlsen or hey it's going to be
dean loren they might prefer one over
the other depending on where they're
from or what corporation it is but they
want to know right they don't want to
have this maybes i think it's important
that you get magnus's signature on it or
off in one way or the other
well i hope negotiations you know pan
out in the next two weeks then but one
thing that's um it was mentioned earlier
too when we had the interview with
jonathan testo he did i asked i think we
asked that's you know what do you think
would be magnus's preference what does
he want
and he did say that uh
you know the what he's doing in his own
online tournaments
exactly the magnus carlson tour that
would be his ideal
so we're that's ideal format yeah so
that's kind of where um
we're gonna see what can he negotiate
okay
uh but that's what we know and more
details will be announced shortly uh is
that right though i mean i'm even going
to have to press tom on this one but the
idea is if we go back to 2013 and this
remarkable
candidates tournament that took place in
london
and the both
kramnik and magnus the tournament
leaders lost the final round game magnus
wins becomes a challenger
uh based on sonnenberg burger
and then when magnus won in london he
came to saint louis months later and it
was in st louis that he actually signed
the contract to play vichy in chennai
but it seemed to me that there was a gap
of several months
and they they even though that the
feeder was putting the match up for bid
uh i didn't
think that the
the candidates and the champion had to
make a decision
so rapidly um
tom
no i think i agree with you i don't
remember it being so soon after right
july 20th sounds like it sounds like
right now
right now right here candidates is over
go sign your stuff yeah i i don't blame
them though like what
no no that makes sense of course
yeah and it was i'm being told that uh
emil
the ceo of fide i'd say exactly the one
that said we'll change it but you need
to let us know you need to confirm with
us on july 20th that you're committed to
the system that you're not going to
change the system and then back out
anyway so it's special circumstances
feed is being a little bit more pushy
and i totally get why because when
magnus makes all of this ostentatious
remarks that perhaps i won't play
fetus worried about their crown jewel
not being so polished anymore right
right so perhaps they will acquiesce to
a few changes but i don't think they
will be very happy if magnus drags this
on
there's a very very very good very very
good point i mean no seriously that
again if i was in fide shoes i would
like to press the point it is a two
million euro match
uh that they're requesting from the
sponsors and that's just the prize fund
that doesn't
impact all of the rest the actual venue
the opening ceremony and i know that
some of those opening and closing
ceremonies of the feed day
have been
pretty glamorous affairs uh big budget
affairs let's say so yeah i can imagine
i understand the the fide pressing uh
the point and um okay uh personally
personally
i love to see magnus play cool stuff of
course especially i want i'm a fanboy i
want him to go i want him to play i
definitely want to see another like a
rematch from that world championship
that i feel like nepal was just not
there he played the first half
so it would be great if we can see
nepo gets another chance
but you know the negotiations are not
that not that easy
it's a lot of
yeah
yeah uh jump in uh
and by the way as we are winding down
our show now's the last time last chance
to get in your social media questions
for dorsa alejandro myself
as uh we get ready to wind up but the
summer of chess continues we've got so
much chess ahead it's just sort of like
we're going to be going from one event
to another to another oh i'm off to med
school yeah you're often let's go i get
that wow
um just tell me where you
have your residency right yes you get
your doctrine
alejandro is going to be a favorite
patient i'm going to make sure that i
don't know i've been considering women's
health that might not work
well
sorry about that
it's like so far ahead but it's kind of
funny i'm looking and i'm like oh
that's like i
i will finish i will start my residency
everything goes right in four years
and i'm like but i've already been in
saint louis for five years so
you know it's like kind of scary just
looking so nine years um i stretched out
my undergrad a little because i wanted
to take only one class my last semester
very good
i mean from
from from the time you stepped foot into
university college college university
how many more years will it take you to
get your medical degree it's four years
for undergrad and four years for medical
school then that's at least three years
60th move it's the new time control but
it seems like the engines absolutely
hate the previous move oh
fabi i guess it's not difficult to
understand that check e4
check is coming check is played already
by alireza i didn't think too much about
that one
and what does favi want to do exactly
let me figure it out let me see what he
blundered first of all
because king up
king down or up or down this way don't
make any sense you go this way i think
right clear but if you go this way
rookie three okay that's not hard
rook e
three yeah okay you just lose a point
that doesn't make sense oh dear so i
guess you go up no if you go up to c4
then rookie no okay
sorry
here oh oh don't tell me it's going to
be a lost
if you take on c5 i take on c3 is your
king trapped no it's just a draw oh can
they say four is a draw okay the problem
is
this
here not not
not uh rookie three right right now i
have to go king d3 no choice then c4
king only to e3 because otherwise you
lose the knight in this case you don't
pick up the pawn clear so king e3 and
now i keep checking you
king d2 and a3
now let's see the engine's saying this
is oh yeah this is lost loss right
because the pawn gets to a2
rook a7 a2 okay i can even kick you out
first a2 wins
rook h4 says a little more more accurate
king d3 more accurate as well
it's just lost apparently oh dear
well you do that yeah king g5 is just
lost king d5 is just lost you kick out
the knight and you just take this right
clear that's not hard that's not hard
it's not hard at all and flubby knows
it's his face oh he's shaking his head
he looks ill
fabi fabi fabi what a collapse
this is just like a summary of the
tournament
oh my god move 60 and
prior to this move 94 we were looking at
king c2 i think we were looking at nice
nice c4 was fine king c2 was fine most
moves were fine i think it hasn't been
like b1 a3
b1 is the top engine
knight b1 just stopping just stop it
just stop fit yeah like don't let it go
anywhere and uh all of those were
just
close to
a draw yes and instead knight e4 and it
goes
minus three i i i think in minus three
because my engine is not stronger but
i think a stronger engine at this point
must be looking at this as a completely
wrong game
just as cruel this is cruel you you have
a six hour game you've been struggling
and for those viewers that are still
here with us this is why we go the
distance this is why we stay here
on a seven hour game
that might be 99 chance draw right
because one percent
tends to happen pretty often this one
percent chance tends to be more like a
20 chance yeah get rid of that 99 score
it seems to me every time we get into
one of these things it's closer to 20
or even 25
that some massive you know like howl or
tiredness absolutely tiredness creeping
in
it's just fabi
everything everything's going wrong for
him everything going wrong all the way
till the end
is looking disconsolate i bet he cannot
wait to get out i was gonna say wait to
get out of madrid but he his place is in
madrid
wow and he just really looks like he is
just
suffering i mean
i don't i don't even have to look at his
face you can see the position yeah
wow dorsey i mean how do you console
somebody who's just had this
that's why i'm going to medicine
crash
there's a
there's a dutch joke that goes like that
it's just
pretty sad so um
discount man he goes into the park and
angel appears and says
that the man is crying and
the angel appears and says you know what
is it he says well i've lost my job
oh says the angel that's terrible that's
really bad news but maybe maybe
this is an opportunity for you to find a
better job
oh says the man yeah yeah yeah you've
got a good point there maybe i i i feel
better
who are you i'm the angel of the park
i'm here to help people oh okay says
the man and off he leaves and next day
another man
this time he has a problem with his
partner relationship oh
but you know
maybe this is good for you it gives you
a chance to
refresh your life and so on then comes
the chess player oh god says why are you
so upset he said well i've lost my final
round position it was a completely drawn
game
i had no problems making the draw and i
have blundered
the last move at the time control
yeah
the angel starts crying
nothing else
that's it that's it you know it's just
that bad and we have king d2 on the
board
uh alejandro and that this is the a3 a2
variation i think you were pointing out
this is very easy even king d5 he just
made a move yeah
out of all the possibilities king d2 is
the worst
really of course i mean king d5 you pick
up with chuck with the bishop on c3
it rained his reigns it pours and then
yeah this is the one that gives the
least resistance nothing wrong with the
move a3 just push them baby right
but king d5 no i i i'll take the pawn
with check any day yeah i think so right
king d5 such an easy move to make you
can't defend the night this game is over
wow
uh yeah crickets sometimes you just i
mean today could not go worse for team
america team usa you sit down in the
last round of the candidates you got
your flags independence day you think
hicario and fabi you know they they're
going to get second second and third
nope
nope chess is cruel
and today proves it favi losing
white cards it must be one yeah but for
favi i think it's gonna be one of the
most painful tournaments
ever he didn't win a single game in the
second half of the tournament after
going plus three which which fabiano
carl i understand he's had disasters
probably side disasters before we've
seen it but in which sermon does he go
from plus three
no never recall anything like that you
know he's finishing on minus one off
he goes minus four and then he goes
minus four he loses four games and draws
three in the last seven
that feels painful ouch
wow wow i mean
i still bought
it's time you always have to go back be
with fabi at all times
and this is his line score so far you
can see his goose eggs 8 10 and 11.
and he's gonna add another one in 14.
that's uh that's four losses
wow tale of two tournaments totally
different tournaments right favi a fabio
b
yeah ever since we had sam shanklin on
the show and sam was talking about
um
nepo a being maybe the second best
player
on the planet and napo b maybe
not so good but this was
i i mean
people usually have good tournaments and
bad tournaments but the bad tournaments
you know start badly they finish badly
that's it i can't recall anybody having
such a great start plus three and then
crashing lavon so badly that was right
that was london 2013. 2013 was something
similar right started looking fantastic
no i think you're right evie started the
first half plus three and he completely
faded
it became the magnus kramnik show in the
second half
yeah
um we're exasperated
yeah
i don't know what to say
well
i would love to hear your stories but
i'm after the blunder i don't even know
what to ask exactly we're expecting
bishop takes c3 check of course we
understand the rook is hanging but
bishop takes c3 comes with check after
the king moves the rook just
gets itself out of danger
your next move is going to be posting up
bishop to d4 dominating position and
suddenly it's two pawns and all of the
pieces are working for black
and white's busted that one actually
even won two rounds in the last seven
did he really yeah he won round 10 and
he beat timor in the last round in an
irrelevant game oh my gosh so how did he
end up actually finishing he's starting
with plus well plus three for the first
half i mean i think he finished on blah
blah blah plus
two
i'll look it up properly but it's either
plus one or plus two
which is an absolute disaster no not at
all no no this is a disaster that's
minus one is a disaster right
all right all right yeah sorry i think
we need a happy happy story happy story
happy memory
[Laughter]
yeah look at that uh line score there i
mean i don't want a tale of two halves
yeah i don't want to look at it yeah
story i actually had to say it was a
kind of a a funny story it was a world
junior championship in skin in norway
okay uh the home of magnus carlson
norway
and uh it was the last round and i
needed a draw okay to make the gold
medal please happy story happy story
happy stuff all right i need and i was
playing gentleman jim plaskett
grandmaster from the uk
and i was black we played like 20 moves
some standard isolated queen pond
position and i offered to draw
and jim
like dismissed the draw offer is like
don't be insulting to my person he
didn't say that he said it in another
way it was like
no way
something along those lines okay
so we're playing the game gets really
intense
and my second john donaldson goes for a
run like because the tension in the
playing hall was just too much
so he goes for a run
and then jim
comes back and says okay yasser i offer
a draw
and i don't know why i did it
i said
make your move first because that was
the rule make your move first and i'll
consider it
so jim went back
and went into like a 20-minute tank
by which time john has finished his run
nice and the rumor in the playing hall
is yasser declined to draw but you
didn't i didn't
but that was the rumor and all i needed
was a draw for the gold medal so i'm
walking around and john comes to me and
grabs me by the throat and that kid he
grabbed me by the throat
said yes sir did you decline a draw i
said no i didn't i sold jim jamaica's
move and if he blunders his queen i'm
going to accept
you very good
go get to go get the take the draw
what was that what's the rule like in
that situation let's say opponent has
offered a draw right and then you you
haven't declined but you're saying make
your move make your move and i'll
consider it that's the rule in that case
what can upon change his mind no
once offered it stands until your
opponent makes a move right all right so
if i offer a draw it doesn't matter if
i've made a move or not
when i make the move it doesn't change
anything either the offer is rescinded
when the opponent
makes
their move yeah that's when it stops so
in this case regardless of whatever
opponent did it's they've already made
they already said it so it's fine
right now it's up to you to make your
move depending on their move or accept
it exactly yeah exactly exactly and you
do you you have had those situations
the blunder of the year award you know
about the blunder of the year award this
was great
so there was a spoof magazine not the
british chess magazine it was unapproved
by the british magazine and the
chess and foreman had the best games the
top 10 games
well in the not the british chess
magazine you had your top 10 blunders of
the wonderful right
and the winner came from australia where
else
in the blunder of the year was
the guy said
would you like a draw
the other gentleman said
make your move first and i'll consider
it and the guy looked into the position
bam
unbelievable
rook sacrifice which would lead to a
second rook sacrifice which leads to
force checkmate
okay the guy forgot about the draw for
resigned
how about you alejandra
what's the blunder of the uh of the
career award i have plenty of those
don't remind me don't remind me are you
kidding me i have a whole collection of
those no but thank you my mood is
slightly impressive
somebody's mood that's not improving
it's funny
this is dead dead i mean it's two extra
fawns we we're just waiting for a
handshake here it's really that bad it's
just just two pawns right so back to you
running out of my uh
blunder of the year awards oh boy oh he
actually took with the rook he actually
he didn't take with the bishop it
doesn't matter yeah i mean he's ready to
go a3
put his bishop on d4 total positional
dominance by the way miss knight also
ah
trickiest thing you've ever done to
opponents it could be a you know like a
draw offer it could be
staring deep into their eyes whatever
you feel it's qualified trickiest
it could be a beautiful sacrifice i'll
leave it completely up to you more or
less it had to be
uh
sealed move related i i'm just not too
sure but the there was so many
strange things that were connected
with
the sealed move now today we don't have
a germans so that entire history
you almost have to explain it to
players
one of my
favorite stories
was a story of akiva rubenstein
and a sealed move so the idea was that
after
a time control say 40 moves in two and a
half hours after five hours of play the
arbiter would give the player an
envelope
and say
you make a secret move you put it in the
envelope
and you're committed to play that move
on resumption
so
that's called
the sealed move
and we just have a move
yeah let me update you guys because i
the game is about i believe to end rook
f5 was played another only has one move
to win in this position not a hard move
he played he found it the move rook g3
why is rook g3 forced because rook five
is running the bishop exactly if i take
the bishop it loses defense of the rook
i'm also threatening knight g4 capturing
the pin bishop i'm also you could say
threatening knight d3 right out of these
one of them is a falsehood knight d3 is
not a threat
rook g3 covers against the problems of
rookie 5 and king takes and it covers
against knight g4 now why is knight d3
not a threat and this is the only
important part of the position right if
knight d3 doesn't exist you resign it's
not very hard to figure out what it is
either you take on d3 you take on d3 and
you pass this pawn oops and it's
important now if you get the pawn to a2
it's not hard to see that it gets to a1
queen that's a queen so the only way to
defend that is to put the rook on the
second you defend this way it's the only
way right but the problem is and also
not very difficult actually somehow
there's more than one move that wins
here but i think c4 is easy to calculate
if the king goes this way
you go secure right and if you go that
way on the second rank anywhere a2 and
a1 that's game so rook g3 played and
that's game exactly knight d3 rook takes
d3
is a clincher absolutely nice finish
nice finish there foreign yes
okay i just finished very quickly
briefly the story
so they present akiva rubenstein you
have to make your sealed move
so then the question is
what would happen if somebody made their
secret move
it was illegal oh what would they do
what would be the punishment
and the answer was that they would be
forced to move their king
on resumption so of course they're in a
king and pawning game i think we have a
result oh my god it's over
well it's over
1-3 a terrible day for team usa guys we
came in with the hopes that usa would
take second and third right let's be
honest we wanted second and third kikaru
clinches second by beating dingleran and
favi wins his own game teamwork doesn't
have a shout because he's black against
rapport so we clinched second and third
and none of that what happened quite the
opposite timor was the one that won his
game favi ends up losing to last place
at the rest i don't know if his last
place after this game and hicario from
what we thought
an opening success
he ends up
wow what what a turnaround day guys but
nothing good for team america tough on
independence day but these are our final
standings
we've been talking about him for two
weeks straight this roof at the top of
the standings not even close guys ten
and a half full one and a
points second from start to finish
start
half
really second place goes to ding loren
timor rajab of anhikar nakamura thai for
third seven and a half points each great
job there for both of these players i
think they weren't
given as favorites for the event
but both team and car finishing on a
nice plus score fabiano falling apart
completely falling apart scoring
half a point of the last five or
something along those lines i think no
he scored one out of five which is still
insane but when you see the sixth
seventh and eighth uh
play
players those were our three rookies
absolutely the rookies just didn't
perform in this tournament lack of
experience
guys it was a pleasure
to cast this with you i have
absolutely thrilled to be able to do the
entire tournament it has been tiring you
want to go with bass players
we want to go
through the players from the eighth to
one to the very laptop go and you get to
start with the eighth player ollie i
actually don't know who finished eighth
now actually that this is not very
surprising richard rapport seventh place
thirty eight thousand five hundred is
what he takes home that includes well
that only includes the points that he
gets
uh times seven remember you get seven
thousand euros for every full point
not a good performance by richard just
too many suicidal ventures at the end of
the day
uh
john kristoff duda the polish champion
coming in with high hopes also time for
seventh he had
one moment in particular where he played
a fabulous fabulous game against fabiano
but otherwise
not a memorable result he'll leave the
tournament
like
uh
richie with experience yes and then we
have on the sixth place my country man
there you go playing for france though
uh eli reza first he was going home with
well i guess a little happy he did with
beat bobby
um with 42 000 euros for six place
and
unfortunately for saint louisians um
fabiano caruana fifth placed
49 000 euros and a lot of other
tournaments to come what to say it
crashes out of plus three after the
first half to a minus one score what on
earth happened to fabi the conjecture is
he ran out of energy he just
maybe played too much whatever
a very very disappointing finish for a
fan favorite of st louis
and well our i guess favorite streamer
our favorite streamer right
uh going home with tight for third place
hikaru nakamura
uh 64 000 euros that's a nice figure
64th right there's something about 64
that i like i don't know why squares
congratulations to hikaru he had a very
very up and down event uh but there was
no question he had a fire and desire uh
throughout a
very very impressive type of wow and the
next uh third place tied for third place
taymor rajable from azerbaijan he did
have the he did bring the warrior
who saw his rights he did not amazing no
last on the second half of the
tournament that's that's pretty
impressive and a plus score at that i
mean he had been languishing in the
cellar for quite some time we had
forgotten about him but boy did he come
back in the second half had tipped to
timor for a fabulous third place
and then we have our clear second place
runner-up
what a rise what a meteoric rise from
a second a first half that just had
everybody saying what happened to
dignity and we expected so much from him
he never fought for first
but clear second is way above
expectations after scoring minus one in
the first
half and dorsa here is our champion um
jan nepomniocci
he is going to play for the
2023 world championship he is our
candidate champion going home with a
whooping
oh
114 and a half
500 euros wow that's a lot of money uh
our congratulations to jan very very
very deserving indeed no it's far far on
superior far way and superior from the
rest of the field
congratulations well done
next
but no i i definitely want to thank
everybody it was my first time with you
yes sir it was wonderful first time in
this very official broadcast thank you
everybody thank you rex and jeannie
thank you this uh the
st louis
city and the chess club
uh thank you the production team var
yasser alejandra thank you everybody
this has been a wonderful
time for me to be here i hope well
with that we enjoyed having you we
really did thank you very much don't be
a stranger uh feel welcome to join us
anytime thank you so much it was really
really nice having you thank you
we're going to take a couple of days off
we're going to see you for the juniors
and seniors coming up i think it would
be unwise of me to leave you hanging
uh if you make an illegal move you had
to move your king
akiva rubenstein is in a very difficult
position he has to move his king one
square is a draw another square is
illegal he sealed an illegal move the
arbiter opened up the scoresheet said
you have to make a king move
you made a king
and it worked out perfectly for him they
changed the rule
so that if you make an illegal move in
the future you lost the game oh thanks
to akiba rubenstein well
there you go that's how our predecessors
played the game thank you everyone thank
you so much for sharing your day with us
goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited